COMMITTEE ON THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE OF. THIS
MEETING WILL NOW COME TO ORDER.
A GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. SENATORS SINCE THEN THE
STAFF. MUST LIMIT THE NONCE
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING HERE AT THE CAPITOL
WITH THE USE OF A VIDEO MEETING
SERVICE. OUR PANELISTS FROM
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY AND BORDER
AFFAIRS ADVOCATES AND ENTITIES
WILL BE PARTICIPATING THROUGH
VIDEO SERVICE IN ADDITION TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS. WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS WILL ALLOW AND
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. FOR ANYONE WHO WILL BE
AT ATTENDED REMOTELY TODAY
PLEASE MOVE YOUR PHONES AND
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN THE ELIMINATING OF ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION YOU SHOULD USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE A
KNOWLEDGE THE SPEAKER POP OF
WILL WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR OUR IT
PANEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION THAT YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FIRST. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL
PROVIDE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AN ACCESS CODE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND IT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AT
THIS MOMENT. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THE TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THEIR HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS. IN A IN AS
CLOSE AS TO THE SAME MANNER IS
JUST CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE USE OF NEW ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN AND THANK
YOU FOR ATTENDING THIS JOINT
HEARING OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. ON CALIFORNIA MEXICO
CORRUPT CORPORATIONS SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ON THE PANDEMIC
MERGED TO RESPONSE DURING THESE
VERY DIFFICULT AN UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS TO DISCUSS THE
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN AND
CALIFORNIA'S BORDER REGION. AND
HOW DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS AND
AGENCIES ARE WORKING IN ORDER
TO MAXIMIZE OUR RESOURCES AND
FURTHER PROTECT THE BORDER
REGION FROM CLOVER NINETEEN.
THIS HEARING WILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
AND ROBUST DISCUSSION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT STATUS
OF OUR BACK BI NATIONAL ECONOMY
AND ITS PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WHAT
THE DIGITAL POLICIES AND
MECHANISMS ARE NECESSARY TO
BETTER ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
BORDER REGION. I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM THE WITNESSES
ABOUT THE DETAILS OF WHAT HAS
BEEN OCCURRING CALIFORNIA'S PER
REGION. AT A WHAT ACTIONS TO
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
DEPARTMENTS HAVE TAKEN. TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS FROM THE
HEALTH INDUSTRY ITSELF AND THE
STEPS THAT THEY ARE TAKING A
FROM THE BORDER REGION AGENCIES
AND ADVOCATES ON WHAT THE NEXT
STEP SHOULD BE. WE WILL ALSO BE
HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC TO
LISTEN TO YOUR COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS. I AM HONORED TO HAVE
MY CALL SELECT MANY HERE TODAY
THEY WILL CHART US SENATE. BEEN
ALAN. HAVE SENATORS BRADFORD.
SENATOR MELISSA OR BATTLE
SENATOR BRIAN JONES SENATOR
CONNIE LEIVA SENATOR SO
INCIDENT RUBIO. SENATOR HENRY
STERN AND SENATORS BOB WILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE ALSO ARE
JOINED BY THE CHAIR. OF THE US
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE- LENA AND
SALAS THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND I WANTED TO. OPEN UP IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
TODAY AND ALSO INTRODUCED
MEMBERS OF YOUR COMMITTEE. SURE
THANK YOU CHAIR WESSEL I
APPRECIATE THE INVITATION TO
JOINTLY HOLD THIS HEARING VERY
IMPORTANT AS A SHARE THE DEEP
CONCERN- ALONG THE CALIFORNIA'S
BORDER REGION AS WELL- IN WHICH
I KNOW YOU REPRESENT- AS JUST
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONTACTS
CONTACTS IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
RESIDENTS WERE TESTING POSITIVE
FOR COVER NINETEEN ALONG THE
BORDER REGION. AND ALL THESE
INCREASES ARE TAKING PLACE ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT REGIONAL VARIATION
ONE OF THE REGION'S HARDEST HIT
OF COURSE IS IMPERIAL COUNTY
FOR WHICH WE ARE HERE TODAY AND
SO THE SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
ON PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE
STANDS READY TO SUPPORT- WE
HOPE TO CLEAN SOME MORE IDEAS
AND- ADDITIONAL ISSUES THAT WE
CAN BRING FOR TO THE COMMITTEE
AND I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING. US TOGETHER TODAY-
AND TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED ARE THE
ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE VICE CHAIR SENATOR PAT
BATES. WE HAVE SENATOR ANDREAS
FORGET BURGESS SENATOR ANNIKA
YET ALL SENATOR BILL DODD
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON
SENATOR BRIAN JONES SENATOR
MIGHT REQUIRE SENATOR RICHARD
PAN SENATOR TOM UMBERG AND
THERE'S WE AT THEM AS WELL THE
IS THE- BUT I'D LIKE TO. YOU IN
THEM AS WELL AND FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT. TO THIS EFFORT AND-
ALSO TO A YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ESTABLISH A DIALOGUE AND
EXCHANGE INFORMATION ON THE
ISSUES THAT IMPACT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND MEXICO DURING
THIS CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO GIVE A
WARM WELCOME TO. THE CONSUL OF
MEXICO LEON EFFORT READ SHE IS
THE CONSUL GENERAL MEXICO IN
SACRAMENTO SHE'S BEEN-
ABSOLUTELY INSTRUMENTAL PARTNER
AND FACILITATING IMPORTANT BI
NATIONAL DISCUSSIONS. AND OF
COURSE SHE'S BEEN ALSO- VERY
CLOSE TO US HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WORKING WITH US ON
SO MANY ISSUES AFFECTING OUR
STATE AND OUR FRIENDLY STATE TO
SELL MEX. WE'RE ALL SO. PROUD
TO HAVE SUCH A GREAT RELATIONS
SO I'D LIKE TO. ASK HER TO COME
TO THE MIKE AND SHARE SOME
COMMENTS IF SHE WOULD-
GOVERNMENT MADAM CONSUL GENERAL
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
SENATOR WHEN I SAW THE WE WENT
OVER THE YES GOOD MORNING TO
ALL. THE SENATOR BEN HUESO
CHAIRMAN SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CALIFORNIA MEXICO CORPORATION
AND THANK YOU SENATOR. THEN I
GONZALEZ CHAIRWOMAN SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSE GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
I WANT TO GIVE SPECIAL THANKS
TO SENATOR WESSEL. ONE OF
MEXICO'S MOST IMPORTANT ALLIES
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
SENATOR GOALS SALAS FOR THEIR
KIND INVITATION TO SHARE A FEW
WORDS WITH YOU TODAY. THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC CALLS BY COVERT
NINETEEN HAS ENDED AS ADDED NEW
CHALLENGES TO OUR STRONG
BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP. AS AN
EXAMPLE AFTER TEN CONSECUTIVE
YEARS ONE OF OUR MOST IMPORTANT
MEXICO CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY DAY
HAS BEEN POSTPONED AND MOST
PROBABLY. IT WILL BE POSTPONED
UNTIL NEXT YEAR THIS IS JUST
ONE OF MANY EXAMPLES OF
IMPORTANT PROJECTS BUT THE
CALLS LIVE HAS BEEN WORKING ON
WITH CALIFORNIA. FOR OVER A
DECADE THAT WE HAVE HAD TO
POSTPONE BUT ON THAT NOTE WE
ARE SAYING HELLO AT A DISTANCE
BUT WE REMAIN VERY VERY CLOSE.
AT HEART. HOWEVER COOPERATION
AS I SAY BETWEEN MEXICO IN
CALIFORNIA HAS CONTINUE TO
STRIVE. THE JOINT HEARING TODAY
AT THE CAPITOL IS JUST LIVING
PROOF OF THIS FACT. AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S A STRATEGIC
PARTNER FOR MEXICO GIVEN ITS
COMMON BORDER THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF BILATERAL TRADE IN THE
SIZE OF ITS HISPANIC MEXICAN'S.
POPULATE AS WELL OR TAUGHT GROW
CLOSER EVERY DAY IT COMES AS NO
SURPRISE THAT ALL ALL THE YOU
STATES. TO THIS. DATE CAL ONE
YET THIS. BIGGEST EXPORTER OF
GOODS TO. WHICH IS ACCOUNTED 4%
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA. WORLD
WIND AND NOT ONLY IS CALIFORNIA
STRONG ECONOMIC PARTNER AS WE
KNOW IT IS ALSO A CLOSE VERY
CLOSE FRIEND TO OUR COUNTRY.
AND HOME TO THE LARGEST OF
MEXICAN ORIGIN COMMUNITY IN THE
UNITED STATES OVER TWELVE
MILLION PEOPLE. FOR THIS REASON
THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO IS
PROFOUNDLY. GRATEFUL FOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOME END THE STATE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT TO PROTECT
THE IMMIGRANT POPULATION DURING
THIS HEALTH CRISIS PARTICULARLY
THOSE OF MOST VULNERABLE MANY
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
RESIDING IN CALIFORNIA. AND
MANY OF THEM MOST OF THEM
WORKING IN A SENSUAL SECTORS
CONTRIBUTING IN A VERY
IMPORTANT WAY TO THE GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND- SUSTAINABILITY
OF THIS ECONOMY. THE DISASTER
RELIEF ASSISTANCE FROM FOR
IMMIGRANTS DR A ALIVE IS A
HISTORIC AN UNPRECEDENTED
PROGRAM FROM THE GOVERNMENT OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS HELPED
THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS. MANY
OF THEM AS I JUST MENTIONED THE
SOCIAL WORKERS WE HIGHLY VALUE
THIS EFFORT AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE ALL OF THE WORK
BEHIND THE BILLS AND
INITIATIVES LEGISLATORS IN
CALIFORNIA OR PORTION. TO
PROTECT OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS
AGAINST COVERT NINETEEN.
UNFORTUNATELY MEXICO IS ALSO
STRUGGLING MUCH LIKE EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE CORNER VIRUS AS WE
ARE FACING ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLEX MOMENTS. THAT IS WHY
THIS HEARING IS SO VERY TIMELY.
IN THIS CONTEXT LET IS NOT LET
OUR GUARD DOWN. LET'S CONTINUE
WORKING TOWARDS A STRENGTH OF
OR MU SOLIDARITY AND
COLLABORATION AND CONTINUE
PROTECTING OUR SHARED
COMMUNITIES PLEASE KNOW THAT
YOU CAN COUNT ON THE MEXICAN
CONSULATE GENERAL IN SACRAMENTO
IN THIS ENDEAVOR BUT ALSO ON
THE OTHER NINE CONSULATES. THAT
WORK IN THIS WONDERFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HE TEN TOTAL OF
FIFTY CALLS WITH WE HAVE IN THE
UNITED STATES WE FEEL MOST
FORTUNATE AND PRIVILEGED TO BE
NEIGHBORS FRIENDS AND FAMILY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS AND
ALL YOUR HARD WORK WE
APPRECIATE CHIU HERE IN
SACRAMENTO VERY VERY MUCH. NOW
I'D LIKE TO GET TO OUR PANEL WE
HAVE PUT TOGETHER A WONDERFUL
PANEL TODAY TERM FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND ALSO TO INFORM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THE IDEA IS THAT THEY'RE HERE
TO ASK. TO ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS
AND TODAY'S PANEL OF ART ARE
HEARING WILL CONSIST OF THREE
PANELS WE WILL HAVE WE WILL
BEGIN THE FIRST PANEL WHICH IS
A BI NATIONAL CRISIS STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RESPONSE A
COVERT NINETEEN. WE HAVE WITH
US TODAY JANET AND GALOSHES TO
DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. FOR IMPERIAL COUNTY
WE ALSO HAVE A MERRY SALAS
SHE'S THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
CHULA VISTA WHICH WILL. BE
JOINED BY- STEVE BY THE I
BELIEVE- NOT THE MERIT THINK
HAS IT COVERED. BUTWE WILL
BEGIN WITH GENET ON GOOGLE IF
WE COULD- CONNECT TO MISSING
WILL. YES GOOD MORNING WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
MORNING HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING THE
IMPERIAL COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TO SHARE. A FEW
WORDS IMPERIAL COUNTY AS YOU
MAY KNOW IS A CHRONICALLY
DISADVANTAGED UNDERSERVED AND
UNDER FUNDED COMMUNITY. IT'S NO
SECRET THAT PRIOR TO THIS
PANDEMIC THE COUNTY WAS ALREADY
IN DIRE NEED FOR RESOURCES.
ONLY NINETEEN JUST CAME ALONG
TO AGGRAVATE IT SITUATION.
TODAY WE HAVE STATE AND
NATIONAL ATTENTION ATTENTION WE
WISH IT WAS FOR REASONS OTHER
THAN TO DISCUSS THE GRIEF
SITUATION OUR COMMUNITY IS IN.
IT IS IRONIC THOUGH THAT I
STILL AWFULLY GRATEFUL THAT
SUCH ATTENTION IS BEING PLACED
IN THIS COMMUNITY NOW. THERE IS
CONSIDERABLE ATTENTION AND
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THE
SEVERITY OF KOBE NINETEEN AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. OF THE THIRTY
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED TESTS
HAVE BEEN ADMINISTERED OVER SIX
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED HAVE BEEN
POSITIVE. THAT MAY NOT FOUND
THE NEXT SIGNIFICANT TO MANY
BUT ONE OF THE COUNTY OF. AN
ESTIMATED POPULATION OF ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND IT
IS THE POTENTIAL. OUR CASE RATE
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION IS AT SIX NINETY SIX
OVER THE LAST FOURTEEN NAY.
ALMOST THREE TIMES AS MUCH OF
LOS ANGELES. COUNTY WITH A
POPULATION OF TEN MILLION. IN
JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS OVER
FIVE HUNDRED PATIENTS HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED OUT OF IMPERIAL
COUNTY AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL. COURSE CONCERNING
SITUATION. LIKE EVERY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE FULLY
COMMITTED TO PRESERVING THE
SAFETY OF OUR RESIDENTS.
CONSEQUENTLY WE HAVE TAKEN A
VERY DELIVERED IT AND A
CAUTIOUS APPROACH AND HOW WE
COMBAT THE DISEASE. ALTHOUGH
IMPERIAL COUNTY HAS NEVER MOVED
FURTHER INTO HIGHER RISK STAGE
TAKING ADDITIONAL AND MORE
AGGRESSIVE THAT. HELP STOP THE
SPREAD OF SPREAD OF KOBE
NINETEEN AND THE COMMUNITY. TO
BE CLEAR THEY ARE HOME AND FACE
COVERING ORDER HAVE BEEN AND
REMAIN IN PLACE AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY. WE CONTINUE TO STRESS
THE IMPORTANCE OF TRADE
COVERING SOCIAL DISTRICTING AND
OTHER PREVENTION MEASURES. TO
DATE IMPERIAL COUNTY HAVE
IMPLEMENTED ALL STATE
GUIDELINES AND HEALTH OFFICER
ORDERS ADDITIONALLY. COUNTY
HAVE TAKEN A VERY CONSERVATIVE
APPROACH TO RE OPENING OF THE
TALISMAN AND BUSINESSES WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM SO THAT
PROPER SAFEGUARDS ARE IN PLACE.
AT THIS TIME NINE AROUND
RESTAURANTS BARS PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES AND ALL OTHER HIGHER
RISK WORKPLACES REMAIN CLOSE.
NOT A LOGICAL QUESTION IS WHAT
IS COSTING THE THIRDS OF CASES
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS IN OUR
COUNTY. NO ANSWER THAT ITS
FIRST IMPORTANT TO SHARE THAT
IMPERIAL COUNTY IS LARGELY
INVISIBLE AND FORGOTTEN AS THE
REGION UNLIKE MORE WELL KNOWN
AND WELL PUBLICISED REGION
BUDGET SAN DIEGO. ANGELES AND
SAN FRANCISCO PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT OUR COUNTY. COUNTY
IS A RURAL COMMUNITY BORDERED
BY TO CALIFORNIA COUNTY SAN
DIEGO AND RIVERSIDE YUMA
ARIZONA IN MAY HE GOT A MEDICAL.
THE TO ITS UNIQUE LOCATION
IMPERIAL COUNTY IS THE MAJOR
CORRIDOR FOR TRANSPORT TO MANY
AREAS OF THE UNITED STATES.
AGRICULTURE IS AN IMPORTANT.
PART OF THE COUNTY TO CONNIE
ALTERNATING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF
VEGETABLES. ECONOMIC CROPS AND
LIVESTOCK FEED THE NATION.
COUNTY IS HOME TO CALIPATRIA
AND SPENT THE NIGHT LEFT THE
PRISON HERBERT HUGHES
CORRECTIONAL CENTER AND EL
CENTRO NAVAL AIR FACILITY. IT
IS ALSO HOME TO THOUSANDS OF
LONG TERM WINTER VISITORS AS
WELL AS WEEKEND AND THE
WARRIORS WITH PASSION IS TO
RIDE IN THE DUNES. QUANTIFY
SOME OF THE IMPACT OF THE LOUD
OR MINT GROUP. BURIAL FAN
DEALINGS RECREATIONAL AREA
BETTER KNOWN AS GLAMIS SUPPORTS
MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION VEHICLES. AND THE OPEN
FIELD WELL- STATE VEHICLE A
RECREATIONAL AREA OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND VEHICLES AND A
YEAR. ALL IN ALL AT TIMES%
DOUBLING POPULATION AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. WITHOUT A
DOUBT. COUNTY THE HIGHLY MOBILE
POPULATION EVEN WITH
INTERNATIONAL CROPPING
RESTRICTIONS OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE STILL
CROSSING THE INTERNATIONAL
BORDER FROM HE KILEY INTO
CALEXICO ON A DAILY BASIS FOR
WORK HEALTH CARE AND OTHER
BUSINESS. CHILD WAS JUST NOT
ONE WAY. COUNTY RESIDENTS THE
HEALTH CARE SHOP AND VISIT
FAMILY ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BORDER. THIS LAST WEEKEND IT
WAS REPORTED THAT LINE TO CROSS
INTO MEXICO WERE MILD LONG WITH
WAIT TIMES OF UP TO SEVEN
HOURS. THIS IS MAINLY DUE TO
SCREENING PROTOCOLS THAT
MEXICAN OFFICIALS HAD
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE WEEKEND.
ADDITIONALLY AS NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES BUT JUST SAN DIEGO
RIVERSIDE IN YUMA. WILL BE RE
OPENING STAGES AND MODIFY THEIR
SPARE HOME ORDERS. TRAVEL WILL
LIKELY INCREASE NOT ONLY
THROUGH OUR COUNTY BUT ALSO
WITHIN THEIR- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT WHILE IMPERIAL COUNTY
HAS HAD RELATIVELY LARGE
OUTBREAKS IN CONGREGATE
SETTING. AND SOME WORKPLACES
MOST OF ITS CASES DO NOT FALL
INTO THE BEDDING. ANY OF THE
KOBE NINETEEN POSITIVE CASES
ARE MADE UP OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ON OUR UNEMPLOYED. DISABLED
RETIRED HOMEMAKERS AND YOUNGER
AND OLDER STUDENTS. SOME OF THE
DYNAMICS THAT ARE THOUGHT TO BE
INFLUENCING THE SPREAD OF KOBE
NINETEEN ARE TIED TO CULTURE
WHAT I GENERATIONAL FAMILIES
AND FACTIONS WITHIN THE SAME
HOUSEHOLD. PERSONAL AND SOCIAL
BEHAVIOR. AND THE CON COMMENT
AND GOING ACROSS THE BOARD. BUT
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS IMPERIAL
COUNTY HAS RECEIVED MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT FROM ITS STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS. IN A
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT INCLUDING
AND NINETY FIVE. SURGICAL MASK
DOWN FACE SHIELDS AND OTHER
ITEMS HAVE BEEN SUPPLIED TO
MANY PROVIDERS OF THIS
COMMUNITY AND ALTERNATE CARE
SITES INTO COMMUNITY TESTING
SITES FIRST BAPTIST TESTING HAS
HAVE BEEN SUPPLIED AND MOBILE
LAB WILL SOON BE SET. STRAIGHT
TEAMS HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED TO
BOTH HOT LOCAL HOSPITAL AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
ADDITIONALLY A TEAM IS WORKING
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
ELECTRONIC PUBLIC HEALTH DATA
MANAGEMENT FROM. FOR ALL THAT
SUPPORT WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL. HOWEVER IT'S A SHORT
TERM FIX COUNTY IS REQUESTING
LONGER TERM SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTION SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
CRAFTED WITH A HEALTH EQUITY
LINE IT IS REQUESTED THAT
FUNDING IS PRIORITIZE TO HELP
SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ITS WORK
FORCE AND FINDING METHODOLOGIES
ARE DEVELOPED. KEEPING IN MIND
THAT IMPERIAL COUNTY HAS UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. DALY MORE WILL
POPULATION THAT IMPACT OVERALL
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'VE BEEN
JOINED BY SUSAN FINALE SHE IS
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE POLICY PROGRAMS WITH THE
STYLE OF WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WE HAVE ERIC LAREAU WHICH IS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR RESPONSE
OPERATIONS FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES SO
WE UNDERSTAND THERE ON A TIME
CRUNCH SO. WE'D LIKE TO GIVE
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AT THIS TIME OF MISS
FINALE AND MR LIBERAL PLEASE-
AT YOUR- WHEN YOU'RE READY
THEIR- THERE WE GOT WE GOT THE
IMAGE PLEASE. WELCOME AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. I THINK YOU
GUYS ARE MUTED SO YOU HAVE TO
AN RA SO OKAY AND YOU HEAR ME
NOW. YES YOU. HAVE PUBLIC
HEALTH IS WORKING WITH OTHER
CALIFORNIA STATE DEPARTMENTS TO
SUPPORT MITIGATE. THE FURTHER
SPREAD OF COKE AT NINETEEN ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER HE PH
IS ENGAGING WITH LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL OFFICIALS REGARDING
PUBLIC HEALTH SURVEILLANCE AND
NOTIFICATION OF BORDER BY
NATIONAL PROBATE NINETEEN CASES
TO PROTECT ORDER COMMUNITIES IN
MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA. AND WE
ARE ENGAGED DAILY WITH THE
HEALTHCAREDELIVERY SYSTEM
PRIMARILY AND IMPERIAL BUT ALSO
IN SAN DIEGO TO ENSURE ACCESS
TO PATIENT CARE IN PARTICULAR
HOSPITALIZATIONS IMPERIAL
COUNTY HAVE REQUIRED PATIENT
MOVEMENT. DALY OUTSIDE OF THE
COUNTY AND WE HAVE ONGOING WORK
WITH MEXICO I WON'T SPEND A LOT
OF TIME YOU'RE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH OUR OFFICE OF BI
NATIONAL BORDER HEALTH WITH A
LONG STANDING COOPER AND
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP.
WITH BAJA CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
OF HEALTH AND WE CONTINUED AT
BAT SURVEILLANCE SURVEILLANCE
ACTIVITIES WITH THEM THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC- WE ALSO HAVE A
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM. AND
CALLED BIDS THE BORDER
INFECTIOUS DISEASE SURVEILLANCE
PROGRAM SO CONTINUING TO WORK
ON- COBIT ISSUES WITH THEM- WE
ARE ALSO WORKING WITH CDC AND
OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES ENGAGING
WITH. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND BAJA CALIFORNIA TO GET THE
BEST HE STATE ARE FROM MEXICO
AND IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE
CALIFORNIA CAN SUPPORT MEXICO
AND OFFICE OF BI NATIONAL
BORDER HOUSEHOLD CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH. THE QUARANTINE
OFFICERS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
TAKE ARE INVESTING IN
STRATEGIES TO ASSIST WITH
BORDER CONTROL I'M OF THAT.
DISEASE MISSION WE ARE ALSO
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TOOK FROM PEOPLE.
THERE PER ON. FEDERAL RESOURCES
DOES TO ASSIST BORDER ISSUES
EPIDEMIOLOGIC APPLE STORE THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WITH FEDERAL ASSETS. OR SHOULD
BE DONE ON THAT FRONT HOW. AND
WE'RE- TO WITH AND- CROSS
BORDER CROSS FROM. EVEN THOUGH
THAT THEY ARE HAPPILY JUST. AND
LEGAL. THIS IMPACTED DISEASE
TRANSMISSION AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN BOTH
IMPERIAL AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES
HOWEVER THE LIMIT RESOURCES
BACK TO NOT JUST SPOKE ABOUT
COUNTY MAKE THAT A BIGGER
CHALLENGE FOR BOTH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ASPECTS OF THIS AS WELL
AS THE HEALTH. CARE DELIVERY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE I WANT TO
REPEAT WHAT CHEN THAT HAVE SAID
BUT WITH A POPULATION OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND AND
A MILLION. PEOPLE IN MEXICALI-
WITH WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TRAVELING ACROSS THE
BORDER EVERY DAY THAT HAS- YOU
KNOW REALLY WORKING ON THEIR
ESSENTIAL WORKFORCE HAS PUT A
BIG STRAIN ON IMPERIAL COUNTY
THEIR SMALL HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
THEY ARE WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK TO DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER TO MITIGATE THIS DISEASE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO WORK AS
CLOSELY AS WE CAN LET THEM BUT
I UNDERSTANDON GOING.
CHALLENGES THEY HAVE TO
HOSPITALS AND THEY HAVE SEVENTY
FOUR OF THEIR SORT OF NICK TWO
HUNDRED BAD SPOKE RECALL THAT
PATIENTS THAT REQUIRES TEN TO
FIFTEEN PEOPLE TO BE MOVED OUT
EVERY DAY- THEIR CASES IN THE
COUNTY CONTINUE TO CLIMB. I'M
IN AND THAT WE ARE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM FOR SEVERAL
WEEKS YOU CAN WORKING ON THEIR
AND DATA MANAGEMENT I AM
HELPING WITH TRAINING GOT THEM
SOME BILINGUAL ASSETS AND AGAIN
THAT'S NOT AN EASY THING RIVER
STATE EITHER. I'M IN TERMS OF
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS AND
CONTACT TRACERS HELPING WITH
THEIR DATA MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
THAT AND LOOKING AT INFECTION
CONTROL IN THEIR NURSING
FACILITIES AS WELL AS. A FREE
EXAM WEEK PACKING PLANT. WE
WERE ABLE TO THAT COUNTY JOB.
CDC ON ON SITE. A TEAM OF FOLKS
FROM CDC- TO HELP WITH THE
OUTBREAK IN THE MEAT PACKING
PLANT PRIMARILY BUT FOUND
BROADER GENERAL EPIDEMIOLOGIC
HELP WE DID SEND A TEAM OUT TO
YOU- IMPERIAL COUNTY ACROSS.
MANY STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
PUBLIC HEALTH OVER AT THE SIDE
AND LICENSING AND INFECTION
CONTROL I'M SORRY HELLO YES
FOOD NAG AND BUSINESS AND LABOR
ON SITE AND- EL COUNTY ON
SATURDAY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THEIR RESOURCE NEEDS. DTH AND I
COUNTY UP PRIORITIZE THE NUMBER
OF NEEDS I THINK YOU'RE NOT
TALK ABOUT THEM AS WELL AND
BOTH DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE ON THE HAPPY SIDE AND
DATA MANAGEMENT SIDE WORKING ON
A DATA MANAGEMENT. PLATFORMS
INCREASING CASTING CAPABILITY-
ON SITE MORE WORK TO BE DONE
THERE WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
OPTIONS ARE SITES BUT WE NEED
BETTER TEST TURNING HOUSE.
TESTING TURN AROUD TIME AND
REALLY NEED AND YOU PUSH THE
FEDS TO GIVE THEM A GENE EXPERT
MACHINE WHICH THEY SORT OF
CONTROL- AND SO WE ARE WORKING
OF COURSE THAT WILL CONTINUE ON
IMPACTS AND CONTROLS IN
HOSPITALS AND SNAPS. AND
ASSISTANCE WITH MEDICAL SEARCH
PLANNING AND PATIENT TRANSFERS
AND THEIR FEDERAL MEDICAL
STATION ALTERNATE CARE SITES.
AND ALSO ISSUES WITH MENTALITY
MANAGEMENT AGENCY MANAGEMENT
STAFFING AND WORKING- ON THE
AND P. EYES WHICH- WE HAVE A
GREAT CALL WHETHER COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS EARLIER THIS
WEEK ABOUT ALL THE STEPS THEY
WANT TO TAKE IN PROTECTING THE
COMMUNITY. AND READING. SPREAD
UPTREND OF TRANSMISSION. I'M SO
I COULD BE I CAN MORE. THE AND
THERE WILLINGNESS TO STOP UP A
SMALL TEAM AND REALLY WORK ON
MEDICATION- OUTRAGE. THEY NEED
RESOURCES WERE TRYING TO GET
THEM TO THEM AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. ON THE FLIP SIDE WE
HAVE SAN DIEGO COUNTY WITH A
POPULATION OF THREE POINT TWO
MILLION- DALY BORDER CROSSINGS
OF SEVENTY FIVE TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND AND I KNOW THEY'RE
HERE SO I DON'T WANT TO TALK
TOO MUCH ABOUT LET THEM SPEAK
ON THEIR OWN BUT- HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM WITH. SIXTY
FIVE HUNDRED LICENSED BEDS
TWENTY TWO HOSPITALS VERY
DIFFERENT PICTURE IN TERMS OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE- THEY HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
HOSPITALS LAST I TRACKED. JUST
MAYBE A DAY OLD. AND THEY ARE-
AND THEY HAVE ONGOING WORK WITH
WITH THE OFFICE OF BI NATIONAL
BORDER HEALTH WEEK. AND ARE IN
SAN DIEGO SO A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM AND
WEBER AND ACROSS THE BORDER.
THERE COUNTY EFFORTS HAVE WE
NEED IT. VERY LITTLE STATE
SUPPORT TODAY- THEY HAVE A
ROBUST SB TEAM MONITORING DATA
TO PRODUCE WEEKLY REPORT
SHOWING IMPACT IN THE ZIP CODES
ALONG THE BORDER MUCH HIGHER
PER CAPITA RATES THAN ANY OTHER
PART IN WHAT THEY CALL THE
SOUTH BAY- CONSISTS.
INSISTENTLY 6270% 6270% OF
HOSPITAL MISSIONS- ARE THOSE
THAT TRAVEL TO MEXICO OR WORK
CONNECTED TO A FAMILY MEMBER-
TRAVEL WHO TRAVELED TO MEXICO
THEY ALSO REPORT SMALL NUMBERS
COMING FROM THE ARIZONA BORDER
BUT NOT A LOT. AND ASSISTING
AND THEY'VE BEEN ASSISTING AND
HAPPY AND LAB TESTING FOR
IMPERIAL COUNTY- THEY HAVE A
LARGER HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM WITH SCRIPTS AND SHARP
IN SOUTH BAY- SEEING THE BULK
OF THEIR HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
BECAUSE THOSE ARE SYSTEM
HOSPITALS. THEY'RE ABLE TO MOVE
THEIR PATIENTS WITHIN THEIR
SYSTEM WITHIN THEIR COUNTY AND
SO LAST THE END OF NEED FOR THE
TRANSFERS OUT- THEY REPORT THAT
THEY'VE TAKEN ABOUT. HALF OF
THE HOSPITAL TRANSFERS FROM
IMPERIAL COUNTY. AND THERE I
HAVE WORK EARLY TO REQUEST THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND TAKE GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY AND CONTINUED OF
COURSE THAT EFFORT- BUT THEY'RE
ALSO SEEING A RISE IN THEIR
POSITIVITY RATE IN CASES IN SAN
DIEGO. AND I AND INCREASING DUE
TO- COMMUNITY MOVEMENT AS WELL
AS OUTBREAKS AND SNIFFS AND
OTHER LONG TERM CARE.
FACILITIES AND OUTBREAKS AND
COMMUNITY STUFF SETTINGS
ESPECIALLY RESTAURANTS AND BARS
FOOD AND OTHER MANUFACTURING
COMPANIES- MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES HAVE A CROSS BORDER
CONNECTION WITHOUT LIVING ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER. NOT
UNLIKE REALISTIC WITH YOUR
WORKERS COMING BACK AND FORTH
AND GOING TO SOME OF THESE ARE
BIG EMPLOYERS- SAN DIEGO COUNTY
IS WORKING WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY MUCH LIKE IMPERIAL
TAKING ACTION TO CLOSE BARS AND
CLUBS RESTAURANTS. AND ACTIVE
THIS WEDNESDAY AT MIDNIGHT AS
SORT OF AN AXE. STAFF AND SO
WANTING TO REALLY JUST SHARE
HI. YEAH. IT'S SORT OF THAT.
THE IMPACT OF THE IS GREAT BOTH
THEIR- BUT THE A BILL TO WORK.
GIVEN THE RE. OF SAN DIEGO IT'S
GET FRESH SO. I'LL STOP THERE
AND LET. ARE GOING TO. GREAT
THANK YOU SUSAN. THANK YOU
CHEERS. HUESO IN GONZALEZ AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
CALLOW YES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY
ON THE CRITICAL WORK UNDER WAY
TO SUPPORT IMPERIAL AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES. THAT'S THE
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES WITH
COPING NINETEEN IMPACTS THAN
THOSE COMMUNITIES. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THAT FELLOW
PANELISTS DIRECTOR- AND LITTLE.
RECENTLY SPOKEN OTHERS FOR
THEIR TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP A
LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL IN
RESPONSE TO THIS EMERGENCY AS
WELL AS THE PANELIST ON THE
UPCOMING SESSION FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THE FRONT LINES
OF THE HEALTH CARE RESPONSE IN
BOTH COMMUNITIES. THE ROLE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES COORDINATES
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO
EMERGENCIES LARGE AND SMALL
ALWAYS IN SUPPORT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE MOBILIZE UNDER
THE INCIDENT COMMAND STRUCTURE
THE STATE PERSONNEL RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO WRAP AROUND
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
DISASTERS WE ALSO WORK TO
COORDINATE THE RAPID DELIVERY
OF FEDERAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO AUGMENT
THOSE EFFORTS. SINCE THE LAST
WEEK OF JANUARY CALLOW YES HAS
BEEN RESPONDING TO THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE CORONA
VIRUS EMERGENCY FROM INITIALLY
MANAGING THE RESPONSE FOR
MULTIPLE REPATRIATION FLIGHTS
INTO CALIFORNIA CHINA. LOADING
PASSENGERS FROM THE GRAND
PRINCESS CRUISE SHIP DOCKED IN
THE OAKLAND QUIRK. DELETING THE
STATE RESPONSE SINCE EARLY
MARCH WHEN THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER WAS ACTIVATED. OUR
AGENCY HAS BEEN FULLY MOBILIZED
WITH STAFF SUPPORTING THE STOCK
OPERATIONS AND FIELD ACTIVITIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE.%
CONTINUOUSLY FOR THE PAST FOUR
MONTHS WE'VE LED ONE OF THE
LONGEST EMERGENCY ACTIVATIONS.
OF THE SOCK IN STATE HISTORY
ARE PREPARED TO CONTINUE TO
GUIDE THIS EFFORT SUPPORT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS LONG AS
NECESSARY. THROUGHOUT THIS TIME
OUR ENGAGEMENT ALONG THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BORDER
REGION. BOTH THE BORDERS WITH
MEXICO AND ARIZONA HAS BEEN A
TOP PRIORITY. IN THOSE SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTY WE
DEPLOYED SENIOR STAFF WITHIN
OUR RESPONSE DIRECTORY. HELLO
YES JUST SERVICE SENIOR STATE
OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT BOTH
COUNTIES. CHARGES BEEN TO
ENSURE CLOSE COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION OF ALL STATE
AGENCIES SUPPORTING SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES. ENGAGE
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
ENSURE THERE'S AN EFFECTIVE
INFORMATION SHARING. AS IT
RELATES TO MOVEMENT ACROSS THE
BORDERS AND TO CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDE BI NATIONAL AWARENESS
CO THE NINETEEN CASES. AND THEN
FINALLY TO OVERSEE AN
EXPEDITIOUS DEPLOYMENT F
PERSONNEL AND RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS REQUESTS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. IT IMPERIAL COUNTY
OVER THE LAST SIX WEEKS HELLO
YES IS LET THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT TO HELP
IMPERIAL COUNTY MANAGE THE
EXTENSIVE CODE NINETEEN OUT. TO
DATE AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTOR NOTED THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY IS
TRANSFERRED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PATIENTS WHILE AND WORKING TO
ADD BED CAPACITY OF AN EIGHTY
BED ALTERNATE CARE SITES THE
STATE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS IS SUPPORTING
THE BUILD OUT OF AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY INTENSIVE CARE UNIT BEDS
IN IT AT THE EXISTING HOSPITALS
WE DEPLOYED SIXTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
TEAM MEMBERS. TO BE ON SITE TO
SUPPORT- IMPERIAL COUNTY
INCLUDING A WORK AT TO SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES WITHIN THE
COUNTY. WE DEPLOYED IN NATIONAL
GUARD MOBILE LABORATORY OUT OF
SACRAMENTO TO SUPPORT THE
COUNTIES TESTING EFFORTS OUR
TEAM ON THE GROUND AND IMPERIAL
IS WORKING WITH LOCAL.
OFFICIALS TO ENSURE WE BRING
APPROPRIATE STAFFING LEVELS TO
SUPPORT THE HOSPITAL NEEDS. IN
COORDINATION WITH THE IMPERIAL
COUNTY COURT RIGHT CORNER.
STAFF FROM OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH IN OUR SOUTHERN REGION
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OFFICE ARE
WORKING TO ENHANCE AND
STABILIZE MASS FATALITY
OPERATIONS IMPERIAL COUNTY.
INCLUDING ENHANCEMENT OF STUFF
IN STORAGE CAPACITY. WE
DEPLOYED SEVENTY SIX
VENTILATORS TO IMPERIAL COUNTY
WE'VE PROVIDED PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. COUNTY
AND THIS IS INCLUDING NEARLY A
HALF MILLION IN NINETY FIVE
MASS MORE THAN ONE POINT ONE
MILLION SURGICAL MASKS EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND FACE SHIELDS ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
GALLONS MORE THAN FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND COVERALLS. THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND TEST KITS AND MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND GLOBS
ADDITIONALLY WE- SENT TO
IMPERIAL COUNTY SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FOR
CONTAINERS OF HAND SANITIZER.
OUR PROJECT ROOM KEEP PROGRAM
HAS ALLOWED IMPERIAL COUNTY TO
SECURE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX MOTEL
ROOMS. THE NINETEEN POSITIVE
INDIVIDUALS ISOLATE. IN TEN
TRAILERS PROVIDED BY THE STATE
TO IMPERIAL COUNTY YOU'RE BEING
USED TO HOUSE THE NINETEEN
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. JUST THIS
PAST SATURDAY CALLAWAY YES LET
A DELEGATION OF SENIOR
OFFICIALS THAT TRAVEL DO
IMPERIAL COUNTY TO JOIN UP WITH
OUR TEAMS ALREADY ON THE GROUND
TO MEET PERSONALLY WITH LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND STAFF. TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD
DEVELOPING A LONG TERM STRATEGY
TO DEAL WITH THE ESCALATING. AT
BOTH THE AT AT BOTH THE STAFF
AND LEADERSHIP LEVEL WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
SUPPORT FROM OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. INCLUDING AIR
AMBULANCE SUPPORT ENHANCED
MEDICAL SCREENINGS AT THE
BORDER AND EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
SUPPORT. FINALLY IN PERHAPS
MOST IMPORTANTLY YOU JUST
JOINED US WE HAVE APPROVED AT
THE STATE LEVEL REIMBURSEMENT
OF ALL THE DISASTER COSTS FOR
IMPERIAL COUNTY- THE HAVE
INCURRED TODAY WHICH INCLUDES
AT THEIR ESTABLISHMENT OF AN
ALTERNATE CARE SITES. ALL THE
WHILE WE'VE BEEN ACTIVELY
SUPPORTING IMPERIAL WE'VE BEEN
MAINTAINED A DEDICATED SUPPORT
CELL AND SAN DIEGO TO ADDRESS
THEIR CHALLENGES AND
RESPONDING. THE CODE RED
EMERGENCY. THIS INCLUDES
SERVING ON THE SAN DIEGO CO
THAT NINETEEN TASK FORCE WERE
TEAM PROVIDES CONTACTS AND
ADVICE ON HOW WE AS
CAPABILITIES AND STATE
RESOURCES INCLUDING THE ABILITY
OF THE USE OF THE ALTERNATE
CARE SITES AND SET UP. IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. HELLO YES IS MADE
INITIAL REQUEST FOR MORE PUBLIC
HEALTH SCREENINGS AT THE BORDER
AND COLLABORATE AND IS
FACILITATED COLLABORATION AMONG
AGENCIES AND PARTNERS. AS WE
UTILIZE OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE THREAT BETTER FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY IN
THE FEDERAL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO GAUGE
ENCOURAGE PUBLIC HEALTH DATA
AND INTEL SHARING AMONGST THE
COOPERATORS. YOUR HOMELAND
SECURITY DIRECTORATE WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
CORRECTIONS AND BORDER PATROL
MONITORING BORDER PASSENGER
NUMBERS AND VEHICLE ENTRY NORTH
BOUND IN THE US HE LANDED THERE.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE U.
S. COAST GUARD THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS ON THE REPATRIATION
OF CRUISE SHIP CREW MEMBERS.
THAT ARE ON SHIPS CURRENTLY
DOCKED IN SAN DIEGO THAT NEED
TO BE REPATRIATED TO THEIR
COUNTRY SUPPORT. OF ORIGIN
EXCUSE ME. THERE ARE
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS OFFICE
HAS BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
BOTH IMPERIAL AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES. SINCE OUR EFFORTS
BEGAN IN SUPPORT OUR HELLO YES
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS OFFICE IN
COORDINATION WITH LIEUTENANT
GOVERNORS BEEN IN COMMUNICATION
WITH BAJA CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND MINISTRY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REGARDING CODED
RESPONSE. IN PP NEEDS IN MAY WE.
SCALIA MAYOR'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
FIRST RESPONDERS IN MEXICALI
AND WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING THAT PP TO IMPERIAL
COUNTY FOR THOSE FIRST
RESPONDERS. IN SAN DIEGO TWICE
A WEEK OUR INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS OFFICE PARTICIPATES ON
THE SAN DIEGO REGION BORDER
UNIFIED COMMAND COORDINATION
CALL WITH SAN DIEGO COUNTY
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH CITY OF
SAN DIEGO BORDER PATROL. CDC
THE AND THE NATIONAL GUARD WERE
ISSUES ON THE BORDER REGION ARE
ARE DISCUSSED AND- INFORMATION
INTELLIGENCE AND SHARE. THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION INCLUDES
HOSPITAL CAPACITY SURGEON
COMMISSION AND TRANSPORTS ALONG
THE BORDER. WE ALSO HELPED
FACILITATE THROUGH OUR
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS OFFICE
SUPPORT THROUGH OUR HOTELS FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKER PROGRAM. FOR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS LIVING IN
MEXICO THAT REQUIRED ISOLATION
HOTELLING- WHEN THEY WERE
OFFERING THEIR ASSIGNMENTS AS
HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN THE
UNITED STATES. THERE'S MEMBERS
AS YOU KNOW FULL WELL THE
EMERGENCY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY ALONG OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH MEXICO IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT BEHIND US AND AS
SUCH WE'RE DEDICATED TO
REMAINING FULLY COMMITTED TO
GUIDING THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO
THIS CRISIS AS LONG AS
NECESSARY. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US HERE TODAY AND
CAPITA TAKE YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WONDERFUL
PRESENTATION AND VERY THOROUGH
AND VERY COMPLETE APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH VERY
INFORMATIVE- ONE THING THAT
I'VE I'VE BEEN. MADE AWARE OF
IS THAT ON MEXICO SIDE THE
GOVERNMENT HAS ISSUED A
MORATORIUM. ON THE PURCHASE OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES WHICH HAS
LED TO- VERY LARGE INFLUX OF
PEOPLE COMING IN FROM MEXICO
INTO THE U. S. TO PURCHASE
THINGS LIKE BEER AND ALCOHOL.
ON ON- ON THE ON THE BORDER
IT'S SUCH THERE'S BEEN THIS
HUGE RUSH FOR THESE. THESE
PRODUCTS ON OUR SIDE OF THE
BORDER THE RESPONSE FROM MEXICO
HAS BEEN TO CREATE CHECKPOINTS
ON THE REENTRY INTO MEXICO THAT
TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE AREN'T
ACCORDING THESE- PRODUCTS BUT
IT'S LED TO LINES OF I I'VE
BEEN INFORMED AS LONG AS- SEVEN
HOURS LONG ON FRIDAY. SO WE'VE
HAD- CARS I LEAN IN A
11510019 DEGREES HEAT BUT WHAT
WHAT CONCERNS ME IS THAT- THIS
IS ALL I THINK- CONTRIBUTED IS
MY OWN THOUGHTS THAT IT COULD
POTENTIALLY LEAD TO AN
EXACERBATIONS OF THE OF THE
CALL THAT INFECTION RATE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN PEOPLE ARE ARE
ARE TRAVELING AND UNDER
INFORMING THE BORDER PATROL OR
THE CUSTOMS OFFICERS AT THE
RESIDENTIAL- WORKERS ARE
ESSENTIAL TRAVELERS WHEN THEY
PROBABLY ARE NOT AND HAVE YOU
BEEN MADE AWARE OF THIS IS BUT
THE ARE ARE YOU AWARE OF THIS
SAYS THERE BEEN A RESPONSE TO
THAT. I IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE
OF THIS HAS CONTRIBUTED TO-
COMPLICATING THE PROBLEMS ALONG
THE BORDER OF CALIFORNIA MEXICO.
I THINK YOU'RE YOUR MUTED AGAIN
SO WE CAN HEAR YOU. HE'S MUTED
SUMS GOING ON. WHAT YOU'RE NOT
MEET IN ON OUR SIDE SO WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU CAN TRY IT AGAIN.
NOTHING YET CHAIR MAKING HERE
YOU ARE YOU'RE HERE YOU'RE BACK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I'M NOT SPECIFICALLY AWARE OF-
THE PROVISION THAT YOU SAID
WAS- INSTITUTED MEXICO
CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP ON THAT- WE
WERE AWARE THAT THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN SOUTHBOUND TRAFFIC
AS OF LATE TRAVELING BACK INTO
MEXICO- WHICH LIKELY IS A
RELATED TO- SCREENING THAT THEY
MAY BE DOING- AS FOLKS ARE
HEADED BACK INTO MEXICO BUT-
CERTAINLY THERE'S A NUMBER OF.
FACTORS WITH THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN IMPERIAL COUNTY IN
MEXICALI WITH PEOPLE LIVING AND
WORKING IN AND- AND- HAVING AN
ESSENTIAL NEED TO TRAVEL BACK
AND FORTH- SO CERTAINLY ADDS
COMPLEXITY. TO THE CHALLENGE.
WELL I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU
TO LOOK INTO THAT BECAUSE THAT
COULD BE A SOURCE OF INCREASE
INFECTIONS AND. AND TO OPEN UP
A LINE OF COMMUNICATION WITH
THE GOVERNOR BUCK CALIFORNIA.
TO DISCUSS THAT PARTICULAR TO
SEE IF THERE IS ANY CORRELATION
WITH THAT THANK YOU IF THERE
ARE ANY MEMBERS THAT THEY THEY
HAVE TO LEAVE SO- WOULD IT BE
GOOD TO ASK QUESTIONS NOW WE
HAVE DOCTOR PAN. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU CHAIR AND- AGAIN WHAT
I THINK- SHARES OF BOTH OF OUR
SOUL- COMMITTEES HERE TODAY FOR
BRING US TOGETHER- ACTUALLY
IT'S QUITE APROPOS WE'RE HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY BECAUSE-
AND- FORTUNATELY I THINK SOME
STATES AT THE NEW YORK ADDS TO
CLEAR DO WANT TO- SENSUALLY
ISOLATE- PEOPLE COMING
TRAVELING FROM CALIFORNIA TO
THE STATE FOR FOURTEEN DAYS
WHEN THEY SHOW UP- BUT- AND
SANDERS OF. SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT- BUT I THINK ALSO AS
EVEN WHEN THIS PANDEMIC WAS
SPREADING- THERE'S SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER. SUCH
ACTIVITY SUCH EFFORTS ARE-
REALLY SUCCESSFUL IN TRYING TO
LIMIT THE SPREAD OF THE-
PANDEMIC THE SPREAD AROUND THE
WORLD BUT- WHEN THE THINGS THAT
IS EFFECTIVE IS ACTUALLY-
EVENTUALLY BE ABLE TO MOVE TO A
CONTAINMENT STRATEGY IN TERMS
OF SIZE. THE ONLY INCREASING
OUR TESTING BUT THEN DOING
CONTACT TRACING AND THEN
ISOLATING PEOPLE WHO ARE
POSITIVE WITH THE DISEASE. SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS ABOUT-
THAT CROSS THE BORDER THAT WE
HAVE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO. WHAT THEIR DAUGHTERS
SOME DISCUSSIONS GOING ON
BETWEEN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH- HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN A CO ABOUT
COOPERATING AND DOING- TESTING
TRACING IN ISOLATION OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE POSITIVE WHEN WE GET TO
THE POINT WHERE WE HAVE- CAN
MANAGE THAT AND- SO IN TERMS OF
BECAUSE KNOWING THAT PEOPLE
GOING ACROSS THE BORDER FOR
MANY DIFFERENT REASONS SUMMER
SENT TO WORKERS SOME BECAUSE OF
TRADE AND OTHER THINGS- WHAT
SORT OF COOPERATIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH- NON. ARRANGEMENTS ARE
BEING DISCUSSED IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO. DO TESTING
TRACING OF PEOPLE TO HELP
BETTER CONTAIN ALBERY THAT MAY
BE HAPPENING IS PEOPLE ARE
COMING BACK AND FORTH ACROSS
THE BORDER. SO WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH PUBLIC HELP
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER
EVERY DAY- I THINK THAT THAT
CONTAINMENT STRATEGIES HAVE
LARGELY BEEN ON THIS SIDE OF
THE BORDER WE'RE WORKING WITH
CDC TO PROVIDE RESOURCES I KNOW
SAN DIEGO HAS PROVIDED SOME.
TESTING AND CON AND SB
EPIDEMIOLOGIC SUPPORT TO MEXICO
I'M AND MORE WORK TO BE DONE
FOR SURE- I THINK BAFFERT'S
HAVE LARGELY BEEN ON THIS SIDE
OF THE BORDER BUT IN
COLLABORATION UNDERSTANDING THE
RESOURCE NEEDS OF MEXICO AND
WORKING WITH CDC TO BUY MORE OF
THOSE RESOURCES. GEN AT AND
OTHERS FROM SAN DIEGO MAY HAVE
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
RELATIONSHIP ON THE GROUND
ACROSS THE BORDER BUT OURS HAS
BEEN THREE CDC AND THROUGH OUR
OFFICE OF FINANCIAL BORDER HOW
WE'RE WE'RE CERTAINLY HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT MOST
OF. THEM WERE PROVIDING THEM
SOME RESOURCES BUT THEY NEED
MORE AND- AND WE ALSO- ARE
PROVIDING MORE RESOURCES
VERTICALLY TO IMPERIAL COUNTY
TO SO THAT THEY CAN CONDUCT THE
TESTING THAT THEY NEED ON THIS
SIDE OF THE BORDER. RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
RESPONSE- SAID THIS IS A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND- WE'LL DEFINITELY
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT- UNITED STATES
IS. NOT FUNDING THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION- BUT WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT WE'RE ARE
PART OF ONE WORLD AND THIS IS A
PANDEMIC IT DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
POLITICAL BORDERS AND SO WILL
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THOSE
EFFORTS SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK. IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH. OUR INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS INCLUDING MEDICO TO BE
SURE THAT WE CAN JOINTLY STOP
THE SPREAD OF THE DISEASE. IT'S
NOT BECAUSE IT'S COMING IN FROM
OUTSIDE IT'S BECAUSE- IT'S-
IT'S SPREADING ACROSS THE ROUND
THE WORLD FROM WITHIN AND FROM
AROUND SO WE ALL NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER WE'RE ALL IN IT
TOGETHER SO I APPRECIATE THAT
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK ON- BUILDINGS THAT.
KIND INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED TO
WITH MEDICO. TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE IN BOTH
COUNTRIES THANK YOU. WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT FROM
PRO COMMUNIST SINGLE NOT WILL
GO TO JIM GROSS. FROM CYNICAL
I'M SORRY- CENTER RUBIO DID YOU
HAVE A- COMMENT OR QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANT
TO ASK A QUESTION AND THREE
DOES FALL UNDER THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. JURISDICTION BUT IT
WILL BECOME A PROBLEM IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS OR
SOLUTIONS- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE FEDERALLY OPERATED PULLED
HIM AS A DETENTION FACILITY HAS
IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE TESTED
POSITIVE. AND I AM ALSO- I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT OTHERS PLANTS
THREE SOME OF THE CHILDREN OR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
GIVEN PERMISSION TO RELEASE
THESE CHILDREN AND I THINK IT'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY BUT-
WHAT THERE IS CONFUSION AROUND
WAS. IF THEY'RE GONNA BE RESET
THEIR PARENTS OR INDIVIDUALLY
SO I WANT TO JUST NOT THERE
THEY HAVE ANSWERS TO THAT. AND
IF THEY'RE BEING RELEASED BY
THEMSELVES IS THERE A PLAN FOR
THESE CHILDREN AND DIE CLEARLY
THERE'S A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
PEOPLE AND INFECTED. HOW ARE WE
GONNA MEDICAID WHEN HE'S UP
INDIVIDUALS COME OUT INTO OUR
INTO OUR- BECAUSE NOT BECOME
OUR- ANY INFORMATION ON THAT.
YOUR SON CUT OFF AGAIN I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT WERE HAVING
SOME TYPE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES- DO WE HAVE
EVERYTHING GOOD ON SON NOW.
LET'S TRY IT AGAIN I CAN LOCATE
YOUR CODE. NEAR ME YEAH. YES WE
HEAR YOU JUST FINE ALL RIGHT-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION- WORK I'M NOT
SPECIFICALLY TRACKING THAT
INTELLIGENCE ON THAT THE
STABILITY BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY
FOLLOW UP WITH OUR TEAM WORKS
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS ON
THE BORDER AND FIND OUT I DON'T
KNOW OF OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
MIGHT HAVE- US SOME MORE
INFORMATION BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE'RE TRACKING BUT WE
CAN CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP. HELLO
THANK YOU. NOW WILL MOVE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE JIM GROWS
FROM WITH THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO MISTER GROCERY THEIR- I
AM MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION. REPRESENTS THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE COUNTY
ON THE ISSUES- THAT ARE THE
SUBJECT OF THIS HEARING- FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. ARE NOT
ENOUGH TENSION HAS BEEN BROUGHT
TO THIS ISSUE AND- IT I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- THE COMMENTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND YES WE ARE WORKING
WITH THEM VERY CLOSELY
LITERALLY ON A DAILY BASIS-
WHILE WE- DO FEEL THERE ARE
RESOURCES- HAVE MET THE
CHALLENGE IT IS ALSO THE CASE
THAT. WE KNOW ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED. OUT THE
BORDER REGION COUNTY AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH ALL OF THE PARTIES
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
ARE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES DATA
ACCELEROMETER HE WAS NOTED
THAT- A- HAVE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS- WITH ALL THE
PARTIES. AND WE HAVE TESTING
SITES ROUTE SOUTH REGION ARE
THOSE TESTS YOU START YOUR
FREE- WE HAVE UP FOCUS VERY
MUCH ON. THE NORTH PART OF THE
OF THE BORDER AND IMMEDIATELY
NORTH OF THE BORDER AS AN AREA
THAT CAN BE A HOT SPOT AND IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT- TO DEAL
WITH- AS WAS NOTED WE
PARTICIPATE- IT WITH A OFFICER
BI NATIONAL BORDER HEALTH AND
WE HAVE A BI NATIONAL SECTOR
WITHIN THE COUNTY- THAT WORKS.
VERY CLOSELY WITH- AT THE
GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO IN FACT TO
DOCTOR AND WAIT BOB WE WORK AND
ARE WORKING- ON ON A BI WEEKLY
BASIS THROUGH A TELEPHONE CALLS
WE HAVE TO HEALTH SERVICES
JURISDICTIONS IN TIJUANA CRAP
DAY WHEN WAS THE RESULT. AND I
HAVE. MAY SURE THAT WE HAVE ON
COMMUNICATION ABOUT OUR JOINT
EFFORTS ARE IN THE NEED FOR
RESOURCES- WE ALSO ARE MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
RESPOND- TO INCREASE REQUEST
FOR- INFORMATION- SUPPLY SIX
CETERA- WE FEEL THAT- THAT.
COMMUNICATION IS WORKING BOTH
WAYS- AND WE FEEL AS THOUGH-
OUR EFFORTS- HAVE INCREASED AS
THE PROBLEMS AND THE INFECTION
RATE. HAS INCREASED- AND I HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE KEEPING THE PUBLIC AT LARGE
AWARE OF THE EFFORTS- THAT ARE
GOING ON AT THE BORDER- WE'RE
CONDUCTING PRESENTATIONS TO
COMMUNITY GROUPS- BOTH IN SAN
DIEGO AND IN MEXICO. IT MAKES
FOR THAT THEY HAVE ALL THE
LATEST INFORMATION ALL THE
LATEST EFFORTS THAT ARE BEING
UNDERTAKEN- TO- PREVENT FURTHER
SPREAD OF THE DISEASE- AND AS
WAS SAID- THE- HOSPITALS AND
OTHERS IN THE REGION OF SAN
DIEGO- HAVE ASSISTED WITH- THE
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH THE-
INCREASE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY- I THINK
THAT. THAT OVERALL WE FEEL AS
OF THIS PARTNERSHIP WHICH IS
REALLY BEEN IN EXISTENCE ARE
QUITE SOME TIME- WAS WELL
POSITIONED- TO RESPONDED. BOB
OUR WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALSO- BEEN GOOD
GENERALLY- WHEN DR ALEX
EASEMENT WAS HERE IN EARLY MAY-
WE MADE SURE THAT- WE WERE
FOCUSED ON. OUR EFFORTS WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
SUBSEQUENT TO HIS VISIT-
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA'S SAN DIEGO
DID MAKE A PROPOSAL- FOR
DISHING ADDITIONAL TESTING
SURVEILLANCE SIX CETERA-
UNFORTUNATELY THE RESPONSE FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
THAT- RESOURCES THAT HAD COME
TO THE CARES ACT WOULD HAVE
SUFFICE WE DO. FEEL ADDITIONAL
WE ARMY TO FOCUS ON THE BORDER
ISSUES AND TO. ENSURE THAT. WE
ARE RESPONDING TO THE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE UNIQUE TO THE BORDER
REGION. I AS YOU KNOW I DO NOT
WORK DIRECTLY IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT YEAH IN SAN
DIEGO WE EXPECTED THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND- I
WILL TRY TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS BUT ALSO- WILL GO
BACK TO THE COUNTY- WITH ANY
QUESTIONS OR NEED FOR
INFORMATION FROM YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND OR ANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HAVE
YOU BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT
SPECIFIC RESOURCES YOU NEED AND
HAVE A HAS THERE BEEN AN
ATTEMPT TO SOLICIT. HELP FROM
ANY OF THE APPROPRIATE
GOVERNMENT. AGENCIES TO OF HELP
OF PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES
OTHERS OR ANYTHING THEY CAN BE
MORE- SPECIFIC ON I MEAN WHEN
YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
REDUCING. THE INFECTION RIGHT
WELL AND- CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO
MADE A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL THAT
INVOLVED ADDITIONAL FUNDING ARE
AND I THINK THAT THE FUNDING
SUPPORT AND THE EFFORTS OF- THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND YES- HAVE BEEN
GREAT- WE DO NOT FEEL THAT- WE
ARE LACKING IN THAT REGARD-
BUT- I THINK THAT IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS ON A LONG
TERM BASIS OPPORTUNITIES
PARTICULARLY WITH TESTING IN
TRACK AND TRACE. I THINK
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
AND WE WOULD LIKE- TO ENHANCE
THAT PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOUR PROPOSAL
OR YOUR YOUR- OF YOUR REPORT OR
YOUR REQUEST FOR A AND TERMS OF
THE TELLING WHAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE WOULD LOVE TO. TO
SEE WHAT THEY ARE TO SEE IF WE
CAN HELP WITH THE STATE SO
THANK YOU MISTER GROSS THANK
YOU FOR JOINING VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WILL
MOVE ON TO THE MAYOR. OF CHILL
THIS TIME AND- THAT ALSO COMES
MEMBER- STEVE BY THE I
UNDERSTAND YOUR- BOTH GIVEN A
JOINT PRESENTATION WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PARTICIPATION VERY MUCH IN YOUR
WORK FOR THE PEOPLE CHELVESTON.
WHAT MORNING SENATOR WEBSITE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONVENING THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
HEARING. AND JOB I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME SPEAK
TODAY ON THE IMPACT OF CODE
NINETEEN THAT ENDEMIC. ON THE
CITY AND- CHILL BASED IN THE
STOPPING. SO CHILL THE STATE IS
LOCATED IN SOUTH COUNTY- AND
IT'S ABOUT FOUR MILES FROM THAT
MEXICO BORDER. AND WE HAVE A
POPULATION OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHICH IS ABOUT
8% OF THE TOTAL POPULATION OF
THE SCENT OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
CHILLED LESTAT IS THE FIFTEENTH
LARGEST CITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S THE MEDICAL
AND COMMERCIAL HUB. US IS OUT
COUNTY REGION. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT AS THE ONLY TRUE FULL
SERVICE HOSPITALS WITHIN A
SEVEN MILE RADIUS OF THE SAN
DIEGO TIJUANA BORDER REGION-
ARE IN CHILDRESS THEM. SO
THERE'D ADDITIONAL
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ARE
US CITIZENS OR LEGAL RESIDENTS
WHO LIVE IN BAJA CALIFORNIA.
AND CAN PROP SUPPORTER TO SEEK
MEDICAL ATTENTION. AND THESE
INCREASES IN PATIENTS. ARE
IMPACTING OUR LOCAL HOSPITAL.
CHILDRESS THAT WAS A FIRST IN
THE CAN. THAT RECORD. COULD BE
NINETEEN CASE IN EARLY MARCH
AND WE ENGAGED WITH THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO- IMMEDIATELY AND
SOUGHT DIRECTION IN THE SYSTEM.
EVEN WITH THE QUICK RESPONSE
CHILL THE STATE HAS EXPERIENCED
A MUCH HIGHER RATE THAN OTHER
CITIES IN THE COUNTY EXCEPT FOR
NATIONAL CITY WHICH IS OUR
NEIGHBOR. AND WITH ONLY 8% OF
THE POPULATION WE HAVE HAD UP
215% OF THE- CASES AND RIGHT
NOW AS OF YESTERDAY OUR
FOURTEEN POINT 2% OF THE CASES.
OUR EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
SPREAD IT IS ALSO DIFFICULT
SINCE WE ARE BROUGHT A THRIVING
BI NATIONAL REGION. AND
ALTHOUGH WE BANNED NONESSENTIAL
TRAVEL ACROSS THE BORDER WE
CANNOT STOP CITIZENS OR
PERMANENT RESIDENTS OR PEOPLE
WITH WORK BASIS FROM CROSSING
THE BORDER. WE HAVE BEEN LUCKY
THAT WE HAVE HAD EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL RESERVES TO FIND MANY
EFFORTS THAT THOSE RESEARCH
HAVE BEEN EXHAUSTED. WITH NO
CONSIDERATION OP ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF CODE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENT ARE ALLOCATING.
FUNDING BASED ON POPULATION AND
NOT ON THE ACTUAL IMPACT OF THE
VIRUS INDIVIDUAL
MUNICIPALITIES. OUR CITY IS
ONLY GETTING A FRACTION OF WHAT
IT NEEDS TO HELP STOP THE
PANDEMIC AND THE IMPACTS OF
THIS PANDEMIC. A PERFECT
EXAMPLE IS THIS. THE CITY
STOCKTON WHICH HAS A POPULATION
OF THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN
PEOPLE HAS AS OF JUNE
FOURTEENTH JUNE TWENTY FIFTH
FOURTEEN HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
CASES AND ARE GETTING A PER
CAPITA YOU'RE- GETTING A PER
CAPITA OF THE CARES ACT
ALLOCATION. OF EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS AND TWENTY SEVEN CENTS
PER RESIDENT WHERE IS THE CITY
OF CHOCOLATE CHILL MISTER WITH
POPULATION OF TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE AS
OF JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH AS WELL
WE HAVE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
SIXTEEN CASES AND ONLY GETTING
A CAP PER CAPITA SURE OF THE
SACKED ALLOCATIONOF TWELVE
DOLLARS AND TWENTY CENTS. SO
THAT'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE EIGHTY
FIVE DOLLARS VERSUS TWELVE
DOLLARS. THIS IS A STARK
EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS FORMULA IS
LEAVING CITIES LIKE CHILDREN
STEP HOBBLED IN ITS EFFORTS TO
CONTROL THE SPREAD OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN. AND LEAVES US
HEAVILY DISADVANTAGED TO
MAINTAIN THE NEEDED SERVICES TO
OUR RESIDENTS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND NOT TO MENTION
THE NEED THE NEEDED MEDICATION
OF THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS THAT
THIS PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON OUR
COMMUNITY. AND WHAT WE ARE
STRIVING TO MEET THESE DEMANDS
WITH THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE IT
IS NOT ENOUGH. THIS VIRUS IS
IMPACTED OUR REGION AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
CRITICAL WE ARE- EIGHT IF WE
ARE TO STEM THE SPREAD OF THIS
AND ARE. THE KERR LINE WAS
INTERRUPTED THAT FROZE.
MICELLES BECAUSE- MER SELES FEW
CAN HEAR US- WE LOST YOU THEN
MAYBE WE COULD HAVE A COUNCIL
MEMBER BY THE MAYBE FILL IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SHARE GONZALEZ ON
ONE THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
ON THE ENTIRE SOUTH SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IS NOW IN SAN DIEGO IS
CONSIDERED A HOT SPOT UNCLE BIT
NINETEEN CASES. JUST COUNTY
COMMUNITIES IN CHULA VISTA
NATIONAL CITY BENITA SINESTRO
TIME MESA BEACH COUNT FOR ABOUT
50% OF THE COUNTY'S OVERALL
POPULATION AND COLLECTIVELY FOR
ABOUT THIRTY TWO PERCENT. OF
OUR COUNTIES POSITIVE CASES AS
OF JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH. AS YOU
MAY KNOW I AM A SURVIVOR OF
KOBE NINETEEN FOR ELEVEN DAYS I
WAS ON A VENTILATOR AND METAL
MEDICALLYINDUCED COMA. I LOST
TWENTY SEVEN POUNDS AND ONE OF
MY LUNGS PARTIALLY COLLAPSED. I
UNDERSTAND FIRSTHAND THE PEOPLE
IMPACT OF THIS DISEASE CAN HAVE
ON OUR COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
STRENGTH AS YOU KNOW OUR ORDER
REGION IS DERIVED FROM THE
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
INTERDEPENDENCY THAT OCCURS
WITH THOUSANDS OF BORDER
CROSSINGS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
ANGEL THIS TO MANY OF OUR
RESIDENTS LIVE AND WORK ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER MEDICAL
TOURISM IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THE REGIONAL ECONOMY. AS PEOPLE
SEEK HEALTHCARE SERVICES ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER IN
THIS MOVEMENT IS OFTEN.
MANDATED BY THE NATURE OF
FRONTLINE WORKERS ON A CRITICAL
SERVICE WORKERS THAT RESIDE IN
THIS PART OF THE COUNTY. THAT
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT FOR WORKING
PLEASE STAND AND- A HIGHER RISK
FOR EXPOSURE. THE MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE SEEKING QUALITY
HEALTHCARE IN THE UNITED STATES
AND MEXICO CERTAINLY PRESENTS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ACCESS IT
ALSO INCREASES THE POSSIBILITY
OF THE SPREAD OF. NINETEEN AS I
SAID. HE SAID THAT HISTORICALLY
AFFECTED BY HIGHER PERCENTAGES
OF CHRONIC CONDITIONS. BASED ON
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INTERVIEW SURVEY STRAUSS
AN EAGLE COUNTY REGION HAS
HIGHER CURRENTS IS OF ASTHMA
DIABETES HEART DISEASE AND IS
NOW WELL KNOWN- THERE IS SOME
CORRELATION BETWEEN OTHER CO
MORBIDITIES AND THE RISK OF
SERIOUS ILLNESS CONNECTION
CC AT NINETEEN. ACCORDING TO
THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DIABETES AND HEART
DISEASE OR LEADING CAUSES OF
REALLY BEST BASED ON CHRONIC
DISEASE JEWEL OF ESTA. AS MAYOR
SALAS INDICATED WE ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF THE COLD THE
CRISIS WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
WE POSSIBLY CAN TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER A FAIR ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING IS NEEDED TO CONTINUE
TO PRESS THAT PROVIDE SERVICES
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL FOR THE WELL
BEING OF OUR RESIDENTS. ANY
STATE FUNDING SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED IN A STRATEGIC WAY.
NOT JUST BASED ON POPULATION
THREATS POLLS OR PER CAPITA
SHARES. BUT STRATEGICALLY
DIRECTED TO AFFECT DIRECT
IMPACTS WHERE IT IS NEEDED MOST.
OBVIOUSLY THIS INCLUDES THE
NEED TO REACH THE MOST
VULNERABLE AREAS WITH THE
HIGHEST INFECTION RATES
AFFECTED DISTRIBUTION ESTATE
PLANNING PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF PEOPLE. BUT TO
BREAK DOWN CULTURAL AND
LANGUAGE BARRIERS THAT A
PERSONAL ON STYMIED OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AND I
THINK THE CHAIRS AGAIN. WOULD
CERTAINLY BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT AND YOU KNOW AS AS THE
SENATE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
BORDER IF I COULD JUST SEND ON
TO THOSE COMMENTS UNITS BEEN
VERY. COMPLICATED TO ADVOCATE
FOR MY DISTRICT BEING THAT IT'S
THE ONLY DISTRICT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE BORDERS OF
FOREIGN COUNTRY AND- AND OF
COURSE THE COMPLICATIONS OF
THAT BRING BRING SO MANY-
CHALLENGES TO- PROVIDING ARE.
ADEQUATE SURE FUNDING THIS IS
AN INSTANCE IN WHICH WE SEE ONE
OF THE LARGEST BANKS IN THE
STATE WITH WITH NO- REAL-
PROPORTIONAL- RESPONSE AND
RESOURCES TO THAT PROBLEM. AND
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU YOU
MADE SOME COMMENTS RELATING TO
THE CARES ACT FUNDING AND HOW
THAT'S BEEN APPLIED TO THE
STATE THERE'S SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
NO CASES. THAT HAVE THAT ARE
SEEN DECREASES AND NOT
INCREASES. AND WELL WE HAVE
ALREADY INCREASES THERE WE
DON'T HAVE. THE FUNDS NECESSARY
TO AID IN THAT SO WE WERE
WORKING VERY HARD TO MAKE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF AWARE OF
THAT THE CALLOW YES OFFICES FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION HERE WAS
VERY IMPORTANT. AND IN IN IN IN
PASSED. UP POLICIES LIKE THE
CALAMARI WERE STREAM COMPLETELY
LEFT OUT THE BORDER REGIONS IN
THE IMPACTS BECAUSE THE TO
MEASURING DEVICES ALONG THE
BORDER WERE NOT AVAILABLE SO
THAT JUST MEANT THAT- THERE WAS
NO FUNDING FROM THAT SOURCE TO
HELP. COMMUNITIES COMBAT POOR
AIR QUALITY AND- AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEMS AND OF
COURSE THAT'S BEEN EXACERBATED
HERE ONE THING CALL THAT HAS
DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
SHOWING. THE VULNERABILITY OF
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES AND WHEN WE
SEE THAT THE BORDER COMMUNITIES
DEFINITELY VULNERABLE OF MERIT
MANY THINGS EMERGENCIES HEALTH
CRISIS- ENVIRONMENTAL CRISES.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN YOUR COMMENTS.
OF WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON ON OUR
CALENDAR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO- CHRIS VAN GORDER SHE'S HE
HE'S A PRESIDENT. AND CEO OF
GAZELLE A. JERRY SURE REEF THE
MD NCM OF SCRIPTS HEALTH. AND
WE'RE GONNA ALSO HEAR FROM THE
PIONEERS MEMORIAL HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT LAURIE LEWIS THE CEO
AND DEAL CENTURY JOURNAL
MEDICAL CENTER DOCTOR ADOLPH
EDWARD. AND FROM THE UC SANTA
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE JESS. MANDEL
THE I GUESS IS THE MEDICAL.
DIRECTOR THERE AT THE UC. SAN
DIEGO SCHOOL OF MEDICINE-
WELCOME TO. MAYBE WOULD BEGIN
WITH PRESS CHRIS VAN GORDER.
THANK YOU SENATOR HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA MEXICO
CORPORATION AND THE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSE MY NAME IS CHRIS AND
ORDER PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
SCRIPT SELF AND I'M JOINED
TODAY BY OUR CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER DR GONZALEZ YOU REACH
AND CHILLS BUT ANY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A SCRIPT HEALTH THANK
YOU FOR TAKING NOTICE OF THE
IMPACTS OF THE COVERED NINETEEN
AND THEN MAKE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BORDER COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
EXPERIENCES WITH YOU TODAY.
THAT'S CHRIS WE TAKE PRIDE IN
OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
DISASTERS SCRIPT HAS RESPONDED
TO EMERGENCIES LIKE HURRICANE
KATRINA. AND THE PARADISE FIRE
SOME MORE. BUT THE SPEND AND
MAKE IS DIFFERENT. TRIPS BEGAN
TO SEE THE CORONA VIRUS THREAT
BECOME A REALITY FOR OUR REGION
BACK IN FEBRUARY. FEBRUARY
SCRIPTS PREPARED FOR AND
TREATED VERY EARLY TRAVELERS
FROM CHINA. WERE QUARANTINED AT
MARINE CORPS AIR STATION
MIRAMAR IN SAN DIEGO. BUT THAT
EXPERIENCE FIRST QUICKLY
WRAPPED UP THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
FOR COVERT NINETEEN RESPONSE.
ON MARCH NINTH WE WERE NOTIFIED
BY THE COUNTY OF OUR FIRST
PUBLIC POSITIVE PATIENT AND
SCRIPTS. THE FIRST KNOWN CASE
IN SAN DIEGO. IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC OUR EARLY CASES
WERE NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO. WE
QUICKLY OPENED A NURSE HOTLINE.
FOR NOT ONLY SCRIPT STATIONS
BUT FOR THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE
WE STOOD UP TRIAGE FACILITIES
ARE HOSPITALS AND DRIVE AT
TESTING SITES. AND THAT ARE
URGENT CARE FACILITIES. BUT
BEFORE I PROCEED I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE GOVERNESS IN. THE
LEGISLATURE. I IN OU COUNTY
SWIFT ACTION DURING THESE EARLY
MONTHS TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS
OF THE PANDEMIC. YOUR ACTIONS
TO COURAGE AND WE'RE NOT
WITHOUT RISKING CRITICISM. THAT
HAD YOU NOT TAKEN EARLY ACTION
MANY MORE LIVES FOR THE LOSS TO
THE SPEND DOWN. AND WE THANK
YOU FROM THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THAT'S THE NUMBERS
BEGAN TO GROW IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WE SAW SON SHIFT IN MID
APRIL. AND APRIL EIGHTEENTH WE
HAD CAN COPE WITH POSITIVE
PATIENTS ALL AT ONCE. IN OUR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. AND EVERY
DAY AFTER THAT THE NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO GROW. SCRIPTURAL
ACOSTA HOSPITALS ABOUT TEN
MILES FROM THE SENATE CEDAR
PORT OF ENTRY. AS YOU KNOW
THAT'S THE BUSIEST LAND BORDER
CROSSING IN THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE. IN APRIL THE SAN
DIEGO UNION TRIBUNE WAS
REPORTING THAT THE CASES AND
SENATE CEDAR BROUGH A HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN PERCENT. BETWEEN
APRIL FOURTEENTH AND APRIL
TWENTY. DURING THE SAME TIME
BOTH SCRIPTS AND SHARP
HOSPITALS IN CHáVEZ TO. THE
NEAREST HOSPITAL SERVING THE
SAN DIEGO TIJUANA BORDER.
EXPERIENCED AVERAGES ABOUT
PERCENT EIGHTEEN PERCENT.
POSITIVE CO THAT NINETEEN TEST
RESULTS COMPARED TO AN AVERAGE
OF 6% POSITIVE RESULTS.
ELSEWHERE IN THE COUNTY. FOR
THE WEEKS TO FOLLOW THAT NUMBER
BECAME EVEN MORE PRONOUNCED. OR
HOSPITALS ANGELES TO SUSPECTS
EXCEEDING 25% POSITIVES. WELL
THE COUNTY PERCENTAGES OF
POSITIVES MORE BROADLY. DROPS
BELOW 5% BY THE END OF A-
EIGHTY. OF OUR COVERT PATIENTS
ORDER TWO SCRIPTS HOSPITALS.
FURTHER UP 48% OF CODE BUT
POSITIVE PATIENTS WHO VISITED
OUR CHILL THIS DIVERGENCE
AROUND BETWEEN MAY TWENTY
FOURTH. AND MAY THIRTIETH SAID
THEY HAD RECENTLY TRAVELED TO
MEXICO. THAT FIGURE JUMP 260%
BETWEEN MAY THIRTY FIRST AND
JUNE SECOND. ONLY ABOUT 5% OF
IT NINETEEN PATIENTS REPORTED
THAT THEY'D RECENTLY BEEN TO
MEXICO THAT'S GROUP'S OTHER
THREE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
WE'RE FORTUNATE SCRIPT AND
SHARPER BOTH SYSTEMS OF
MULTIPLE HOSPITALS AND SO WELL
OUR CHILDREN'S TO HOSPITALS
WERE NEAR CAPACITY FOR WEEKS ON
END. WE HAVE THE LUXURY OF
BEING ABLE TO TRANSFER SOME OF
THOSE PATIENTS TO HOSPITALS IN
THE NORTHERN PART OF THE
COUNTY. A MAY ELEVENTH SCRIPTED
SIX PATIENTS ARRIVE AT SCRIPT
RESIDUAL MISTER DIRECTLY FROM
THE BORDER WITHIN AN HOUR. FOR
BY AND LISTEN TO WALKING.
THROUGH THOSE PATIENTS FOR BACK
TO BACK INTO PATIENTS AS THEY
WERE CRITICALLY ILL WHEN THEY
ARRIVE. THIS EXPERIENCE IS NOT
UNIQUE TO SUPPRESS THIS TREND
CONTINUES TODAY JUST LAST WEEK
RECEIVE SEVEN AMBULANCES FROM
THE BORDER TORTURE LISTA
HOSPITAL. BY THIS TIME AND THEN
WE ARE TRANSFERRED FORTY THREE
PATIENTS FROM FROM SOUTHERN
HOSPITALS. ARE NORTHERN
HOSPITALS TO MAKE ROOM IN THE
SOUTH. TODAY THAT NUMBER IS
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
I THINK AS OF THIS MORNING WAS
A HUNDRED AND- FIFTY SEVEN. OUR
PATIENTS WE TRANSFERRED FROM
THE SOUTH. WE SAW US LIKE
STABILIZATION AT THE END OF MAY
AND THE BEGINNING OF JUNE.
HOWEVER SINCE JUNE NINETEENTH
OUR NUMBERS OF COVERT POSITIVE
TEST RESULTS. HAVE NOT ONLY
GONE BACK UP. THE NUMBERS ARE
DOUBLING. ON JUNE TWENTY SECOND
OF FORTY THREE UNIQUE NEW
COVERT POSITIVE CASES SYSTEM
WIDE. THE HIGHEST SINCE THE
SINCE THE START OF THIS
PANDEMIC. NEW RECORDS WERE SET
THE FOLLOWING TWO CONSECUTIVE
DAYS. OUR DAILY AVERAGE IS NOW
WELL ABOVE THE PREVIOUS GAVE
THE CASE RECORDS CYNICAL
PREVIOUS PEAK. WAY BACK IN
MARCH. ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD WE
HAVE FORTY EIGHT UNIQUE NEW
COVERED A POSITIVE CASES SYSTEM
WIDE. HI. THIS IS THE START OF
ENDEMIC. OUR NURSE HOTLINE IS
AN AVERAGE OF ONE THAT. SIX ON
CALLS FOR WEEK. ATOP FROM. FROM
WHAT STARTED ABOUT THIS ONE
THOUSAND. SCRIPTS ALONE
DISPOSES THE CHALLENGER
STAFFING. OUR SUPPLIES AND
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND SO MUCH MORE. AS WE FIGHT
THE COVER NINETEEN BY
RESTRICTIONS USING TEN THOUSAND
SURGICAL MASKS ONE THOUSAND AND
NINETY FIVE MASKS SIX THOUSAND
ISOLATION GALS ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND GLOVES EVERY DAY.
THE NEED IS GREAT THE
CHALLENGES ARE BORDER
COMMUNITIES ARE COMPLEX GIVEN
THE INTEGRATED NATURE OUR
FAMILIES OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR ECONOMY. WE ARE NOT A SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY THREE MILLION
PEOPLE WE ARE COMMUNITY THREE
MILLION PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO
PLUS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
US CITIZENS. YOU'LL CITIZENS
AND MEXICAN NATIONALS WITH THE
NEEDS AND RIGHTS TO CROSS THE
BORDER. SENATE HOSPITALS ARE
ALSO LIFELINE TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTHCARE NEEDS IMPERIAL
VALLEY AND ACCEPTED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TRANSFER
STUDENTS DIFFICULT CRIME. AS OF
THIS MORNING WE HAD ACCEPTED
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY ONE PATIENT
TRANSFERS FROM THE BUREAU
COUNTY. HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
FROM PIONEERS AND A FORTY EIGHT
FROM EL CENTRO REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER AND EIGHTY ONE OF THOSE
STATIONS REPUBLIC POSITIVE. SO
WE DON'T NEED A BURGER CO
CLOSURE WE NEED SUPPORT. WE
NEED SUPPLIES EP MEDICATION.
THE AGENTS FOR OUR LABS- AN FDA
APPROVED SLOBS FOR BOTH OF THE
NINETEEN AN INFLUENZA ALL OF
WHICH ARE IN DEEP IN SHORT
SUPPLY. AND WE NEED CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITIES OF ALL SIDES. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME BECAUSE THAT'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE HAVE
A LARRY LEWIS THE CEO. OF
PIONEERS MEMORIAL HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT. THE MORNING DELIVERS
AND THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK PAUL RYAN
YEARS EXPERIENCE DURING THE
COLD EMERGENCY FIVE YEARS IS A
LOCATED ABOUT- TWO HOURS EAST
OF SAN DIEGO ON ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILES NORTH OF THE
MEXICAN. BORDER HUNDRED AND
SEVEN BEDS SO WHERE ARE ROLL
HOSPITAL HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION THE NET REVENUES AND
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED EMPLOYEES-
LIKE EVERYONE'S EXPERIENCE WE
SAW THIS IS A FAR AWAY STORM AT
FIRST BUT NATIONAL NEWS IT WAS
LIKE CRACKING UP FOR EIGHTEEN-
REPORTS WERE FIRST HEARD. OF
YOUR THE FIRST OF THE YEAR-
CERTAINLY THOUGH REPORTS FROM
WASHINGTON AND NEW YORK CITY
PAINTED SOME ENHANCE USE OF THE
POSSIBLE COVERT STORM. GETTING
THIS NATION- CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION MEMBERS
THE OPERATIONS CENTER ALARMS
WENT OFF SHORTLY THEREAFTER. IN
EARLY MARCH- CH A EXECUTIVE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS SOME URGENT
ALARM REQUESTING HOSPITALS
DEVELOP A- FLEX PLAN FOR A CO
WITH PATIENTS STORM SURGE- IN
PREPARING. FOR THAT STORM OF.
FOR YEARS A STATUS IT IS A
COMMAND SYSTEM IN EARLY MARCH-
AND WE BEGAN BY. SPACE ICE USE
SPACE MOVING UP FROM EIGHT
LICENSED BED STOP THE THIRTEEN
QUICKLY AND THE MENTALLY UP TO
THIRTY TWO BEDS- JUSTIN SPACE
PLANS A NEGATIVE AIR SPACE-
STARTING AT TWENTY NINE- TO
MOVE QUICKLY TO FORTY- TODAY OR
AT FIFTY EIGHT- SO. METROPASS
OF THE REALLY WAS PLANNED
PLEASE THANK. BY WITH. THE
POSSIBLE OF COULD. OF EXTERIOR
TENSE AND THE SHELTERS UP WE
HAD CLOSED FROM ELECTED SIR.
AND THE SHOW IN A RESULTANT IN
A PERCENT IMMEDIATE AND ARE
CLINIC WERE CUT IN HALF
EMERGENCY ROOMS- SURGERIES ALL
DECREASED DRAMATICALLY
pOVERNIGHT WITH THE- SHELTER IN
ORDER- ALSO CREATED A CASH
CRUNCH- AND RESULTED IN SOLEIL
OFF EARLY ON NOT KNOWING WHAT
TO REALLY EXPECT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN AND NO INDICATION BOTH.
WHAT KIND OF RELIEF WOULD BE
ORGANIZED. BUT THE STORES OF
THE STORM SURGE DID INCREASE-
AND CERTAINLY EL CENTRO WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM NEXT- AT
A PARTICULAR MUCH HIGHER A
NUMBER OF ADMISSIONS THE
PIONEERS- BUT- YEARS IN MARCH
OUR FIRST CASE WAS ON MARCH
SIXTEENTH. WE HAD- NINE NEW
ADMISSIONS IN MARCH AND APRIL
TWENTY ONE NEW ADMISSIONS AT
LIKELY YOU'LL WE ALSO
ANTICIPATE BY- OR EXPECT BY
EASTER ESCALATION- AND WE HAVE
NO CASES TRANSFERRED FROM
PIONEERS THAT WORK BUT PATIENTS
A MONTH. IN MAY- WE PROCEEDED
TO SEE SIXTY TWO NEW
INVENTIONS- ALSO FUELED BY A
MOTHER STAY IN A MEMORIAL DAY
IS WHAT WE AS SOON AS WE FOR
LIKE DAYS WHAT THE INCREASES.
AND WE TRANSFERRED TWENTY EIGHT
CASES THAT MONTH ALONE. EARLY
JUNE- WE WERE ON A PACE IN THE
FIRST NINE DAYS FOR ABOUT SIXTY
NEW CASES OUT OF A TOTAL NUMBER
RIGHT NOW BUT I'M SURE IT'S IN
THE SEVENTIES. AND IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE- SEVENTIES K. OF
THREE JUNE TWO EIGHTH SO A DRUM.
IN WHAT YOU SEE IN A WAY A SON.
IS ONLY THE BEGINNING OF THE
STORY FROM THE AREA- AND WE'RE
RIGHT NOW ANTICIPATING A STRONG
POSSIBILITY- THAT THE FOR THE
JULY COULD RESULT IN HERE OR
GREATER- CONTACT AND SPREAD OF
THE DISEASE SO- WE'RE PLANNING
ON THIS LEVEL TO CONTINUE FOR
THE NEXT YEAR WE'VE GONE AWAY
FROM A- SHORT TERM STRATEGY AND
HOW THE WE- WORK THROUGH THIS
CRISIS TO THIS IS OUR NEW WAY
OF OPERATING- THE FINANCIAL
PRESSURES- ARE GREAT- WE DID
SEE SOME TEARS ACT. FUNDING
WHICH GREATLY HELPED US AS
WELL- MOST. RECENTLY IN JUNE.
AND BUT IT'S REALLY- WITHOUT
ANY NOTIFICATION OF WHAT TO
EXPECT OR HOW MUCH TO EXPECT.
OR WHAT'S COMING NEXT IF
ANYTHING SO WHAT WE'RE IN A
GOOD POSITION TODAY THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO BE GREAT NEEDS-
RESOURCE SHORTAGES- AS CHRIS
MENTIONED- THE PPVS.
IMMEDIATELY NOTHING WAS
AVAILABLE AND YOU COULDN'T
INCREASE SUPPLIES OF ALL- BUT
WE DO- THANK OUR- YOU'LL SEE
PARTNERS- IN THE COUNTY. WHO
HAVE BEEN VERY RESPONSIBLE NOT.
TESTING AS WELL REAL TIME WE
HAD NO TESTING THEN SOME
TESTING AND NOW MORE TESTING
BUT- NOW WE HAVE. LET'S SAY
SPORADIC INTERRUPTIONS OTHER
CAUSES TO SHUT DOWN. FOR A DAY
OR TWO OR THREE AT A TIME
EQUIPMENT ACQUISITIONS-
VENTILATORS PRIMARILY- THE
STATE WAS VERY QUICK TO REACT
AS WELL AS OUR COUNTY YOU'LL
SEE. A TO A PROVIDED SOME
TRANSPORT LAYERS. BUT THEY'RE
NOT INTENDED REALLY FOR LONG
TERM USE- REGGIE OPERATIONS
ABOUT HER SUPPORT HAS BEEN
GREAT- AS I MENTIONED THE
RPG'S- THEY PROVIDED AND ARE
QUICK RESPONSIVENESS THEIR
GREATLY APPRECIATE I THINK THAT
THE ORGANIZATION OF THE MURDERS
THE RESPONSE HAS BEEN A MUCH
GREATER THAN I EVER EXPECTED-
THE TRANSFER CENTER HAS BEEN
VERY PROMPT AND DAVE DUNCAN
THIS BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE.
NATIONAL GUARD THAT THEY
PROVIDED WAS MUCH NEEDED AND
JUST IN TIME. AS FAR AS
SUGGESTIONS GO. AND WE LOOK TO
SEE THAT- IN THE FUTURE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO- COORDINATE OUR OUR
MEETINGS AND OUR EMAILS AND- IT
STARTED PLAN MORE ON. IT'S EASY
TO ADD NEW SPACE IS MORE
DIFFICULT TO ADD STAFF AND
THOSE WERE PRIORITIZING NEEDS I
DO SEE THAT THE YOU'LL SEE IS
REALLY STRONGLY SUPPORTING US
MORE IN- STAFF NEEDS WHICH IS
WHAT REALLY NEED BECAUSE THERE
IS EXISTING SPACE. IT JUST
NEEDS TO HAPPEN TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE THAT. WE SHOULD STAND UP
THE FACILITIES FIRST AND THAT
COMES WITH STAFFING AS FAR AS
LOW SHORT TERM FUTURE OF CHANGE.
I TO GO CHANGES THE DIFFICULT
WHAT WE SEE IS THE LIONS
CONTINUE TO INCREASE THE
TRANSFERS CONTINUE TO INCREASE.
AND THERE'S NO EMINENT VACCINE
OR CURE IDENTIFIED IN THE NEXT
SIX TO TWELVE MONTHS. SO IT'S
ABOUT PLANNING FOR THE CHANGE
AND AS I MENTIONED BEFORE NOW
IT'S NOT ABOUT DEALING WITH THE
CRISIS IS AN ONGOING WAY OF
LIFE NOW- AT LEAST FOR THE NEXT
TWELVE MONTHS. SO RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED- I LOOK FIRST TO
YOU KNOW THERE ARE MORE
PLENTIFUL SUPPLIES AVAILABLE.
BUT I'LL CALL IT OR WAITED TO
FOOD INSECURITY IT'S SUPPLY AND
SECURITY- WE DON'T KNOW WHEN
THE NEXT SHIPMENT WILL BE OR
HOW BIG THOSE ORDERS ARE GOING
TO DEMAND A WELDER- A SUPPLIER
WHETHER IT CUT BACK ON- BUT WE
HAVE SEEN GREAT INCREASES OF
NAS'S. BEEN VERY HELPFUL.
THERE'S OUR URGENT NEED FOR
TREATMENT RESOURCE ARE ALL
RAPID TESTING- ORDERS ARE NOT
RELIABLE- WE RUN SHORTLY A
SHORT REGULARLY- I DID HEAR
FROM THE NATIONAL GUARD THIS
MORNING WHICH I WAS A GREAT TO
HEAR- I THINK ON SATURDAY
ALTHOUGH THEY WERE IN ON THE US
STATES VISIT. OUT TO THE
COUNTY. AND HEARD ABOUT THE-
LOCAL GOT A SHORTAGE OF THOSE
SUPPLIES FOR A BY A FIRE. THIS
MORNING THEY CALL THE SAID
THAT- THEY EXPECT TO BE DOWN
HERE SHORTLY- WITH WILDFIRE AND
SUPPLIES AND STAFF TO RUN IT-
SO THAT'S LOGISTICS IS BEING
WORKED OUT RIGHT NOW- FROM
DOUBLE ZERO OF THE STATE YOUR
PHARMACEUTICAL TREATMENT
REGIMEN IS ALSO A SHORTAGE OUT
THERE- THERE HAVE BEEN.
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES AND I DID
HEAR THAT WE WERE DUE ANY DAY
NOW TO RECEIVE THE NEXT UP
FRONT- BUT AGAIN WE'RE GETTING
BACK TO UP THERE'S BEEN GREAT
IMPROVEMENTS AND NOW IT'S ABOUT
THE IN SECURITY ARE WE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP THAT UP. AND
WILL KEEP GROWING IN NEED OUT
THERE. REGISTRY WE TAPPED INTO
A TWENTY CRITICAL CARE NURSES-
TEN OF WHICH WE EXPECT TO SEE
BY MONDAY- ONE ADDITIONAL
INTENSE WAS TO HELP RELIEVE THE
ONLY OTHER CRITICAL CARE
POSITION NOW AND THE BALLOT-
FOR OUR TEAS AND TELL YOUR MEN
SURGICAL- NURSES OUT THERE. BUT
THE NEED IS REALLY GOING TO BE
HOUSE SUPPORT. AT A REGISTRY
PREMIUM COSTS SO THERE IS GOING
TO BE A NEED FOR INCREASED
FUNDING IN THE FUTURE. REAL
TIME NEEDS OF. CONTINUOUS
SUPPORT FOR SAFE EXPANSION AND
THE ALTERNATIVE LEGAL LICENSE
SPACE- WE APPRECIATE THAT- THE
STATE- CITY PH HAVE ALL BEEN
VERY HELPFUL IN ALLOWING US TO
QUICKLY TRANSITION SPACE LIKE
AN ALTAR SOUNDS BY USE OF THE
ICE YOU BILLS. THEY END UP END
UP MOVING OUR OF ULTRASOUND AND
RPG SPACE. TRANSITIONS FROM
IMMEDIATE YEAR NEED SPACE TO
PERMANENTLY AVAILABLE SPACE IS
GONNA BE NEEDED- THAT IS THERE
TODAY BUT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
CONTINUE THAT. AND THEN THE
LONG TERM FUTURE- JUST YET TO
BE DEFINED I THINK THE SHELTER
AND IMPACT. HAS A GREAT UNKNOWN
OUT THERE ABOUT HOW THIS BILL
CHANGE SOCIETY ON A LONG TERM-
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND- TV'S.
VIRUS IMPACT ON TRAVEL AND- AND
HOSPITALS AS A PLACE TO HEAL AS
A PLACE AS OPPOSED TO A PLACE
TO AVOID BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS.
ALL OF THOSE ARE GOING TO HAVE
A GREAT. LONG TERM IMPACTS OF
PRIMARY CARE IN RURAL AREAS IS
ALWAYS NEEDED. I THINK THE
FINAL FOR THE CONCLUSION HERE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
REPEATING KIND OF WHAT CHRIS
IT'S A- SOCIAL DISTANCING
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE WORKING-
IT IS NEEDED BUT AS YOU OVERLY
HOLIDAYS WITH THE- INCREASES
AND- TRANSFERS OUT OF HERE AND
THE INCREASING SENSE US. IT'S
HARD TO TELL HOW WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO CHANGE THE SOCIAL
NORM OF MAYBE BY COMMUNICATING
YOUR TESTIMONIALS OF THOSE IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT NO AND ARE
KNOWN AND TRUSTED- IN ANY CASE
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CHANGE FOR A LONGER TERM
SOLUTION. I JUST WANT TO ASK
YOU THE RESUME I'M SORRY IT
INTERRUPT YOU AT THAT YOU'RE
FINISHED BUT I WANT TO ASK YOU
THERE WAS IN IT- OF COURSE A
DISASTER UP IN IRELAND YOUR THE
HOSPITAL CLOSEST TO AN ISLAND-
OVER FORTY WHO HOMES WERE
BURNED FAMILIES WERE DISPLACING
OF COURSE ARE BEING HELD
INTERPRET FACILITIES RIGHT NOW
AND I HOPE. THERE HEALTH IS
BEING UP. PROTECT WALK THROUGH
THIS CRISIS THE THIRD DURING.
BUT I WANT TO ASK- DID THAT TO.
AFFECT THE OPERATIONS OF THE
HOSPITAL DID YOU SEE AN
ADMISSIONS TO YOUR HOSPITAL
RELATED TO THAT THAT
COMPLICATED THINGS. I DID NOT I
DID NOT HEAR ABOUT THAT
SPECIFICALLY SO I WOULD ONLY
SAY THAT- WE WERE IMMEDIATELY
MADE AWARE AND OUR ORGANIZATION
OUR STAFF OF ALL. BEGUN TO
ACCUMULATE- RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED OUT THERE- THERE'S A
GREAT RESPONSE GOING ON
INCLUDING THE APPLYING YOUR
FAMILY. HAVE YOU BEEN AT ALL IN
COMMUNICATION WITH OR IN
PARTNERSHIP FOR COOPERATION
WITH THE OFFICE OF BI NATIONAL
BORDER HEALTH. IN IMPERIAL
VALLEY IS SETS ASIDE BEEN. HEY
THE IS IF YOU KNOW THE CAL THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OFFICE OF BY NOR BY NATIONAL
BORDER HEALTH THE COORDINATES
BETWEEN MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA
ON HEALTH MATTERS. IS THAT ARE
YOU ENGAGE WITH THAT ARE YOU
AWARE OF IT IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN USING AS A
SOURCE OF POTENTIAL RESOURCES.
I DO LEARN FROM THEM. I'M NOT A
REGULAR PARTICIPANT IN THEIR
MEETINGS BUT- I DO PARTICIPATE.
AND THE RESPOND WHEN I ASKED
SO- I DO THINK IT'S A GOOD
RESOURCE TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE ACROSS BORDERS-
AND- LEARN HOW WE CAN HELP EACH
OTHER- BUT THAT'S THAT. I DON'T
HAVE ANY OTHER ALL. JUST RIGHT
NOW DO YOU FEEL THAT THERE'S
BEEN AN OUT REACH BY THE
OFFICE. TO HELP YOU DURING THIS
CRISIS. I DID NOT HEAR FROM
THEM DIRECTLY NOW OKAY THANK
YOU. UP WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO-
DOCTOR EIGHT OFF AT WORK WITH
L. CENTROS- REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER. DOCTOR ARE YOU HERE.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO LISTEN TO OUR INPUT AND- FOR
ALL THAT YOU WILL DO TO ASSIST
IMPERIAL COUNTY TO FIGHT BACK-
AGAINST THIS CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC YOUR HELP AND SUPPORT
IS REQUESTED. NEEDED AND
APPRECIATED ESPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BEN HUESO WHO HAS
BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
C. R. M. C. THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER. I'M THE CEO OF YOU SEE
OUR I'M SEEIN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN UC SAN DIEGO
HEALTH AS MANAGER YOU SEE OUR
MC OUR CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER
OUR HIGHER MEDICAL EVEN THE
EDIE AND I AR OLD. UC SAN
DIEGO HEALTH EMPLOYEES AND HAND
STATE ASSETS. ON THE EIGHTEENTH
OF FEBRUARY ECR MC STOOD UP
WHAT'S OPERATIONS COMMAND
CENTER WE PUT OUR ENTIRE TEAM
ON HIGH ALERT. AND I THINK THIS
SITE THANK THE- MEDICAL SERVICE
IN THE AIRFORCE FOR MY TWENTY
TWO AND A HALF YEARS SERVICE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO LEARN ABOUT
THAT ON OR ABOUT EIGHT MORE
SHINAN SO THE RESIDENTS OF
IMPERIAL VALLEY. THE ARRIVAL OF
OUR FIRST SCHOOL WITH NINETEEN
CASE THE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
TRAVEL TO SEE THEIR KIDS IN
MEXICO IN FLORIDA AND THEY WERE
IN THIRTY THROUGH ATLANTA
GEORGIA. ONCE REMEMBER SINCE.
THIS IS ONE OF THEM STORE THAT
HAVE BECOME THE NORMAL SO
INSTEAD DAY. ACT OF COVERT TO
THOSE WHO HAVE LOS THEIR FOR
MEMBERS IS DEVASTATING AND NO
DOUBT ESTRANGED LIVES FOREVER.
WE HAVE SEEN A NONSTOP
INCREASING CASES AT LEAST YOUR-
SEASONS THAT DAY INCLUDING AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CASES
COMING FROM MEXICO. ACROSS THE
BORDER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND US CITIZENS WILL
LIVE IN MEXICALI INCLUDE
THIRTY. THOUSAND RETIRED US NOT
THE EVENTS FROM VETERANS LIKE
MYSELF AND THOUSANDS OF GREEN
CARD HOLDERS ACROSS THE BORDER.
BUT ALSO REMEMBER THEIR SIXTY
MEMBERS OF MY STAFF THAT WORK
HERE OUT OF THE ELEVEN HUNDRED
LIVE IN MEXICALI AND THERE ARE
ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES AND THEY DO
TRAVEL BACK AND FORTH. MANY OF
THESE FOLKS THAT TRAVEL DEL
CENTRO ON OUR HOSPITAL SEE
CARE. YOU SEE ARMS HE DOES NOT
ASK PATIENTS ABOUT THEIR
NATIONAL ORIGIN THEIR ETHNICITY
SEX OR EVEN HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE. AND SO WE ARE UNDER
THE CARE MANY. BESIDE THE FIVE
HUNDRED PATIENTS THAT YOU FOR
DEBT BEEN TRANSFERRED SENSE.
YOU SEE OUR M. C. HAS HAD
SERVED OVER WELL TWO THOUSAND
PATIENTS SINCE OUR FIRST CASES
IN MARCH. DALY WE SEE A HUNDRED
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE OR
MORE PATIENTS THAT COME TO OUR
ET. AND ONE DAY IN MAY WE HAD
SIXTY FIVE PLUS COVERT PATIENTS
IN THE HOSPITAL THAT HAD A
HUNDRED AND TEN PATIENTS THAT
60% OF OUR PATIENTS WORK OVER
THE BOSS THAT. INITIALLY WE
USED TO TRANSFER TO THE THREE
PATIENTS EACH DAY FOR CARE WE
COULD NOT PROVIDE. BUT NOW
WE'RE TRANSFERRING FIVE TO TEN
PATIENTS DAILY YOU THE
EXCESSIVE OVER HERE NEEDED.
THAT WE CAN ALL KEEP ADDING TO
OUR LIMITED CAPACITY FACILITY
WHICH IS CONSTRAINED BY BOTH
SIDES AND STAFFING LIMITS AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THERE. WE
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF CASES AS WELL FROM
OUR OWN COMMUNITY MEMBERS WILL
TRAVEL TO YUMA ARIZONA AND
OTHER LOCATIONS IN THE
VICINITY. AND HAVE BEEN OPENED.
THESE MEMBERS RETURN BACK TO
THE. VALLEY INCOME FOR THE-
WITH COVERT SYMPTOMS. YOU SEE
ARMS LAW TO ME. DOLLARS A THE
FIRST THE OTHER WITH KOBE IN
FEDERAL. AND HAVE LOST MILLION
EACH TO MONTHS THEN. THE
FEDERAL CARES ACT FUNDS HAVE
DRIED UP FAST. ADDITIONALLY
HOSPITAL LIKE OURS WILL BE
RECEIVING ADDITIONAL RENDON'S
OF YOUR ALLEGATIONS. UNDER THE
AGREEMENT IS THE ARM SEE HAS
BEEN USING THE DRAW AND WITH
ENCOURAGING RESULTS. BY WILL
NOW HAVE TO PAY THE WHOLE SALE
ACQUISITION PRICE FOR THE DRUG.
WHICH IS ABOUT THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER TREATMENT
FORCE. WHICH AMERISOURCEBERGEN
LIKELY TO SHIFT FOR US EVERY
TWO WEEKS. THE PROBLEM IS THIS
ADDS HALF A MILLION DOLLAR OF
EXPENSES. OUR BOTTOM LINE WHICH
WE DO NOT HAVE. AND WE WILL
NEED HELP COVERING THOSE COSTS.
WE HAVE RECEIVED PLENTY OF HELP
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHICH HAD DO DISASTER MEDICAL
ASSISTANT DEMOBILIZE AND HELP
US WAS. WE ALL HAD THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MOBILIZED NEWLY MINTED
OUR INSTEAD FOCUS WHICH HAD THE
AIRFORCE RESERVES SEND US THE
TEAM OF CLINICAL THERAPISTS AND
DOCTORS WE HAVE LEARNED THAT
THAT THEY WILL STAY WITH US
UNTIL THE FIFTEENTH OF JULY
TWENTY TWENTY AND WE CANNOT
THANK THEIR NATIONAL GUARD FOR
THAT EXTENSION. WE CANNOT THANK
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL RESPONSE
SYSTEM AND- YES HEADED BY DR
DAVE DUNCAN FOR ALL THE HELP
THAT HE'S PROVIDED US HE AS
WELL AS OUR COUNTRY COUNTY
HEROES OF THE MST. HAVE
ARRANGED FOR FULL AIR GROUND AN
EMERGENCY REQUEST OFF LOCATIONS
INTO OTHER FACILITIES AND OTHER
COUNTIES WHEN WE NEEDEDIT THE
MOST. WITH THIS HE HAD NOT DONE
SO I ASSURE YOU WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN OVER ONE. WE ALSO HAVE
SHARED OUR NEEDS WITH MANY HIGH
RANKING STATE OFFICIALS
INCLUDING A RECENT RECENT VISIT
BY DOCTOR SONYA ANGEL. DUST
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER IN THE
DIRECTOR OF CD PH. WE INFORM
THEIR THAT THE DESIGN AND THE
DELIVERY OF THE FEDERAL
ALTERNATE CARE SITES IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY WAS LACKING THE
RIGHT SUPPORT CYCLE. WE NEED
THE EIGHTY BED STATE YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE HIGHER LEVELS OF
CARE SO THAT WEEKEND OUR ICY
USE SO WE CAN CONTINUE ON.
INCLUDE MORE PATIENTS AS THEY
COME THROUGH ALREADY. FOR THAT
REASON WE'RE ASKING FOR YOU
THIS SUPPORT THEIR STRATEGIES
TO HELP US BY STAFFING AND
MANNING SO THAT WE CAN STOP
THEIR ALLIANCE OF TRANSFERRING
PATIENTS OUT OF TOWN. AS
HOSPITALS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY-
ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BEGIN TO FILL UP WITH OVER THE
PATIENTS OUR PATIENTS STAY WITH
US INDEED THE WAITING TO BE
TRANSFERRED. SOMETIMES IN
EXCESS OF THREE DAYS AND THIS
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE. WE RECEIVE
MANY REASONS FOR THE DELAYS OF
BEING TRANSFERRED SOME OF IT
RELATED TO EVEN BE SURE
INSURANCE. WE'VE ASKED THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
FOR HELP. AND HAVE SINCE HELPED
US WE NEED TO STOP OUR RELIANCE
ON TRANSFERRING TO UC IS THE
AND OTHER LOCATIONS WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY ESTABLISHED PATIENT
CARE AND ABOUT. AN INCREASE
THAT CARE OUR FIRST HOUSE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONTINUE.
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT EASY
TO HAVE ALL THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO MAKE CRITICAL CARE
AND I SEE OKAY ARE READILY
AVAILABLE. IT IS EXPENSIVE AND
PROVIDED THROUGH THE NEEDS THAT
ARE DOING WHAT MOUNTS OF EIGHT
THE SHARED. SETS WITH US AND
CRITICAL CARE NEEDED.
INTENSIFIED AND OTHER. IF YOU
ARE ASKING ME TODAY WHAT DO I
NEED TO EXPAND MY IC IF
ABILITY. EITHER SIMPLE FOR I
SEE YOUR DOCTORS TWENTY EIGHT
OUR ENDS FOURTEEN RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS AND TWENTY
ADDITIONAL EVENTS. IN ADDITION
TO ALL VENTS WE RECEIVED
THROUGH THEIR COUNTY RESPONSE
TEAM AND THROUGH THE STATE. WE
MIGHT ALSO UC'S. ANSWER I HAVE
A TO DELIVER MODEL OUR I USE
BECAUSE OF ORDER. WE CONTINUE
TO THE STUFF WE NEED BY USE. TO
MACY S. THAT WILL ASK IN HAND
OUR NEW TO ASK. FOR THIS KIND
OF MANPOWER. FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO HELP DELIVER
HERE NEAR HOME. WITH CLOSE 230%
OF UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND WITH
43% OF OUR PATIENTS ON
MEDICAID. WE WILL CONTINUE NEED
HELP GETTING FOR OUR COMMUNITY
BEYOND TODAY. WE ARE THANKFUL
FOR ALL THE HELP THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED US SO
FAR. HOWEVER IMPERIAL COUNTY
NEEDS THE STATE'S HELP STOP OUR
RELIANCE ON A TRANSFER SYSTEM
THAT MAY BE NON EXISTENCE IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS IF COVERT
OPERATIONS INCREASE ACROSS THE
STATE. WE NEED MORE STATE
SUPPORT STAFF US WAR SUPPORTERS.
SALIM SO WE CAN AFFORD IT SO
OUR STUDENTS. WE HAVE SPENDING
OVER ONE POINT I'VE NOT DOLLARS
A MONTH. ON EXTRA HELP AND
RESOURCES THROUGH STAFFING
AGENCIES THIS IS NOT ANYTHING
NEW WE'RE GONNA NEED. MORE
HOUSE OUR SECOND. IS THAT WE DO
NOT FOR YOU SEE OUR MC AND
OTHER HOSPITALS THE RELY ON
THIS. SHARE HOSPITAL DOLLARS
THREE FORTY B. PROGRAM AND THE
STATE CRIME PROGRAM AND MORE
STATE FUNDING STREAMS JUST TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. PLEASE
DISCOURAGE ANY CUTS IN THESE
PROGRAMS OR BOTH HOSPITALS. WE
ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT OUR VALLEY.
AND YOU SEE OUR MC IS HEARING
SHOWS YOUR COMMITMENT AND
SUPPORT FOR OUR HEALTH CARE
MISSION THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS AND I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THAT YOU
CAME UP WITH A VERY SPECIFIC
NEED LIST OF YOUR NEEDS AND
THAT MAKES IT EASIE FOR US TO
WORK ON SATISFYING YOUR REQUEST.
IT'S A VERY MUCH AND EVERYONE
ELSE THAT'S ON THIS CALL THAT
ON AND ON THIS PANEL THAT ARE
PER HAVE PARTICIPATED. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO-
FIVE TRY TO BRIDGE THAT GAP TO.
OF FUNDING IN OR PROVIDING-
THOSE NEEDS TO THOSE AREAS THAT
THE NEEDHAM SO- ANYTHING YOU
CAN DO TO FORWARD A SPECIFIC
LIST FOR OFFICE. AND TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SO WE CAN
WORK DILIGENTLY TO SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS AND- ENSURE THAT ARE.
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE ARE
CARED FOR WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
SUGGESTS MANDEL. HE IS- THE
MEDICAL DOCTOR OF THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR UC SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. DOCTOR WELCOME THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US WE REALLY
APPRECIATE. HAVING YOU JOIN US
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SURE
HUESO INSURE GONZALEZ THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME HERE TO TESTIFY
TODAY. ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
SENATOR HUESO FOR RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT THE CODE
NINETEEN SITUATION ON THE
BORDER. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
HIM FOR HIS STRONG SUPPORTER OF
UC SAN DIEGO UC SAN DIEGO
HEALTH OVER THE YEARS AND
STRONG COMMITMENT DURING THE
SAN DIEGO REGION. PRESLEY TWO
MONTHS AGO PHYSICIANS AND SAN
DIEGO BECAME CONCERNED ABOUT
THE WORSENING OF THE NINETEEN
EPIDEMIC IN TIJUANA. WITH
ASSISTANCE FROM THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH WE
ARE ABLE TO MAKE CONTACT WITH
DOCTOR REYES GIVE ME UP THE
DIRECTOR IF YOU WANT TO GENERAL
HOSPITAL AND ARRANGE A VISIT IN
EARLY MAY BY SAN DIEGO
PHYSICIANS NURSES. CREATION WAS
VERY SO. AS THEY WERE BOTH IN
OVER NUMBER OF CLOTHING.
PATIENTS AND A DECREASED NUMBER
OF PHYSICIANS AND NURSES. MANY
HAD CONTRACTED CODE NINETEEN
WERE REQUIRED R. G. AT WHOLE.
ADDITIONALLY ALL MEXICANS OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO WORK BECAUSE THE
pTO HAZARDOUS THEIR HOUSE. MANY
HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN MEXICO
ARE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY SO
THIS FURTHER COMPOUNDED THE
PROBLEM. WE HAD OUR MEXICAN
CALLING DECIDED THAT WE CAN
BEST ASSIST BY STARTING DAILY
BUSINESS OF SAN DIEGO
PHYSICIANS AND NURSES DID FEEL
WANTED GENERAL. SEVEN DAYS PER
WEEK FOR FOUR WEEKS IN ORDER TO
ROUND IN PERSON. THE MOST
CRITICALLY ILL AND THE MOST
CHALLENGING PATIENTS WITH
RESPIRATORY FAILURE UNICODE
NINETEEN. SAN DIEGO COUNTY
MEDICAL SOCIETY AND I CALLING
DOCTOR ANDRES MISS A SHARP TOOL
THIS. ASSISTED IN RECRUITMENT
AND SUPPORT BETWEEN MAY
EIGHTEENTH. JUNE FOURTEENTH.
DURING THAT PERIOD WE MAY
TWENTY EIGHT CONSECUTIVE DAILY
BUSINESS AND INCLUDED A
CRITICAL CARE PHYSICIANS. TO
INFECTIOUS DISEASE PHYSICIANS
FOR RESPIRATORY THERAPISTS
TWENTY NINE CRITICAL CARE
NURSES AND FOR TRANSLATORS. AS
WELL AS EXTENSIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE COORDINATION
PROVIDED BY UC SAN DIEGO. BASED
ON THE- OF THESE TEAM MEMBERS
WE PERCENT OF A HOSPITAL
DIRECTOR IF YOU WANT TO GENERAL
WITH DETAILED SUGGESTIONS FOR
IMPROVEMENTS IN CARE IN
MULTIPLE AREAS. THESE WERE
RECEIVED WITH ENTHUSIASTS. WE
ARE NOW SEEING SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT PROCESS THESE OF
CARE IN TIJUANA WE THAT WE ARE
SEEING IMPROVEMENTS IN PATIENT
OUTCOMES AS WELL. AT THE SAME
TIME THAT WE WERE DOING THIS WE
ALSO RAISED ALMOST FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR THE PURCHASE
EQUIPMENT FOR TIJUANA GENERAL
HOSPITAL. WE PURCHASED
DESPERATELY NEEDED BEST I'D
MONITORING EQUIPMENT FOR
MECHANICALLY VENTILATED
PATIENCE. AND ALSO FIRST
PURCHASED UNIFICATION EQUIPMENT
FOR THE REGULATORS WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR SAFELY
MECHANICALLY BATTLING PATIENTS.
PROBABLY NINETEEN WHO MAY
REQUIRE THIS THERE ARE SEVERAL
WEEKS. FOLLOWING COMPLETION OF
THE DAILY IN PERSON SUPPORT AT
TIJUANA GENERAL WE'VE CONTINUE
THE COLLABORATION BY A TELE
CONFRONTATIONS SAN DIEGO SOME
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
VENTILATED PATIENTS TWO TO
THREE TIMES PER WEEK. BECAUSE
OUR SUCCESSFUL COLLABORATION
WITH YOU ON A GENERAL BUT THREE
WEEKS AGO WE RECEIVED AN
INVITATION FOR A GROUP TO VISIT
NEXT COUNTY GENERAL HOSPITAL
AND TO TRY TO ASSIST THERE AS
WELL. WE VISITED THERE AND JUNE
ELEVENTH AND OVERALL WE ARE
IMPRESSED WITH THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE CHALLENGE AFTER FACING AS
WELL AS HOW WELL THEY'RE TRYING
TO HANDLE IT. WORKING WITH A
HOSPITAL DIRECTOR DR- BY EIGHT
HE STARTED TELEMEDICINE
COLLABORATION WITH THEM AS WELL
AS WELL IN PLANNED INTENTIONAL
INPATIENT BUSINESS INCLUDING
ONE TOMORROW. FOCUSED ON A
SPECIFIC INITIATIVES RELATED TO
CROWN VENTILATION PRESSURE ALSO
PREVENTION AND OTHER
INTERVENTIONS TO IMPROVE
PATIENT OUTCOMES. WITH BOTH
THE- AND MEXICALI WE WILL BE
INVITING PHYSICIANS AND NURSES.
FROM THE HOSPITALS THEY ARE TOO
BUSY UCSD AND JOIN US IN
ROUNDING AND CALL THE NINETEEN
PATIENTS. AS WELL AS INVITING
PHYSICIANS THERE TO JOIN OUR
TEACHING CONFERENCES EACH WEEK
RISE. IT MAY BE POSSIBLE TO
COMBINE SOME OF THE BUSINESS
THE SAN DIEGO SOME OF THE
TELEMEDICINE INITIATIVES
BETWEEN BIRTH TIJUANA AND
MEXICALI. THE HOPE OF
STRENGTHENING COLLABORATION AND
CROSSTALK BETWEEN THESE TWO
IMPORTANT BAJA CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS AND INCLUDING OTHER
HOSPITALS IN TIJUANA AS WELL. I
SHOULD THAT ADDITION TO
ASSISTING TIJUANA AND MEXICALI
UC SAN DIEGO HAS BEEN WORKING
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
NEAR THE BORDER WERE IMPACTED
BY THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING BOTH THE
I SEE YOU IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT AL CENTRAL REGIONAL
MEDICAL CENTER WAS PHYSICIAN
BOOTS ON THE GROUND. DIRECTLY
PROVIDE CARE AND ALSO WITH
TELEMEDICINE SUPPORT TRUST
CENTRO FROM SAN DIEGO. OUR
MOBILE TEAM HAS GONE EL CENTRO
INTO TRUE OF THIS AND TO
STABILIZE THE STATUS OF THE
STATE'S. TRANSPORT THEM BACK TO
UC SAN DIEGO FOR FURTHER CARE.
INCLUSION WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT OUR COLLEAGUES IN
MEXICO DURING AN UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES OF THE CALL THAT
NINETEEN. THE MEXICAN
PHYSICIANS AND NURSES WITH WHOM
WE COLLABORATE ARE EXTREMELY
DEDICATED SMART AND HARD
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THEIR
PATIENTS AND WE HAVE LEARNED A
GREAT DEAL FROM THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND PERSPECTIVES.
TRULY THESE EFFORTS TO HELP
PATIENTS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE.
THESE COLLABORATIONS FAR INTO
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
ALREADY TODAY AND FOR ALL
YOU'RE DOING. THANK YOU DOCTOR
AND I THINK I SPEAK FOR THE
ENTIRE LEGISLATURE- FOR ALL
EVERYONE EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY
PROVIDING THE FRONTLINE OF
SUPPORT. ALL THE ALL THE
DIRECTORS ALL THE DOCTORS ALL
THE NURSES ALL THE SUPPORT.
STAFF ALL THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE STAFF EVERYONE THAT'S
HELPING WITH THIS CRISIS. FROM
THE BOTTOM OF OUR HEARTS WERE
VERY GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK AND YOUR DEDICATION
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY AND ON AGAIN. WE'RE DOING
OUR BEST HERE TO PROVIDE OF.
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR THE
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE SO PLEASE.
WE INVITE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH US AND ASK HOW
WE CAN SUPPORT YOU MORE. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT UP PANEL.
REGARDING VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WE ALL KNOW HOW
THIS PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED TO
OUR OUR ABILITY TO COVER
EVERYONE EQUITABLY ACROSS THE
STATE AND THERE ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE SEEN. A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF COVE
IT. NOT ONLY IN IN THE HEALTH
ARENA BUT ALSO. A IN THE-
ECONOMIC. OF FRONTS- OF SO. THE
ECONOMIC AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACTS OF COVERT NINETEEN WILL
BE A SHARED WITH US BY THE
MAYOR OF IMPERIAL BEACH SEARCH
TO DENY HE'S ALSO THE CHAIR OF
THE SENDER BORDERS COMMITTEE.
AND HE'S SUCH A- UNIQUELY WERE
OF THE IMPACTS OF IT ALONG THE
BORDER BEING THAT HE REPRESENTS
THE SOUTHERNMOST STATE. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
HAVE KATE CLARK SHE'S A SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRATION
SERVICES FOR THE JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICES CENTER. AND WE ALSO
HAVE LEASE OR MIDDLE OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS THE SEQUEL
OF THE **** THE VALUE OUT THERE
IN PER COUNTY DOING A WONDERFUL
JOB OF PROVIDING. SUPPORT FOR
THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
IN FIGHTING FOR AIR QUALITY
JOBS AND SO MANY OTHER THINGS.
WERE VERY VERY HONORED TO HAVE
WE SHOULD MEDDLE WITH US TODAY
WE'RE GONNA BE IN BEGIN WITH
MER- SEARCH TO THE NO WELCOME.
MAYOR MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH OUR SERVER WAS ALWAYS
ONE OF THE STATE AND SAY GOOD
MORNING TO SERVER HUESO SERVER
GONZALEZ AND CONSUL GENERALS
ARE AN ECHO ARE YOUR KNOWLEDGE
IN THE WEST OF THE MOVING
TESTIMONY OF OUR MEDICAL
WORKERS IN LEADERS OFTEN TO
JOURNALISTS IN YOUR COUNTY TO
KNOWLEDGE CITY. COUNCIL HER
OKAY COURAGEOUS ARE INSPIRING
WORK EVEN CARRYING OUT WE DO
APPRECIATE IT GREATLY- ALL MY
TO MARYLAND CITY TO DRILL BEACH
THE SOUTHERNMOST TURN ON THE
CALIFORNIA COAST TRUE BORDER
CITY THE CHAIR IS SENT OUT
BORDERS SAID I'M THE SENATE
ALSO STATION OF GOVERNMENT IS
THE REGIONAL COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS IN THE METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATION. FOR THE
SAN DIEGO REGION AND ALSO
SERVING AS A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCY
SAID IT IS THE ONLY GOVERNMENT
AGENCY REGIONAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDES MEXICO BI THREE NUMBER
ON OUR GOVERNING BODY THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS AND WE HAVE A
BORDERS COMMITTEE WHICH
PROVIDES OVERSIGHT FOR PLANNING
ACTIVITIES BUT IN FACT THE
BORDERS OF THE SENATE OR REGION
ARE COUNTY BORDERS ARE TRIBAL
BORDERS AS WELL AS- FAR AS OUR
BORDER WITH MEXICO. AND THE
COMMITTEE ON WHY NATIONAL
REGIONAL NEWS BY NATIONAL
WORKING GROUP OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND STAKEHOLDERS FROM
ACADEMIA THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND CIVIL SOCIETY- ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER THAT
ADDRESSES OUR OUR NATIONAL
CHALLENGES LAST FRIDAY WE NOT
EVEN HEARD FROM CALTRANS ON ITS
GRANTS PLANNING FOR A BI
NATIONAL. STRUCTURE PROJECTS
WHICH IS MOST. PHONE I DON'T
REALLY NEED TO SAY THIS AND OR
LIKE THE TO COME ALL BEEN AS
WELL MEXICO ARM THESE EXTRA
TIME DUE TO THE GLOBAL.
PANDEMIC HEALTH PRICE BUT ALL
AS PART OF OUR CONTINUOUS WITH
EQUALITY SOCIAL INJUSTICE YES
WE AGAIN. IN THE ISSUE OF IN
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE AND HOW THIS
KIND OF IS OUT BOTH IN TERMS OF
WHO'S GOING. OUR BORDER WITH
MEXICO IS REMAINING THIS IS
YOUR- OPERATING WITH RESEARCH.
ON WHAT US. TO RETURN THE
COUNTRY. WILL ALSO FROM A SENSE
WORKERS TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY
TO KEEP HER LINE. OPERATE YOU
KNOW SO YOU CAN ONLY AND SOCIAL
INTEGRATION SEND YOUR WITH OUR
NAY. ARE TO THE SOUTH AND SO.
THE MANY THE AND NOT LATE
THEY'RE ABOUT CAN DOWN.
INDUSTRY UNDER CERTAIN THROW BY
NOW ONE IN FREE I THINK IT'S
HEARD MANY SAN DIEGO SIR SECTOR
JOBS SERVICES CENTRAL. OUR JOB.
ARE HELD PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
INTO QUORUM. ON WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE THOUSAND OF AMERICAN
FROM BYRD WHILE FROST BORDER
GET. MEDICAL SYSTEMS THE SUMMER
PROBABLY NINETY IS IN. ALL OVER
TO. BUT A RE REPORT BY. HIGH
SOME REALLY IMPACT CRITICAL IN
FRONT. DEVASTATING RESEARCH
PROGRAMS. AND IT'S JUST AFTER
STINT ON THE COMMUNITIES LOW
EXPO TO THE ECONOMIC AND HEALTH.
AND WE'RE GONNA SO THE FIRST
LIGHT PLEASE SECONDS. ON THE
MAP THE LEFT THE SLIDE SHOWS
YOU AREAS IN THIS A REGION OR
HARDEST BY. THE MAN ON THE
RIGHT SHOWS THAT THERE IS AND
HOW THE HIGHEST. RATES OF.
PERFORMANCE I DON'T WANT TO
SEND TO TRY AS A TO JUST.
COMMUNITIES FOR MISTER
CALAVERAS. COOL SO TRULY TO WHY
LOOK AT THE COLOR ON USED MOUNT
THE AREA THAT X. THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT OR THE IS A- GOOD
MY CODE. WHERE YOU SEE THE
INTERSECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WAS ROLES YOU KNOW. INEQUITY
NOT SAY THERE'S THIS IS A CON
WALKING BEGINNING BECAUSE ONLY
MEAN ONE BECAUSE YOUR BUT
THERE'S- A CORRELATION. THE
NEXT STEP OF THE CENTER NOW
THROUGH IDENTIFIED THAT COME TO
BOTH THE HIGH CASE OF ON. AND
HERE'S WHERE YOU CAN SEE WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR ORDER REACHING
THERE'S- ZIP CODES IS SENDING
COUNTY THAT ARE THE TOP 25% FOR
HIGHEST LEVEL OF UNEMPLOYMENT
AND CORPORATE WHAT WE CAN TELL
FROM THE DAY IS A PANDEMIC IN
THOSE WHO WORKED INDUSTRIES ARE
SHUT DOWN LIKE TO RE
HOSPITALITY MAINSTAY OF THE SAN
COM. BUT THAT DOES WERE WORKED.
WHILE MOST OF US FOR SHELTER
PLACE AND THOSE THAT COULD STAY
HOME SO YOU KNOW WHAT SEE WITH
THE FIRST. DOCTORS AND
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE THE FUEL
YOU CAN ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
THE NORTH SUPPLY COULD LINES
THERE ARE. WHAT THE UNDER LIGHT
SO WHAT WHAT THIS. RESEARCH
SHOWS IS THAT BLACK AND
HISPANIC PART. ARE OVER. IN
THESE HIGH. ESSENTIAL. IS THERE
ARE THERE AT RISK OF LOSING JOB
OR HIGH RISK OF EXPOSURE THE
JOB A HOUSE. CONTINUE TO WORK
THIS FLIGHT HI PUBLIC HEALTH
RISKS FOR EXAMPLE HISPANIC
EMPLOYEES ACCOUNT 432% OF THE
OVERALL WORK FORCE IN THE
REGION OR REPRESENTS 46% OF
THOSE WORKING IN THE FOOD
SERVICE INDUSTRY. BY THE SAME
TOKEN HISPANIC EMPLOYEES MAKE
UP THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE OF
THE ESSENTIAL WORK WORKS
BUILDING CLEANING SERVICES
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT. GROCERY
DRUGSTORES 44% THE CHILD CARE
AND SOCIAL SERVICE 39% EMILY
BLACKENED WORRIES ACCOUNT FOR
NEARLY 5% OF THE OVERALL WORK
FORCE IN THE REGION REPRESENT A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE CENTRAL
WORKFORCE. MORE THAN 7% OF THE
CHILD CARE SOCIAL SERVICES 9%
AND TRUCKING WAREHOUSING POSTAL
SERVICE NEARLY 20% PUBLIC
TRANSIT. WORKERS NEXT SLIDE. IT
IS ALEX STUDY WHEN THEY'RE TO
THE WHITE PROPER IS AND POP
ROCK. OR MORE THAN TIMES AS
LIKELY TO LIVE IN AREAS THAT
BEEN IMPACTED BY BOTH.
UNEMPLOYMENT IN KOBE NINETEEN.
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF THE
REGION'S BLACK POPULATION 70%
HISPANIC 67% RESIDE IN ZIP
CODES WITH HIGHER THAN AVERAGE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. IN
APPROXIMATELY HALF A BLOCK 52%
IN THE SENATE 49% RESIDENTS
LIVING ZIP CODES WITH HIGHER
THAN AVERAGE HOGAN NINETEEN
CASES. WHERE THE STATEMENTS
WHAT WE DO NOT SURPRISE MANY
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING WE NOW HAVE THE DATA
POINTS TO BACK THEM UP. THIS IS
THE KIND OF RESEARCH THAT NEEDS
TO LOOK LEAD TO SYSTEMIC POLICY
CHANGES WHEN WE ARE NOT MEANS
THAT CHANGED INCESSANT
INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING PUBLIC
HEALTH ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS.
THAT DIRECTLY DEAL WITH THE
ISSUES OF INEQUALITY. SERVICE
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE BORDER REGION
CONSIDER SPECIAL TRUCKS
STRATEGIES THAT ADDRESSES
ISSUES OF QUALITY AND SOCIAL
EQUITY WHEN DEALING WITH
SITUATIONS. AS THE PANDEMIC.
WE'VE SEEN IT DURING THIS
CRISIS AS WE DON'T HAVE TO
SPEND YEARS AND YEARS OF DEBATE
AND MEETINGS TO GET THINGS DONE
WE CAN MOVE AND WE MUST
CONTINUE TO MOVE LIGHTNING
SPEED. TO GET THINGS DONE TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS. NO MATTER TO
CARRY OUT PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES OF MATTER BECAUSE
EXCUSES ABOUTWHAT WE CAN DO
AND WHY WE CAN'T DO THINGS NO
LONGER APPLY I THINK YOU SAW
THAT. ARE PROBABLY IN THE
MEDICAL. FIELD TO MATERIALS.
YES THE SERVICE ONE MOVING AT
LIGHTNING SPEED. WE NEED A BOX.
IN A BROADER PERSPECTIVE WE
HAVE SEEN ALL FACETS OF DAILY
LIFE IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC
THE US MEXICO BORDER IS NO
EXCEPTION JUST A I LIKE
SOMETHING IN ADDITION TO THE
STAND UNDER WE SUFFERED AS A
CRISIS IMPORTER POLLUTION TOXIC
SEWAGE AND TOXIC WASTE THIS
NOVEMBER ON THE RESIDENTS OF
SOUTH SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL
BEACH MOST IMPACTED BY HOGAN
AND UNEMPLOYMENT HAVE ALSO BEEN
EXPOSED TO MORE THAN BETWEEN-
ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY FIVE TO
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION GALLONS A
DAY OF RAW SEWAGE IN THE TO
CUENTA RIVER THAT ENTERS THE
UNITED STATES- ON THE LAST
SEVEN WORDS THE STOP IS
SITUATION IS WORSENING. AND WE
NEED ACCESS TO OUR BEACHES AND
HEALTHY OPEN SPACE OUR BEACHES.
AND CLOSE PRETTY MUCH FOR THE-
RESTRICTIONS WERE NOT AS CORE.
TRIPS ONE TO AFFECT MARCH
TWENTY FOR TWENTY. AND RICK SAN
ANGELO JULY TWENTY FOR. TWENTY
TWENTY. SIX AND WE SEE NOR ON.
ACROSS DEGREE SLICE. FIVE WHAT
WE TYPICALLY. AND THE OTHER
CROSSING I HAVE. A DRUG DRUG
CROSSINGS BILL WHAT ABOUT 25%
BUT I SAID TOMORROW ENJOY. OR
OR THREE NORTH AMERICAN
COUNTRIES WILL START
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW TRUCK FREE
TRADE AGREEMENT. LIKE THE
AWESOME CA WHICH NICE DARK
RUSSIAN DELEGATION. ARE
SENATORS LIKES. SENATOR HUESO
ON HER. ONE NINE INCLUDED THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TO ADDRESS OUR.
TO REGISTER RIGHT FROM THE SO
THIS IS A HISTORICAL. ON ONE
REPRESENTS A FOR THE REAR WERE
ECONOMY CENTER FOR RE. BUT AS
YOU CAN STRATEGICALLY
POSITIONED THE GROUND. AND YOU
MCA IS KEPT UP HOPE CENTER
ELSEWHERE ME CRITICAL
PRODUCTION LINES. WELL THE
POLICY IN MARKET IS. TO KEEP.
SENATE ACTUALLY START TO WE
HAVE A HUGE JOB. FOR QUITE A
LESS LEARNED FOR THE ENTIRE OF
COVER NINETEEN WE DEVELOP OR
NOT. REGIONAL. TO SAN DIEGO FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
READ PLAN WILL BE OUR VISION
FOR THE READ OVER THE THIRTY
YEARS. AND OUR FOCUS ON. ACROSS
JURIST. AND INTERNATIONAL BUT-
WHAT TO LEVERAGE. THE REGION'S
STRATEGIC OKAY. WE DID A
GROWING MEGA REGION ACTUALLY
THE BORDER REGIONS CRITICAL TO
BOOK MEXICO THE UNITED. SAID
COORDINATE SOME OF PLANNING TO
US MEXICO TRADE INDUSTRY BUT
OTHER CROSSWORD REPRESENT
WORKING TOGETHER TO PROVE WATER
QUALITY IS MENTIONED AND SUPPLY
DEVELOP AND EXPAND RESOURCES
AND PROTECT TRUST HOUSE.
LEADERSHIP AMONG GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL ALLOW
US TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
ENHANCE ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS AND WORK
TOWARDS A MORE SUSTAINABLE
ENVIRONMENT REGION AND I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
PRIORITIZING THE ISSUES OF
EQUITABLE AGGRESSION AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
OUR HELP THE MOST OF THIS TIME.
RECEIVED THE MOST HELP THANK
YOU SO MUCH OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE THIS MORNING THE
END OF TAX ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE BORDER REGION
FURTHER INSPIRING ENCOURAGES
OFFERS. TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE WE-
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MYRNA
PRETTY YOUR- VERY HARD. ON
BEHALF OF NOT A THE- PEOPLE OF
IMPERIAL BEACH BUT IF THE IN
THE ENTIRE STATE. WITH ALL YOUR
WORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO KATE CLARK ON THE
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRATION
SERVICES WITH FOR JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE CENTER. EIGHT ZERO.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATE
CLARK I AM THE SENIOR DIRECTOR
AND IMMIGRATION SERVICES AND
LEAD IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF SAN
DIEGO. I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE HOW JEFF
FAST A LARGE NONPROFIT SERVICE
PROVIDER IN THE BORDERLANDS.
HAS RESPONDED TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY DURING THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. YOUR FAMILY
SERVICES LIKE CLIENT CENTERED
IMPACT DRIVEN ORGANIZATION
WORKING TO BUILD A STRONGER
HEALTHIER MORE RESILIENT SAN
DIEGO. FOR MANY IN SAN DIEGO
MAKING ENDS MEET IS A DAILY
CHALLENGE THIS IS SPECIFICALLY
TRUE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES MOST
VULNERABLE UNEMPLOYED AND
UNDEREMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS AND
PARENTS WITH CHILDREN AT HOME.
OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND
ASYLUM SEEKERS TO NAME A FEW.
TODAY I WILL FOCUS MY TESTIMONY
JUST ON A FEW AREAS OF
JACKASSES SERVICE DELIVERY
PROGRAMS TO RESPOND TO AN
INCREASED NEED DURING SCOPE IN
BANKING PANDEMIC. NO TOUCH
DRIVE THEIR DISTRIBUTION FOR
FOOD. JEFF I KNOW TOUCH FOOD
DISTRIBUTIONS ARE OPEN EVERY
DAY TO MEET SAN DIEGO'S
CRITICAL FOOD NEEDS. I THINK
THIS PANDEMIC BEGAN ON AVERAGE
MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED DRIVE THROUGH MEALS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED THROUGH THIS
DISTRIBUTION EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
THIS EQUATES TO OVER A HUNDRED
AND 1-800-060-0408 DRIVE
THROUGH MEALS DISTRIBUTED SINCE
KOBE NINETEEN BEGAN. SENIOR
SUPPORT COATED NINETEEN HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED OLDER
ADULTS WITH THE RISK OF
INCREASED INFECTION BUT ALSO
THE HEALTH RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH SOCIAL ISOLATION. OUR ON
SITE KITCHEN HAS PREPARED MORE
THAN QUADRUPLED THE NUMBER OF
PRODUCTIVE MEALS PRE KOBE GOING
FROM ONE SHIFT TO TIER SHIPS
WERE ME MAKE MORE THAN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED MEALS PER DAY. IN TOTAL
FOR MARK SIXTEEN TO JUNE TWENTY
FIRST OUR TEAM OF VOLUNTEER
DRIVERS HAVE DELIVERED UPWARDS
OF THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN FRESHLY COOKED AND
SHELF STABLE MEALS TO OLDER
ADULTS IN THEIR HOME. SAFE
PARKING. ALREADY WIDELY USE PRE
PANDEMIC JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES
THREE SAFE PARKING LOT PROGRAM
LOTS OFFER A SAFE PLACE
OVERNIGHT FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN THEIR VEHICLES. IN RESPONSE
TO COOK AT NINETEEN WE'VE
EXPANDED OUR HOURS OF
OPERATION. INCLUDING TED TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN NINE TWO LOTS AND
ONE NOT MOVE TO A LARGER
LOCATION TO HOLD MORE VEHICLES.
WITH AN AVERAGE OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE PARTICIPANTS EACH
NIGHT THE SAFE PARKING PROGRAM
HAS PROVIDED CRITICAL RESOURCES
INCLUDING THREE MEALS PER DAY
TO FAMILIES INDIVIDUALS. AND
PEOPLE WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
DISASTER RELIEF ASSISTANCE FOR
IMMIGRANTS JFS IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S PARTNER TO
DISTRIBUTE ITS DISASTER RELIEF
ASSISTANCE FOR IMMIGRANTS OR
DRY PROGRAM IN SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES. UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
TODAY'S HEALTH CRISIS AS THEIR
INELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL STIMULUS
DOLLARS VIA THE KERRS ACT OR
OTHER DISASTER RELIEF FUNDING.
THROUGH THE DRIVE PROGRAM JUST
YESTERDAY JEFF ASKED COMPLETED
IN RULING TEN THOUSAND
APPLICANTS WHICH EQUATES TO A
TOTAL OF FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
DISTRIBUTED TO UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS. WE FIELDED CALLS
FROM IN EXCESS OF TWENTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN THE
BORDERLANDS TRYING TO ACCESS
THESE FUNDS. IMMIGRATION
DETENTION IN THE BORDERLANDS FS
IS ONE OF A HANDFUL OF
NONPROFIT IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE REGION
PROVIDING PRO BONO
REPRESENTATION TO DETAINED
EMIGRANTS. TO DETENTION CENTERS
THE- TIME IF THE DETENTION
CENTER AND THE IMPERIAL
REGIONAL DETENTION FACILITY AND
BOTH ARE OPERATED BY FOR PROFIT
CORPORATIONS. THIS PRESENTS A
UNIQUE TALENTS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF COULD BE NINETEEN AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. CURRENTLY THE- TIME IS
A DETENTION CENTER IS THE SIDE
OF ONE OF THE LARGEST OUTBREAKS
OF KOBE NINETEEN IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. WITH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY INDIVIDUALS
HAVING TESTED POSITIVE FOR KOBE
NINETEEN. INDIVIDUALS DETAINED
AT THEIR TIME IS A DETENTION
CENTER WERE COERCED DESIGN
LEGAL WAIVERS AS THE ONLY WAY
TO OBTAIN PP. INDEED THE
OPERATION OF BOTH OF THESE
FACILITIES BY FOR PROFIT
OPERATORS RAISES SERIOUS
QUESTIONS AS TO HOW DECISIONS
INVOLVING PUBLIC SAFETY ARE
BEING CARRIED OUT. RESPITE
MIGRANT SHELTER IN THE
BORDERLANDS THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF A RESPITE MIGRANT
SHELTERED TO THE PROTECTION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS VIOLATE
VITALLY IMPORTANT DEFENSE
OPERATE SAN DIEGO'S MIGRANT
FAMILY SHELTER AND WE HAVE
ASSISTED MORE THAN TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS SINCE
OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
IT'S INCLUDES ELEVEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED CHILDREN. OUR JOB
WAS TO ENSURE OUR SHELTER GAS
WERE HEALTHY AND ABLE TO TRAVEL
TO THEIR FINAL DESTINATION.
TODAY WITH THE BORDER
EFFECTIVELY CLOSE THE NUMBER OF
ASYLUM SEEKING FAMILIES WE ARE
ASSISTING HAS DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED THOUGH WE HAVE REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT THESE NUMBERS
WILL AGAIN INCREASE ONCE THE
SAME DIEGO IMMIGRATION COURT
RESUMES HEARINGS. IN MID JULY
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND ROLLED INTO
THE REMAINING MEXICO PROGRAM.
AGAIN IT WILL BE THROUGH A
COORDINATED EFFORT BY JEFF ASSN
OTHERS IN ADDITION TO GOVERNOR
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS INCLUDING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILL BE CRITICAL
IN MEETING THE UNIQUE NEEDS
PRESENTED IN OUR REGION. JEFF
THAT'S UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
STATE IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED FISCAL CRISIS NOT
BROUGHT ON BY AN ECONOMIC
RECESSION BUT BY A PANDEMIC
THAT WAS BROUGHT. AND THAT IS
THE WORLD TO A HALT. IF WE
CONTINUE TO SEE HOW KOBE
NINETEEN IT WONDERFUL
POPULATION THE HARDEST THOSE
WITH WEAKENED IMMUNE SYSTEMS
SENIORS PEOPLE OF COLOR AND-
THIS. SUCCESS WE WILL PAY OVER
THIS BY. WILL BE MEASURED
ABOUT. BY HOW WELL WE ARE FOR
CARE FOR- PEOPLE THAT ARE MOST
AT RISK IN OUR STATE AND IN
THIS MOMENT JEFF US
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE STATE.
TO CONTINUE INVESTMENT OR
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES IN
ADDITION TO ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT OVER THE DETENTION
CONDITIONS FOR THE TWO.
DETENTION FACILITIES IN OUR
REGION THOUGH THERE ARE OTHERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CONTINUED INVESTMENT- TO
MAINTAIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE REPS BUT SHELTER OPERATED
BY JACK FAST FOR ASYLUM SEEKERS
RELEASE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY TO ENSURE THE
PROTECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
CONTINUED INVESTMENT FOR THE
DIRECT FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
FEDERAL STIMULUS DOLLARS VIA
THE CARES ACT. I JEFF THAT'S
OUR CALL TO ACTION IS MOVING
FORWARD TOGETHER. THIS IS WHAT
WE INTEND TO DO THROUGH THIS
CRISIS AND BEYOND AND AGAIN I
THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE OUR DAY TO DAY IN THE
CHALLENGES WE SEEK TO RESPOND
TO AND FIND SOLUTIONS FOR. AS
THE SITUATION CONTINUES TO
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT
A GREAT PRESENTATION AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON BEHALF
OF. THE PEOPLE OF OUR COMMUNITY
CENTER REPEAL DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. YES THIS QUESTION IS
FOR KATE- CLARK. AFTER TWO OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICES I'VE JUST I'VE BEEN
ONE OF THE PRIVILEGE WANTS TO
TAKE A TOUR WITH YOU ARE NOT
ONLY IN THE JEWISH CENTER BUT
ALSO THE ALL TIME SO DETENTION
CENTER. I JUST WANT A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF AN EXPANSION ON THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE CURSED TO
SIGN WAIVERS. IF YOU CAN EXPAND
ON THAT OF WHAT HAS BEEN THE
OUTCOME OF THOSE THAT THAT WERE
COERCED AND- WHERE DID THE END.
BASED ON THOSE CORPORATIONS.
SURE WE HAD RECEIVE THAT
INFORMATION DIRECTLY FROM OUR
CLIENTS- OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS REALLY. IT'S CLEAR TO
ME THAT THERE THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING- SHARED WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BEING
DETAINED SPECIFICALLY IF YOUR
TIME IS A DETENTION. CENTER IS
REALLY OUT OF A VACUUM THERE'S
NOT REALLY. ANY ANY STRUCTURE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE TO ENSURE. THAT
BE ADDED TEAMED INDIVIDUALS
HAVE- THEIR THEIR SAFETY AND
WELLNESS BEING CARED FOR OR
THEIR VESTING INTERESTS ARE
BEING LOOKED AFTER OF COURSE BE
A STILL YOUR SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES HAVE SINCE
CHALLENGED- AND BROUGHT SUIT
AGAINST. IMMIGRATION CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT FOR. ON THE
CONDITIONS THAT ARE OUT THERE-
TO MEET THE DETENTION FACILITY
BUT- WE CONTINUE TO SEE OR TO
RECEIVE- HORRIFIC REPORTS FROM
OUR CLIENTS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
YOU. ARE SEEKING LEGAL
SERVICES- AND YOUR OF COURSE
INTERESTED IN AND GETTING OUT
OF THE DETENTION CENTER AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. IT'S REALLY
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE UNITED
STATES IS TAKING THAT APPROACH-
TO SIMPLY DETAIN IMMIGRANTS
THERE. NO REASON TO DO THE
ESPECIALLY FOR US I'M YEARS
THEY'RE SEEKING FOR. AND FLEE
FOR A BI TEMPER. FROM THEIR
HOME BUT JEFF OTHERS CONTINUED
RECEIVE THESE. EVERY DAY- AND
DO OUR BEST TO YOU KNOW.
REPRESENT FOLKS AND BOND AND
HEARINGS AND ROLL THEM OUT OF
THIS. GIVEN THE EGREGIOUS AND
HORRIFIC CONDITIONS OF THE
FACILITY- AT TEN MESA. THANK
YOU AND I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION IF I MAY UM EARLIER I
HAD ASKED BECAUSE I HAD HEARD
ABOUT THE- HUNDRED AND SIXTY
CASES AND THE DETENTION CENTERS
BUT- I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT-
INFORMATION I WAS RELEASED I
BELIEVE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS. GOING TO ALLOW IRAQ I THINK
OVER A HUNDRED- CHILDREN TO BE
RELEASED AND THERE IS CONFUSION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE RESET THEIR
PARENTS. OR ALONE DO YOU HAVE
INFORMATION ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
TO THOSE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
RELEASED. YES YEAH MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ABOUT LARGELY
APPLIES TO FAMILY DETENTION
CENTERS FORTUNATELY THERE ARE
NO NO FAMILY DETENTION CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA- BUT THAT REALLY
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE. OF
THE- INVESTMENT THE STATE'S
CONTINUED INVESTMENT INTO THE
SAN DIEGO RESPITE. SHELTER FOR
MIGRANT FAMILIES ON BECAUSE
THERE IS NO FAMILY DETENTION
CENTER- INDIVIDUALS. FAMILY
UNIT SPECIFICALLY ARE ABLE TO
BE RELEASED ON THE ALTERNATIVES
TO DETENTION PROGRAM SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT DETAINED- FAMILY
DETENTION CENTERS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES- IN ORDER TO GET
TO THEIR FINAL DESTINATION SO.
I'M WELL WE DO NOT HAVE TO
SPECIFICALLY DEAL WITH- BEING
DETAINED IN OUR IN OUR- REGION
OR OUR STATE. I'M IT IS
SOMETHING THAT OTHER. STATES
ARE GRAPPLING WITH- BECAUSE
THERE ARE FAMILY DETENTION
CENTERS THERE NAMELY INTACT.
THANK ONE MORE A FIGHT ALREADY
LAY IS THAT OKAY. I DON'T KNOW
OUR TIME WHERE WE ASKED TO
RECESS BY THE PRO TERM. ALL
HELLO SIR ONE FORTUNATELY WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO- RECESS ARE
HEARING AND COME BACK AS SOON
AS WE'RE DONE. WHETHER CAUCUS
MEETING UNFORTUNATELY SO THANK
YOU. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS AND I BELIEVE WILL BE
BACK IN ABOUT APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY MINUTES AND WE'LL RESUME
OUR HEARING FOR THE PEOPLE
THERE ARE WAITING ON LINE I
APOLOGIZE WE'VE GONE OVER ON
TIME. AND WE ALSO HAVE ONE
PRESENTER LEWISVILLE OF MY
LITTLE THAT'S WAITING ALSO
PERCENT. AND WE'LL TRY TO
RECONNECT WITH EVERYBODY WHEN
WE RETURNED SO ON APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BUT FORTUNATELY WE HAD
ANOTHER SCHEDULED. IN THAT WE
ALL MUST ATTEND SO WE'RE GOING
TO SCHEDULE FOR ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES RETURN.
A WITH A
SPECIAL COMMITTEE IN THE
PANDEMIC MARGINS HE RESPONSE.
AND THE- CALIFORNIA MEXICO
CORPORATION SELECT COMMITTEE
ARE GOING TO RESUME OUR
HEARING. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
APOLOGIZING TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE SET IN
THE QUEUE TO SPEAK. AND FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. FOR
INTERRUPTING OUR MEETING WE HAD
A VERY IMPORTANT TO US SESSION
TO GO INTO A VERY SORRY ABOUT
THAT. BUT WE DID GO OVER ON OUR
ALLOTTED TIME. THROUGH OUR
PRESENTATIONS IN OUR SPEAKERS
SO THAT- CREATE A PROBLEM FOR
US AND WE HAD A- A RECESS AND
ONE APOLOGIZE TO ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY FOR THAT RECESS.
BUT WE ARE BACK AND WE WILL
RETURN RESUME. OUR HEARING AND
ABOUT- SIXTY SECONDS
APPROXIMATELY. WE WILL WE'RE
SENDING MESSAGES OUT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
ON THE CALL TO. GET THEM- TUNED
IN ONCE AGAIN FOR THOSE THAT
WANT TO SPEAK. AND WE ARE
REACHING OUT TO OUR PRESENTER
IS WELL. TO SO- IN ABOUT SIXTY
SECONDS WE WILL RESUME LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SUPPORTING US IN THIS
AND WE'RE VERY VERY SORRY WE
HAD RECESS BUT ONCE AGAIN. THIS
IS THE A JOINT HEARING WITH THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON THE PANIC
PANDEMIC MERGES TO RESPONSE AND
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON A
CALIFORNIA MEXICO COOPERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHERE IS
THE GENTLEMAN WE WILL RESUME
OUR HEARING FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOLLOWING OUR NEXT
PRESENTER WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND FOR ALL OF THOSE.
THEY'RE TUNED IN AND WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL
PREFER PROVIDE. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
AND IT'S ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE RIGHT NOW IF YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION. WHEN
WE MOVED TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU ON THE WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AGAINST AGAIN I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE FOR INTERRUPTING OUR
HEARING BUT WE WILL RESUME NOW.
AND HEAR FROM OUR FINAL.
PRESENTER OUR FINAL PRESENTERS
LEASE OR MENTAL THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF. COMPLETE THIS
CYNICAL THAT VIA YEAH ON
ORGANIZATION THAT'S BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT OF PROVIDING- ACCESS
TO- DIFFERENT PROGRAMS FOR. THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY AGAIN
THIS IS UNDER OUR- HEADING OF
THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THE
ECONOMIC AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACTS OF THE COVERT NINETEEN.
AND AS WE KNOW THERE HAS BEEN A
DISPARATE. IMPACT ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND-
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MR LOOK RACHEL
MADDOW OR ARE AND THE TIP OF
THE SPEAR PROVIDING SERVICES TO
THE- MEMBERS OF OUR AUNTS
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES SO. IT
IS AT THIS TIME THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN WORKING HARDEST. TO
PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES. AND WE
WANT TO THANK A INDIVIDUALS
LIKELY SCHNITZEL METAL WHO HAVE
BEEN OUT THERE PROVIDING THE
SERVICES FOOD. SERVICES ACCESS
TO INFORMATION ABOUT
HEALTHCARE. ACCESS TO OF. VITAL
SERVICES AND INFORMATION THAT
ARE HELPING THE MOST
UNDERSERVED. US SURVIVE IN OUR
STATE. SO IF RELEASE A MISSILE
METAL ISON THE LINE WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN UP THE MIKE AND LET
HIM. NOW BEGIN IS-
PRESENTATION. MR MEL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US IT'S A
PLEASURE TO HAVE YOU. I KNOW SO
MANY THINGS ARE GOING ON IN PER
COUNTY WE REALLY. WISH THAT THE
PEOPLE OF THE BEST OUT THERE
THE VICTIMS OF COVERT. THE
FAMILIES OF VICTIMS OF THE FIRE
AND ISLAND OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO
THOSE FAMILIES I NO NO NO
THERE. ARE THEY ARE IN DIRE
NEED OF ASSISTANCE AND HELP
MANY OF THEM NOW. OUR FAMILIES
ARE NOW HOMELESS SO LOTS OF
THINGS HAPPENING IN A AND OF
COURSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO OUR STATE. AND THE
AND THE AND THE PEOPLE OF YOUR
BEAUTIFUL COUNTY. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR WHAT YOU DO AND
JOINING US TODAY THIS IS A MUST
BE DIFFICULT TIME BUT-
PROTECTING FROM FROM YOUR DAY.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK
CHAIRMAN ON CENTERS IN HUESO
YOU KNOW THE SENTIMENT SINCE
OUR SUPER GLOW AND- IF THERE
WAS EVER A TIME THAT. WE COULD
FORECAST THIS WORST CASE
SCENARIO AND RESTRICTIONS ARE
LEADER- WE DEFINITELY WOULD
THAT. LEADERS LIKE YOURSELF
WOULD BE AT THE HOME
REPRESENTING US IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO A RULER SHIA- WE
COULD NOT BE IN BETTER HANDS
AND THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WILL HAVE ALSO
MADE TIME TO LISTEN TO OUR
BORDER COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
OFTEN BEEN LEFT BEHIND- AND
HISTORICALLY. I YOU KNOW IN IN
IN THE RECESS I MEAN I
GUESSTIMATE SOME FORMAL
COMMENTS- BUT I DON'T WANT TO
FOCUS ON THOSE FROM A COMMON
SIGHT I WANT TO BRING BACK. SIR
THE BIGGER PICTURE THE
SITUATION THAT'S HAPPENING HERE
IN THE IMPERIAL VALLEY- FOR
FOUR DECADES- I KNOW I'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR TWENTY YEARS AND WE
HAVE BEEN POUNDING ON THE DOOR
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO RECOGNIZE
THE FACT THAT WE ARE AN
INTERCONNECTED COMMUNITY WHEN
MEXICO. WE HAVE A FLUID-
RELATIONSHIP- WHERE THERE IS A
CONVENIENCE OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ARE WORKING ARE YOU
CENTURY JOBS ARE ARE I
AGRICULTURE OUR MANUFACTURING-
RETAIL OR WHOLESALE. WE ARE
INSIDE COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS HAS NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT IN WHETHER IT BE
THROUGH LEGISLATION WHETHER IT
BE TO HELP THEIR FIRST I HAS
NOT RECOGNIZE THAT INDIVIDUAL
THE WORST POSSIBLE CONDITIONS
THAT WE CAN BE IN RIGHT NOW. WE
NEED TO CHANGE THAT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS WE CAN I JUST FIGHT
THE BATTLE- AT THE FRONT LINES-
WHEN THE AGENTS HAVE ALREADY
REACHED THE WORST POSSIBLE
SCENARIO WHICH EMERGED. CARE TO
ALL ACTIVE OF NOT PROACTIVE WE
WILL NEVER ENDS I MEAN WHAT WAS
THE LAST TIME WE WERE ABLE TO
YOU READY KATE- EIGHT EIGHT IN
AND THAT'S RIGHT BY YOU READY
KIDDING ONE I'M NOT IT'S TIME.
AND THAT THIS IS A PRIME
BREEDING GROUND FOR HOPE IT ARE
THE INEQUITIES THAT EXISTS HERE
WE HAVE ASSAULTS AND SEE WE
HAVE THE NEW RIVER WHICH IS A
BREEDING GROUND. FOR THESE
TYPES OF VIRAL CONDITIONS THAT
HAVE EXISTED HERE IF WE DON'T
LOOK AT THE BIGGER PICTURE IF
WE JUST TAKING CARE OF THE
EMERGENCY WE'RE ONLY GONNA
CONTINUE TO CARE FOR THE MOST.
CRITICALLY ILL AND WE'RE NOT BE
ABLE TO COPE. AND BE ABLE TO
STOP THIS CRY. IN TIME. BEFORE
IT SOME. SOME SICK. DAMAGE IN A
COMMUNITIES WE DEFINITELY NEED
AND I RECIPROCATE EVERYTHING
ARE LEADERS IN HEALTHCARE HAVE
BEEN SAYING- WE NEED YOU KNOW A
PERSONAL. PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
P. P. WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
BORDERS WE SEND LETTERS AND
BELIEVE OFF FOR FOUR MONTHS AGO
TO OUR CONGRESSMEN WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR A MEETING. BUT
THESE ARE THINGS THAT THAT HAS
BROUGHT TOGETHER OUR
COMMUNITIES. EVEN AMONG
NONTRADITIONAL PARTNERSHIPS
SUCH AS A FARM BUREAU. WHO
STEPPED IN AND SAID WE
RECOGNIZE THAT BORDER AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE FARMWORKERS AND
THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS THAT ARE
UNPROTECTED. AND WE NEED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT JUST STEPPED
IN I'VE BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH
TO SEE A- FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BEING VERY RESPONSIVE. AND I
SEE. IN THE BACK UP. WHAT WE
COULD NOT BE IN BETTER HANDS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE GOVERNOR
THE HAS BEEN RESPONSES BUT WE
NEEDED GIVEN THE ENTIRE ACCOUNT
AND WE NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO
SEE THE WHOLE PICTURE AND THE
WHOLE PICTURE IS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH THESE INEQUITIES
AND EAST PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS THERE ARE PUTTING
OUR ENTIRE POPULATION AND WE'RE
SEEING THE RESULTS. THE RESULTS
OF THE SPIKE IS IN THE
CONDITION SINCE EIGHTY EIGHT IS
IT'S NOT TO THE JUST POINT AT
THE VICTIM BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS
A BIG. EVERYBODY WHO LIVES HERE
WHETHER YOU HAVE. BEEN AWARE
THAT YOU'RE REDUCED. RATE IT
HIGHER HIGHER- RESTORE CODE IS
YOUR BEING PUT IN A IN IN THESE
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
SO WHAT WE NEED RIGHT NOW- I
YOU KNOW I'VE GOT TO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH MUCH OF
MY MANY OTHER BUREAUCRACIES
HAD. A LONG HISTORY WORKING
WITH C. P. H. IN AND NICE AND
SHERRY- CONGRATULATE. THE NEW
DIRECTOR IN HER IN HER
APPOINTMENT THIS LAST FRIDAY
BUT- THE STATE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC OUT PASSED. IN OFFICE OF
EQUITY IN THIS IS WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DID. WE WANT THAT
PROMISE OF THAT. EQUITY IN
INVESTMENT IN OUR COMMUNITY ANY
READY KATIE. ALL THESE BE
EXISTING CONDITIONS. ARE YOU
KNOW ALL THE SEARCHERS SOCIALLY
GERMANS I HELP. THE BARRIERS
THAT EXIST THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
TO JUST HAVE A TWO WAY
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN EMERGENCY
CARE AND WE IN BEING REACTIVE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF NONPROFITS
HERE IN THE VALLEY THAT HAVE
BEEN HERE THAT HAVE. BEEN
FILLING THE GAPS OF SERVICE FOR
DECADES UPON DECADES I DECISION
AS BEEN HERE FOR THIRTY YEARS
THIRTY OVER NEARLY THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. WE HAVE ORGANIZATIONS
YEAR I'VE BEEN HERE MUCH LONGER
AND I HAVE NOT SEEN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA STEP UP. AND SAY
LET'S PULL IN ALL THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THERE
PROVIDING HEALTHCARE PROVIDE
SOCIAL SERVICES FOOD SERVICES-
MANY SERVICES THAT WE NEED. SO
THAT WE CAN ALSO TAKE THIS
STRATEGY TO BE PROACTIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES MAKING SURE WE'RE
REACHING. THE HARD TO REACH I
HAVE SEEN THIS STRATEGY SO MANY
TIMES. WHERE THE STATE
BUREAUCRACY JUST LOOKS AS FAR
AS ARE THERE THERE ARE IN IN
SEAT. AND THEN THEY FOCUS IN
AND THESE STATEWIDE STRATEGIES
IN THE REGIONAL STRATEGIES. AND
YOU KNOW WE ARE- WE SURCHARGE
SOLITARY ROSE THIS IS A- YEAH
WILL AND- YOU DON'T. BUT BUT WE
NEED THE STATE. EIGHT OUR LOCAL
WE'VE BEEN HAVE MANY GO HERE IN
THE COUNTY AND I VERY THAT SOME
OF THE COUNTY. I REALLY
STEPPING UP AND RAKE IN AND THE
FACT THAT OWN POLICIES HAVE
BEEN RE OVER A YEAR AGO THESE
ARE HI PA THAT THAT THAT THAT
WERE HEALTH TO ELEVATE IN IN
THE OF THE THAT ECSTASY BUT WE
FORGOTTEN ABOUT THE OVER 85%
LATINOS IN AND WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN IN IN NOT GETTING
A COMPLETE COUNTY COULD EASILY
BE OVER 90% AT THE MOST. AND BY
THE WAY KOBE IS. IS HAVING HIS
GREATEST DAMAGE AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR LATINOS- COMMUNITIES
AND THIS IS THE PRIMARY IN
ROUND FOR THE POOR QUALITY.
RIGHT SO. IN WHAT IS A THING
SAID THAT WE NEED WE TO SAY
THAT. TO NOT ONLY JUST
COORDINATE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
WE NEED TO ENGAGE ALL THE
NONPROFIT THAT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO GO OUT. AND RETOOL
FOR YEARS USE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THERE
THAT HAVE BEEN THE STATE THE
NARROWNESS STATION I'VE BEEN
CAUGHT YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR WE NEED TO PUT RESOURCES
IN THEIR HANDS. SO THAT WE CAN
REACH THE POPULATION THAT THAT
THAT SOME SOME HAVE CHOSEN TO
SAY IT'S THEIR FAULT IT'S
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WEAR THEIR
MASS IS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
LISTENING LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
THE FARM WORKERS. THEY HAVE TO
BUILD THIS TYPE OF RESISTANCE
IN STATE BECAUSE OF THE WORKING
CONDITIONS BECAUSE OF THE
EXPOSURE THAT THEY FACED YOU
THINK THAT THEY'RE SCARED OF A
VIRUS. THEY DON'T THEY HAVE
BEEN THEY HAVE BEEN. CONDITION
TO DEAL WITH VERY HARSH
CONDITIONS. SO WHEN WE WANT TO
TALK TO THE COMMUNITY IN THE
FARM WORKERS THEY FEEL THAT
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER CALL IS
GOING TO PASS THEM BY AND
THAT'S NOT A FAILURE OF THEIRS.
THAT'S THE FAILURES OF THE
CONDITIONS. THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
PUT TO AND THE FACT THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- BENEFITS.
THESE KNEE SO LEASES. WERE YET
IS NOT PROVIDING AND RESOURCE
THEY NEED. WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IS TAKE A STEP BACK. THE GENIE
RESPONDER HOSPITALS AND BY THE
WAY I WANT TO SAY THAT EVERY
LUIS I WANT TO CONGRATULATE HIM
BECAUSE- HE IS A LEADER THAT IS
NOT AFRAID OF BEING IN NON
PROFITS INTO HIS SPACE. AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE FORMAL AGREEMENTS
WORKING IN YEARS COPPER AND WE
NEED MORE OF THAT. AS WELL AS
IS AND THE COUNTY OF IMPERIAL
BRING IN NONPROFIT INTO THEIR
SPACE. AFTER GREAT SPECULATED
FOR THAT HE STOPPED ON MODELS
I'M NOT GOING TO WORK HERE. SO
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO BRING AL
NONPROFITS. RITUAL THEM.
RESPOND THEM. AND GET THEM ON
THE COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER. IN THIS IS A
MESSAGE TO THE LEADERS OF THESE.
AND YOU NEED TO GET YOUR TEAM
THE BUREAUCRATS THE
BUREAUCRACY. TO CONNECT TO OUR
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONNECT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW THIS. VERY
WELL WE KNOW THE CONDITIONS WE
LIVE IN WE KNOW WHAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE. SO WE NEED A TAX
TO TACKLE CHECK THIS THAT THIS
SITUATION FROM BOTH. FROM FROM
BOTH ENDS MEET MERGES YOU CARE.
PROVIDE HIM ALL THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED. AND LET'S GET OUT IN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THE HIGHER
REGION AND ANY RADIC A. B. C.
INEQUITIES THAT EVERY EXIST AND
A HALF BAKED OUR COMMUNITIES
FOR A VERY LONG TIME. THANK YOU
CENTER I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS I HAVE SUBMITTED.
COMMENTS AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE MANY ADVOCATES
THAT HAVE BEEN MORE- IN
COLLISIONS THAT WERE BORN OUT
OF THIS CRISIS HERE. NOT BLOODY
SO THAT I WHEN I SAID WE MEAN
IS THAT WHEN YOU DIE YOU. HEAR
ABOUT THE- IMMUNITY HEALTH
COALITION- AS WELL AS THE-
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION
AND MANY OTHER NONPROFITS ARE
WORKING YOUR LOCAL. WE WANT TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION ENGAGE
US. AND THANK YOU CENTER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. I AND I ECHO
EVERYTHING THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN SAID ALL THE EXPERTS ARE.
ABLE. THEY SHOWED THE
CONDITIONS. BUT WE NEED ENOUGH.
TO A MEANING FOR YOU. IN THIS.
THANK YOU. BUT WE REALLY YOU
JOINING US IN IT JOINING US TO
ARTICULATE THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES EXIST AND NO
ONE KNOWS BETTER THAN SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN SERVING A BORDER
COMMUNITY AT THE GRASSROOTS
LEVEL SO WE APPRECIATE YOU YOU
WAY N<c.cyan>. AND I THINK IT'S AN</c>
IMPORTANT MESSAGE SO WE WANT TO
SEND TO THE LEADERSHIP HERE.
NOT ONLY THE SENATE OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND ALL THE DEPARTMENTS.
THAT THERE ARE. CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH AT THE
BORDER THAT ARE ARE CAUSING
RISE TO THESE INCIDENTS AT
ALARMING RATES AND THAT IS
BECAUSE- THERE THERE IS JUST A
SUCH A- BUT THE AMAZING
INTEGRATION OF THE BORDER
COMMUNITIES MEXICO IN
CALIFORNIA ARE INTERTWINED IN
SO MANY COMPLEX WAYS. REAL
COUNTY IS THE SALAD BOWL OF
CALIFORNIA AND- THEY THEY
PRODUCE JUST A ON AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF AN IMPORTANT
INGREDIENTS THAT WE ALL CONSUME
AS AS A CONSUMERS. AND WE NEED
IMPERIAL COUNTY AND A WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE IS- IS VERY
DANGEROUS TO ALL CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLICHEALTH ESPECIALLY IF IT
INTERRUPTS THE PRODUCTION OF
MANY IMPORTANT FOOD SOURCES FOR
OUR STATE SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. ONE ASK A CENTER GONZALEZ
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS OR ANYTHING OR IN
PARTICULAR. THANK YOU SENATOR
WEST- AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PANEL PANELISTS AS WELL THIS IS
BEEN A VERY- VERY GOOD- HEARING
ON THESE VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
AND SO- I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE A FEW THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN MENTIONED BEFORE BUT
THE PROGRESS ON A SPECIFIC
READ. IS A- COUPLE OF THE
PANELISTS CAN SPECIFICALLY WHAT
THEY NEED AND- I HOPE WITH IN
OUR FOLLOW UP TOGETHER JOINTLY
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE A MEMO THAT
REALLY PROVIDES THIS
INFORMATION TO. PUT UP TO BOTH
HOUSES IN ADDITION GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT WE GET
THOSE NEEDS MET. AND TIMELY
MANNER- I WILL ALSO REITERATE
THE ICE DETENTION CENTERS AND-
FEDERAL DETENTION CENTER
ALTHOUGH THAT OUTSIDE PURVIEW I
KNOW THAT MANY THESE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE ARE BEING
TRANSPLANT UP I- SHE'S. GETTING
TO HER IN A- COMMUNITY MEMBERS
GOING THESE FACILITIES I HAVE
LARGE- POSITIVE CASES WHICH IS
NOT A YOU KNOW AND MANY OF OUR
THOUGHTS. NOT A GOOD SPACE FOR
THEM TO- CONTINUE LIVING AND SO
AT SOME POINT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO ADDRESS THAT WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AND WORK VERY
CLOSELY TOGETHER WITH THEM- BUT
LASTLY I JUST WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT THE TESTING CAPACITY
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT HAD BEEN
LIGHTLY TOUCHED AND- ALTHOUGH-
RIGHT NOW I THINK THE STATE IS
MADE THAT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
TESTS PER DAY. SIX AND THERE IS
AREAS I'M WONDERING IF THERE'S
ANY DATA IN THE IMPERIAL SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AREA RELATED TO A
SYMPTOMATIC. OF PEOPLE BECAUSE
WE DON'T HEAR ENOUGH ABOUT IT
IN A SYMPTOMATIC ESPECIALLY THE
YOUNGER POPULATIONS. THAT ARE-
JUST SPREADING THE VIRUS SO- IF
THERE IS ANYONE ON THE PANEL
THAT CAN ANSWER THAT THAT WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL AND THEN
LASTLY I HAVE BY WILL SAY. IN
OUR FIRST HEARING FOR THE
PANDEMIC AGENCY MONTHS WE'D BE
CONNECTED WITH DR STEVE CORNEAS
FROM CST. UP AND I'D BE HAPPY.
TO ENSURE THAT SENATOR WHAT
OFFICE HAS HIS INFORMATION
BECAUSE HE HAS HIS OWN TESTING
INCREASING AND IS SYMPTOMATIC
DATA AS WELL SO. I'LL LEAVE IT
THERE THINK- WE HAVE MISTER
MIDDLE DO YOU ARE YOU PRIVY TO
ANY OF THE INFORMATION SHE
REFER. TO DURING THE A STRAIGHT.
YEAH I DON'T HAVE THE TO
PROVIDED DETAIL WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WHAT I DO HAVE IS- I
DEFINITELY AGREE WE WILL ONLY
HAVE LIMITED TEST SITES- I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT THAT
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO- LOCAL
PRIVATE DOCTORS WERE THE FIRST
TO GO OUT AND DO. THESE
TRACKING CLINICS THEY DID NOT
HAVE THE P. B. ON HAND AND WE
MADE SURE THAT WE WORK WITH
THAT- YES WE CHEN REFERRED US
TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC OUT WHICH DâN MUNICH
EIGHTY TO THE COUNTY PUBLIC
OUT. THE THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A MUCH
BROADER STRATEGY THAT WE ARE
NOT MISSING OPPORTUNITIES SO WE
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN DOING TESTS
FOR QUITE A FEW MONTHS BEFORE
THE STATE AND BEFORE BUT COUNTY
GOT MUTUAL THEM TO ACTUALLY GO
OUT AND DO THEIR- BUT- I. IN
THE WE HAVE YES BUT WE. MORE
TO. LOW IT GO BACK WHAT I
MENTIONED LEAST. ASIAN
TRANSPORTATION. YOU KNOW WE
STILL HAVE ABOUT AREAS AND GET
THE END OUT TO PEOPLE NON NOT
GETTING THE INFORMATION TO SUCH
MEDIA WE NEED TO GO OUT THERE
DORA BE ABLE TO AND SOCIAL
DISTANCE SEEMS. AND MANY
DIFFERENT TO REACH THE TO REACH
BOB SO IT'S THE JOY STRAT THAT
WE NEED NOT ONLY TO HAVE MORE
JESSE SIZE BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE
MANY DEATHS INSIDE BUT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE TO CATION YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THAT THE FAMILY
SHOULD BE ABLE AND IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION THEY
WANT BE ABLE NO YES AFTER THE
MAN EARLIER THE RECENT. WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE SITUATION
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW WHERE A
FIRED HALF OF FIVE FIVE TO TEN
MILES AWAY FROM THE EMERGENCY
CENTER AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED
THAT- ALONG WITH THE COUNTY IS
ACTUALLY THE COUNTY IDENTIFIED
THERE'S TRANSPORTATION IS NOW
TRYING TO SOLVE THAT WHERE THE
COUNTIES ARE CHECKING WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT TO
TRY TO PROVIDE THAT
TRANSPORTATION BUT THAT IS
EXACTLY. THE ONLY WITH RIGHT.
SO YES WE NEED MORE TESTING WE
NEED MORE SUPPORT. BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO RETOOL AND I'M GLAD I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I ACTUALLY SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THE ASKED AND YOU KNOW
WE NEED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO START WITH. LET'S GET THESE
DOLLARS INTO LAW THESE
NONPROFITS WE NEED TO HELP THE
COUNTY CAN DO IT ALONE WE ALL
RECOGNIZE NONE OF US IN THE
LONG WE NEED TO DO IT TOGETHER.
WELL THANK YOU WE HAVE- SEVERAL
PEOPLE ON THE LINE- WISHING TO-
EXPRESS THEMSELVES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND OTHER ALSO
REPRESENTS OF ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL OF
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM THE CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE FROM- ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE PASS FAMILY OUT IT'S BEEN
A VERY INTEGRAL PROFITABLE DOES
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES
AND WHEN ONE OF US SAN DIEGO'S
MOST CHALLENGE COMMUNITIES
ANSWER WILL GO. TO THE FOR NOW
TO LISTEN TO. PUBLIC SO. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
LISTENING AND YOU'RE NOT
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE THE
PARTICIPANT PHONE NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE. SIX THREE FOUR FOUR.
THEN THE PARTICIPANT ACCESS
CODE IS. 636-481-5636. FOUR
EIGHT ONE FIVE. THE MODERATOR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO OPEN THE LINES
AND ANNOUNCE EACH COLOR
INDIVIDUALLY WE CAN BEGIN
HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC EACH
PERSON TESTIFIED IT'S LIMITED
TO ONE MINUTE. TO PROVIDE THEIR
COMMENTS- SO WE MAKING IT UP
AGAIN- FEW COULD ANNOUNCE THE
COLOR AND I ASK CALLERS TO
STATE YOUR NAME AND IF YOUR-
REPRESENTING AN ORGANIZATION IN
PARTICULAR PLEASE LET US KNOW
THAT AS WELL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOUR PARTICULAR TO
GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS. ONE PROVIDE YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND FURTHER INSTRUCTIONS
IF YOU'RE USING THE PHONE WE
ASK YOU TO PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
THAT ARE KILLING BUT THIS TIME
WE WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT LINE THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT COMING OUT WITH
A FEW TO YOUR CALIFORNIA. IF I
THINK OF THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
NOW RAGING IN CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT DETENTION CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA C. T. R. CONTINUES
TO VOLUNTARILY I THANK YOU NAY
MEMBERS INTO DETENTION RATHER
THAN RISK RETURNING THEM TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES.
I WANT TO GET YOUR IDENTIFIABLE
VULNERABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR XCELERATED RELEASED THIS
SPRING SEVENTY EIGHT THAN THOSE
SEVENTY FIVE THOSE COMMUNITY
WORK TRANSFERRED I. MENTIONED
DRAPER ONE KOBE HOT THAT TO
ANOTHER. MID JUNE I SUPPORTED
20% POSITIVE RATE AMONG
INDIVIDUAL PROTECTED IT HAS TO
BE TESTING SANITARY CONDITIONS
AND ACCESS TO P. B. REMAINS
EXTREMELY LIMITED MONTH INTO
THAT AND THEN THE- FAMILY
MEMBER OF A PERSON DETAINED AT
THE IMPERIAL REGION A DETENTION
FACILITY. SELECT RECORDS ONE
THAT THE DAY IN. A PARADE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INABILITY
TO PRACTICE SOCIAL THAT THING
INSIDE THE PRISON. HOW WE
COMMUNITY. COMMITTEE STAGE ROLE.
THE BAY AND THAT MAKE WITHIN
THE ORDER COMMUNITY. BY
CONTINUING TO TRANSFER
COMMITTEE MAY THE STATE JAILS
IN PRISONS THANK YOU. DETENTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE YOUR PART TO. WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE. WE
CERTAINLY DO WILL GO TO LIE
NUMBER FOR THREE LAW AND THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER CONNIE DELGADO
ONLY HAPPEN DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP CORE REPRESENTING
DISTRICT I MEAN AT THE
HOSPITAL- SENATORS WE
APPRECIATE THE GREAT DISCUSSION
ON THE PROGRAM THAT CAN IMPACT
AND COMMUNITY THE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO BORDER. WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU
AND OTHER MEMBERS ON HOW WE CAN
<c.red>ELP OUR DISTRICT HOSPITALS</c>
WHETHER THE PANDEMIC COOLEY
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU I
WILL GO TO THE NEXT BAKER NOW.
OUR NEXT CALLER'S FROM WHY
NUMBER THIRTY THREE LINES THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
AND MANY MANY MANY CRESSMAN AND
I'M AN ORGANIZER WITH HI MISTER
DETENTION ASSISTANCE AND- WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE QUESTION
ABOUT COLLISION OF PEOPLE
DETAINED AT THE TIME. WE
RECEIVED CALLS FROM PEOPLE TO
PAY THAT ENTIRE THING WERE TOLD
THEY WOULD RECEIVE A SAFE MASK
ONLY IF THEY FIND A LIABILITY
WAIVER. SOMEONE INCLINED AT THE
WAIVER THE PHONE. INDEED
INCLUDED ABOUT HOLDING OF THE
ONE. EVEN TOOK MY TO TIME WITH
ONLY ONE BUT IN A HELLO AND
DONATION WAS YOU. QUESTION
BECAUSE THE FOR PROFIT COME
PUTTING THE PEOPLE DETAINED ARE
IN HIGH COMMUNITY AND REST. MY
WILL CRY PRIVATE PRISON
OPERATOR THE COUNTER FOR THE-
THING CALLED WHICH- DASH. INTO
FAR GOVERNOR THEM AS A YOU FOR
TO DO. WE NEED CAL. TEMPERATURE
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WHICH MEANS
HOLDING THE COMPANY. HOPING
FROM STATE. TO PUT. IN THE-
FACILITIES AND HOPE EXTRA OF
THE FACILITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO OUT TO THE CALL.
OUR NEXT CALL SO MY NUMBER
FORTY TWO LINES DOORS LINE IS
OPEN. WELL WHATEVER. OUR I BY
FAR AS I BEEN MEMBERS ENSURE
THAT HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE I MEAN
OVER THE NEXT TO GO EITHER BY.
AFTER KNOW MEDICAL. OR WHY NOT
YOU ARE HOSPITALS YOU DON'T
NUMBER AGAIN THE COUNTY. NUMBER
I KNOW THAT'S NOT A QUESTION
YOU GUYS. AFTER TODAY BUT I'M
HOPING THAT MAYBE CAN GET BACK
I. CALIFORNIA THAT LIKE NOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND THE WE
KIND OF UP TO RESPOND A WE'RE
GOING TO UP TO TRY TO THAT IN
FOR SO IF YOU WANNA COMMUNICATE
WITH MY OFFICE TO. WE COULD
PROBABLY A- IN GETTING THAT A-
FOR YOU THANK YOU FOR. HOW DO
WE HAVE THE NEXT PAUL. YES NEXT
COLOR COME FROM NUMBERS TWO
THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON- DONE A
NUMBER OF THE ONLY CALIFORNIA
MY QUESTION IS WORSE FREMONT
AND- ON THE WHILE THE UPPER BY
THEN WE CAN ONLY A- THE P. H.
ALL BY THE MORE WITHIN THE YEP
WITH BY THE HARDWARE. THAT IN
THE TOWN IN THE METAL A YOU
COMBINE EFFORTS ARE IN THE- OF
THIS AND THAT CLEARLY. ONE OF
MY EYES IS THE FEDERAL. THE ALL
THESE. OF UP SO I'M GOING TO.
THE MORTGAGE AT THE JEWISH.
ESSENTIAL WORKERS CONCERN ABOUT.
WHAT KLAY SHOULD. ARE WE- THAT
THE BE SOMEONE. FEDERAL LEVEL
THE MOTION A AND ALSO WONDER AB
THAT YOU TO STEP UP. SO DO YOU
TO BE IN THE CAR. YOU KNOW THE
GOING ON COMMEMORATE MEXICO YOU
BORDER TRADE HERE FROM. BUT
OVER HERE IT ALL THE WHILE YOU
KNOW THE ABOUT AN EARLY ALONG
INTERVIEWS. AND WE ARE HERE IN
THE BORDER WE GIVE LOOKING.
THAT AND THEN THE GRAY DISOBEY
YOU VERY AND BY THE- AND TO THE
PARTY IS ADAM OF BRING MATTER.
AND THE- HM HAVE YOU CHECKED
THANK YOU THE YOU VERY COMMON
SIR YOUR COMMENTS BUT NEXT CALL.
NEXT CALL FROM WHY FORTY LINE
FOR OR IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
HAMID BONHAM THEM BY OF DEFEND
ADVOCATE AS KATE CLARK MEANT.
WE NOW HAVE CALLED OUTBREAK AT
TWO TO FACILITY THAT BORDER ONE
OF THE OUTBREAKS AS ONE OF THE
LAW IN THE NATION. I THINK IT'S
WORTH IT THAT ONE DO SO ARE
OVER RUN BY COLD BILL OVER THE
LOW HOT AND A LOT OF OUR OF
BUDGET NIXON. REPRESENT PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK I ALSO WANTED TO
JUST CALM ON THAT- THE COMMENT
THAT WAS MADE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ SAYING THAT THESE
FACILITIES ARE NOT WITHIN OUR
PURVIEW- IF YOU ACTUALLY. TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE FACT
THAT THESE FACILITIES ARE RUN
BY FOR PROFIT CONTRACTORS WHO
ROUTINELY VIOLATE THE TERMS OF
THE CONTRACT. YALLA ONCE THEY
ARE. OF THE TERM OF THE
CONTRACT THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
STATE REGULATION IN ADDITION TO
HAVE THE EXPLICIT AUTHORITY. TO
REGULATE AND INSPECT THE
CONDITIONS INSIDE THE
FACILITIES EXPLOSIVELY UNDER AB
ONE OH THREE. INTERNET GENERAL
HAS THE RIGHT. TO INSPECT THE
FACILITIES SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT- IN ADDITION TO. WHAT'S IN
THE CONTRACTS THESE PRIVATE
OPERATORS ARE ACTUALLY MANDATED
BY ICE. TO DEVELOP- MEDICAL
PLAN DOT ORG COORDINATED WITH
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN DOING UNTIL NOW. TO
ONCE AGAIN IF WE'RE GOING TO
SECURE THE STATE IF WE'RE GOING
TO DEAL CO IN NINETEEN THERE
HAVE TO BE A PLAN IN PLACE IN
WHICH WE- DO REGULATE THESE
FACILITIES. AND THE FOR PROFIT
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE RUNNING
THEM AND WHEN THEY VIOLATE
CALIFORNIA LOG THE HAPPY
CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. WE HAVE A SPEAKER HERE
IN THE GET. UP. YOUR NAME. SAY
MY NAME UP THE STATE YOUR THANK
YOU I GUESS THIS PLEX IS
PROTECTING ME FROM SOMETHING
VERY SCARY AND DANGEROUS SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT EVEN THOUGH
THIS ROOM APPEARS TO BE EMPTY
MY NAME IS EVERY HAD STORM AND
I HAVE NO AFFILIATION. OTHER
THAN I'M A CONCERNED PERSON
HERE IN IN CALIFORNIA AND- I'M
STANDING HERE BECAUSE IT IS MY
OPINION THAT. EACH LEGISLATOR
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT NEEDS TO
DO THEIR OWN RESEARCH. AND THAT
DOESN'T MEAN MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
IT MEANS THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN BOUGHT AND
WE KNOW THIS. AND IF YOU WANT
THE TRUST OF THE PUBLIC YOU ALL
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
YOUR OWN ANALYSIS. NOT
MAINSTREAM MEDIA FOR INSTANCE
THE HOOVER INSTITUTE STUDY SAYS
THAT THERE'S THREE TIMES MORE
LIFE YEARS LOST FROM A LOCK
DOWN MEASURES THAN FROM COVE IT.
FROM THE DEPTHS OF DESPAIR
DELAYED MEDICAL PROCEDURES TEEN
SUICIDE WE'RE MEASURING THESE
THINGS NOT MAINSTREAM MEDIA YOU
ALL HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
YOUR OWN RESEARCH. YOU HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE PUBLIC
MORE CASES DOES NOT MEAN MORE
DEATH. YOU WORK FOR US WE THE
PUBLIC EXPECT YOU TO UP HOLD
YOUR AND OF THE BARGAIN. IS
THAT MY TIME YEAH YOU WHAT
YOU'RE- ONLY THEN HUESO THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR I'M SORRY TO
LEAVE THE BUILDING AND COME
BACK AND HAVE MY TEMPERATURE
JACK AND HOW MY CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATED BUT I'M HAPPY LET ME
AND BEHIND THE PLEXIGLAS.
CLEARLY IT'S KEEPING ME SAFE I
HOPE IT DOES HAVE A NICE RECESS
YOU TO MA'AM. NEXT IF WE COULD
GET TO THE NEXT SPEAKER ON THE
LINE. OUR NEXT SPEAKER WILL
COME FROM LINE NUMBER FORTY
FOUR LINE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON JACKI
INVOLVED WITH IMMIGRANTS AND
ADVOCATE- WITH RESPECT TO THE
ISSUE OF CROW COLLISION THAT
UNDER RUBIO RATE I WANTED TO
GET OUT BY JUST TACKLING. THESE
FACILITIES. ARE IMMIGRATION
DETENTION FACILITY BUT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY OPERATED BY PRIVATE
OPERATORS ADD SOME OF MY-
COLLEAGUES IN PUBLIC COMMENT
HAD REYES. AND PRIVATE
CORPORATIONS HAVE
SYSTEMATICALLY ROUTINELY
ENGAGED IN PERPETUATING PERFECT
CONDITIONS BOTH THE TEAMS AND
THE- ISSUE THAT I'M NOT GOING
ON THE- EXACERBATED WITH COLD.
AT NIGHT. AND THERE ARE VERY
CLEAR GUY THAT WE COULD REACH
ARE SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW. I'M TO
PRINT KNOWN. FOR HEALTH AND
EIGHTY WHAT THEY- THEM USING
VIOLENCE COLOR YOU AS ON WITH
CLARK TESTIFIED TO EARLY IN.
PRESENTATION AFTER NO A OF THE
FOR THE HE AND WHAT THEY DO THE
THEY'RE ACTING OUT. OF THEIR
FEDERAL CON. FILL IT ABSOLUTELY
OUR PURVIEW REGULATE FEES
CORPORATION. ADD ACCOUNTABILITY
AND MY ABILITY WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE TO PROTECT PEOPLE
NEED. MUCH IN THE MANNER FOR
EXAMPLE THAT WE LATEST. FOR
ELDERLY FOLKS TO TEACH A
PRIVATELY RUN THIRTEEN CONCORD
HEALTH SORRY I'M IN THE COUNTRY
AND I'M OF THE RENTER'S. WE
DON'T TURN A BLIND EYE TO THAT
CONCENTRATED VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
CHARACTER IN. SO WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT COMBATING THE
TIRES. LEFT BREAK A COLLECTIVE
EFFORT. WE BELIEVE IT'S
REPUGNANT- TO BE THE NUMBERS
ARE OUR POPULATION BEHIND IT
ALL AND OUR SELF INTEREST. WE
KNOW THAT THE SPREAD OF COOLEY
NINETEEN AT OLD PAYMENT THAT
AFFECT THE BORDER RIGHT NOW BUT
LIKE SO MANY ISSUES THAT BEGIN
AT THE BORDER THEY HAVE LARGER
IMPLICATIONS ARE EIGHTY. I WANT
TO THANK. ESPECIALLY AMERICAN.
HUESO FOR COLD BECAUSE JOINT
HEARING AND THEIR CREDIT. APPS
ON. THE WORK IN NINETEEN ON THE
CARD. ON THE ISSUE THINKING
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANOTHER
SPEAKER IN THE LAW. YES LOCAL
I. NUMBERS FOUR LINE FOR YOU
LINES SO. CAN YOU HEAR ME MY
NUMBER WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW GO
AHEAD. OKAY HI HI MY NAME'S
YOU'RE RIGHT AND I. WAR ON ICE
YEAH. BOB I WANT. I YOU'RE
FADING OUT OF THE CALL OF THE
CALL WE HEARD YOU LOUD AND YOU
START TO FADE FADING OUT NOW I
CAN'T HEAR YOU SO. OKAY CAN YOU
HEAR ME BETTER NOW YEP YOU SOME
NICE NOW. OKAY SHARKS. I'M KILL
RILEY AND I AND SAYING THAT
THERE'S FIFTY THOUSAND
VULNERABLE PEOPLE ELDERLY AND
DISABLED PEOPLE THAT ARE ON ARE
YOU TO TEST IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER FIFTY THOUSAND WORKERS
WHO TAKE CARE OF THEM AND- THEY
BEAT WORKERS CO. OP FROM- YOU
KNOW MEXICO TO THE UNITED
STATES. AND ARE. YOU KNOW
REGULARLY SOME OF THEM AND WE
NEED TO HAVE. A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WILL CASH. DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY WORKERS. BY TO
ASK AND THEY'RE ALREADY IN WITH
PMS WHICH IS A FEDERAL AGENCY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND DOT EDS BAD. AND
THEIR LOCAL COUNTY SO WE'RE
ALREADY IN CONTACT WITH ALL
THOSE AGENCIES YOU COULD EASILY
YOU TESTING OF BOTH THE STATE
AND THE WORKERS WITH YOUR CARE
GIVERS THAT. WIDE WORKERS AND
THEY'RE PAID AROUND MINIMUM
WAGE MOST OF THEM DON'T HAVE
HEALTHCARE. AND SO- IF YOU
COULD NOT DO A PILOT PROGRAM
ONLY. A GO AN IMPERIAL OUT
WHERE YOU PUT IN FUNDING. FOR
OUR- HE AND TEXTING AND WHAT
THE BAND OF WOULD BE. OUT
THERE'S OUT YOU KNOW I'M TWO
COULD THOUSAND OF HONORABLE
PEOPLE THAT ARE. ABILITY ON
TRADE STAND DOC BUT I'D YOU
LATER PLAN YOU FOR KINDS OF.
NEED TO UNDERTAKE CARE OF BY
THE FRONT LINES. WHICH I CARE
GIVERS BETTER EXPLORE. THAT GO
NOT GET PROPER PAID THERE
ALWAYS AROUND MINIMUM WAGE AND
THEY'RE ALWAYS. APPLE NUMBER ON
YOUR YOUR OVER THIRTY OVER YOUR
A LOT OF TIME SHE COULD JUST
WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS. OKAY SO
I'M JUST HOPING THAT YOU COULD
GET SHOT A PILOT PROGRAM NOT.
CONCENTRATING ON THE MST
VULNERABLE AND ALSO IF YOU
COULD GET OUR CHILDREN AND
IMMIGRANTS OUT OF CAGES AND
BEING DETAINED THAT WOULD ALSO
HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER CALLER ON THE LINE. YES
A LITTLE AYE NUMBER FORTY ONE
LINE FOR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YOUR
HIGHNESS YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
CHRIS POWER WITHIN THE FOR
BANKING ATTORNEY AT THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
IT KNOWLEDGE IN THE CODE CRISIS
IN IMMIGRATION DETENTION
CENTERS I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE CRITICAL THING
THAT CAN HAPPEN RIGHT NOW IN
ORDER TO HOT CALIFORNIANS FROM
BEING FUNNELED INTO THESE
TERRIBLE FACILITY. ARE NOT JUST
I THOUGHT THE TRANSFERRING
PEOPLE TO THE DETENTION CENTER.
IT IS IN FACT THE STATE. IN
COOPERATION I'M AT THE COUNTY
JAIL AND STATE PRISON LOCAL
WITH ICE WE ARE VOLUNTARILY IN
ACTIVELY TRANSFERRING PEOPLE
FROM LOCAL IN STATE CUSTODY TO
THESE. FILE IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTER. I'M EVEN
BEFORE CO THAT ESPECIALLY
DURING PROGRAM IT REMAINS THE
PRIMARY WAY THAT THESE
FACILITIES A POPULATED. NOTABLY
THE OPERATIONS ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARILY. ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY
IT IS WITHIN THE STATE FORTY
EMPOWER TO HALT THE
CORPORATION. AND PRACTICES
ALREADY HAPPENED. IN SEVERAL
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER
WHAT WE NEED MORE THAN JUST
SELECT COUNTIES RIGHT TO THE
CHALLENGES SIMILAR TO THE
SHELTER HOME ORDERS WEEK WHAT
WE REALLY NEED IS A WHOLESALE
STOPPED ALL TRANSFERRED.
STATEWIDE ESPECIALLY UNDER COPE
AT NINETEEN AND SO WE TO- CASE-
THE STATE TO A HALT ALL ALREADY
TRANSFERRED AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVEL AND STOP OUR GOAL
AND FINALLY PEOPLE INTEGRATION
ATTENTION CENTERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER NOW. WE HAVE ACTUALLY
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
REPRINT. YES PLEASE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND JOHN ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PLACE YOURSELF IN
A QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
IS ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND IT
APPEARS WE MAY HAVE A COUPLE
MORE QUEUING UP PLEASE ALLOW
FEW MOMENTS REST PROVIDE LINE
NUMBERS. SO IF ANYONE IS
LISTENING WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
FROM YOU IF YOU. WANT TO CALL
IN IF YOU WANNA EXPRESS
YOURSELF NEXT COMMENTS. NOW IS
THE TIME- WEEKEND- OUR NUMBERS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. LINES ARE
OPEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO CALL THE
PARTICIPANT ACCESS CODE IS SIX
THREE SIX FOUR EIGHT ONE FIVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO WAY AND PLEASE
GIVE US A CALL WE'D LOVE TO
HEAR FROM YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE OUT AND WE DID IT. WE
DID HAVE A FEW MORE THAT HAVE
CUED UP I'M GONNA GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN. FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND FORTY
SEVEN CAN YOU CHECK YOUR LINE
FOR SELF MUTE FOR NOT HEARING
ANY AUDIO. OR NOT HEARING ANY
AUDIO ON THAT LINE SONG IN A
RELEASE THAT ONE THERE CAN FEEL
FREE TO REAP QUEUE UP IF THEY
SO CHOOSE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
RIGHT NOW. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
JUST. YES MY NAME IS MARGARET
BAKER AND I'M WITH SAKE PEOPLE
COLOR IN THE MIDST OF THE I'M
PRESIDENT OF GLOBAL CALL THE
NINETEEN AND THEN MAKE.
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUING TO
FUNNEL IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE RELEASED FROM
LOCAL AND STATE CUT TO THE- IT
TOO I. DETENTION FACILITIES
WHERE THE VIRUS IS SPREADING
RAPIDLY IN AN UPDATED BASED
TRANSFERS ICE NOT ONLY
JEOPARDIZED THE LIVES OF THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THEY ALSO UNDERCUT. THE STATE
HARD FOUGHT EFFORTS TO FLATTEN
THE CURRENT REDUCE THE HEALTH
RISKS OF THIS HIGHLY
TRANSMISSIBLE VIRUS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SO WE ARE CALLING
ON THE GOVERNOR AND OUR
LEGISLATORS IN THE STATE TO
SUSPEND TRANSFERS TO AND
EXPANSION OF IMMIGRATION
DETENTION FACILITY WHEN
IMMIGRANT MEMBERS INCLUDING
GREEN CARD HOLDERS AND
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE RELEASED FROM
LOCAL JAIL AND STATE PRISON
RATHER THAN BEING REALLY SEVEN
BEING HANDED OVER TO AYE OR
PRIVATE SUBCONTRACTORS TO BE
TRANSFERRED INTO IMMIGRANT
DETENTION FOR DETENTION
PURPOSES. NEEDS MEMBERS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR RELIEF FROM LOCAL
JAILS AND PRISONS WHEN THEY
COMPLETE THEIR SENTENCES AND
RECEIVE A CONNOTATION FROM THE
GOVERNOR FOURTEEN A CALL
GRANTED BY THE POLITICAL HERE
YOU. REVIEWED BY THE GOVERNOR
SO OUR GOVERNOR HAS THE POWER
TO INDICT TRANSFERS WE ARE
CALLING ON HIM AND ARE
LEGISLATURE'S. LEGISLATORS TO-
SUPPORT IN THIS EFFORT JUST
SUSPEND ALL TRANSFERS TO AND
EXPANSION OF IMMIGRATION
DETENTION PRESENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING AND FOR YOUR
COMMENTS DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
CALLERS ON THE- ON THE LINE.
YES TOTAL WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY NINE NINE FOUR
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR. CITIZENS THANK YOU
FOR. HAVING THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE SPRING AREN'T TO ME I LIVE
IN CENTRAL ONE LARGEST BREEDER
CYNICAL COUNTY. IS ONE OF STATE
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST BREAK A
CONSTRUCTION. TRAVELING HAVE
YOU SAID EARLIER IN THE
COMMITTEE. I ALSO THINK THAT
KERRY. PEOPLE ARE WITHOUT MASS
PEOPLE ARE GOING. AND PLACES
SOUGHT CARS MORE CAN BE.
ACTUALLY CLOSER JUST-NEIGHBORHOOD CENTRO I THINK
PEOPLE ARE YOU NINETY PARTY'S.
LOOK THE HOLIDAYS BIRTHDAYS.
AND AFTER THERE'S GONNA BE A
MAJOR. BACON FACTORY I'M FOR
THE CHIU A THAT THERE YOU COULD
BE. FOR SPENT A HER. FROM THIS
IS A LACK IF WE DON'T ACT A
CURFEW. IT'S CAN I GET EM
WORSE. AND THAT IS WHAT I WANT
TO SPEAK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN LINE. AT ONE
MORE CURRENTLY IN Q. THAT'S
LINE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN LINE
FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I HAD MY
NAME IN OUR LOBBY LACK I AM A
REPRESENT THE SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS TODAY. AS
MENTIONED BY MANY OF THE
SPEAKERS THE PANDEMIC HAD
HIGHLIGHTED OUR CROSS BORDER
INTO THE INTERDEPENDENCY. WHICH
REQUIRES A HIGH LEVEL OF
COORDINATION TO OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE. THERE'S
OVER SEVERAL FACTORS WHICH CAN
ADVERSELY IMPACTED OUR
COMMUNITY. AT AND I'VE OUTLINED
THEM IN WRITTEN TESTIMONY WHICH
I SUBMITTED- BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME HERE I'LL JUST
MENTION ONE IN PARTICULAR. I'M
AND THAT'S THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS WOULD FOR
IMPLEMENTED AT THE BORDER AND
REMAIN AT PLAY. I'M GLAD YOU
REDUCED HOURS OF OPERATION AT
AND BLAME AT SEVERAL PORTS OF
ENTRY- HOWEVER. NEED THIS AND
IT WAS MENTIONED BY. MAYOR TO
TINA AND THEN AFTER THAT BUT IN
THE END I BETTY BUT THERE WAS
REDUCE THAT VEHICLE TRAFFIC IS
THAT PROMPTED TO REDUCE
OPERATIONS HOWEVER. AND THIS
LED TO INCREASE BORDER WAIT
TIMES AND WE KNOW THAT BORDER
WAIT TIMES CONTRIBUTE TO AIR
POLLUTION ENDANGERING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BORDER COMMUNITIES.
AND NOW AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
ON LINE CAUSES. FOR HIGHER
HIGHER RISK. CATION CODE.
RESTORING BACKING LEVEL OPERATE
AT THE BOY BUT ALSO ADVANCE THE
CAUSE OF THE CAN MAKE THE LAN
HE LAND COURT OF ENTRY A
PROJECT BY THE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL ARE CRITICAL AT TIME TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT AND ALSO AS
WE LOOK EACH RECOVERY EITHER
SIDE OF OUR BORDER CAN BE CAN
SUCCEED THE OHER FAILED I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK UP FOR YOU
HELLO IN THIS IMPORTANT.
HEARING AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AND
FOR- WAY IN AND GIVING US YOUR
COMMENTS PRITCHETT VERY MUCH
AND- KEEP UP THE GREAT WORK
WITH CHAMBER DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE LINE. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE THAT JUST LATE CUED UP
WILL ALIGN NUMBER FIFTY ONE
LINE FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ADRIANA
COUNTERCULTURE WITH NEXT GEN
POLICY I WANTED TO FIRST TO ADD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN ADDRESSING. OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE BOTH
AS IT RELATES TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE BORDER AND
WHAT IS HAPPENING AND- OUR
DETENTION CENTERS- NEXT GEN
POLICY HAS BEEN AT WORKING
EXTREMELY HARD. TO GET THIS
ISSUE IN FRENCH I HAVE. HAD THE
LEGISLATURE SO AGAIN THANK YOU
WE'VE ALSO BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD WITH THE GOVERNOR I AND
BRINGING THAT- UP I'M- BAD AT
THE CRISES THAT IT IS- TO
ANSWER EACH MAJOR REITERATE-
THAT. WHAT WOULD AFFECT
AMERICANS DOLLARS WHETHER OR
NOT WE HAD GIRL JURISDICTION
AND I KNOW SOME OF OUR OTHER-
NONPROFIT- FOLKS THAT WERE ON
THE LINE COMMENTED ON THAT I'M-
NEXT GEN AT THE PARTY I'M A
BILL THAT ACTUALLY WOULD
ADDRESS. SOME OF THESE ISSUES
WHICH IS EIGHTY THREE TWO TWO
EIGHT AND SO. WE WANT TO CHAT I
WANTED. TO SHARE THAT AND-
THREE EIGHT OR EIGHT ARE
COMMITMENT TO THE ISSUE AND IN
A- IN ANY WAY WE CONTINUE TO BE
HELP TO BRING THEIR TO LIGHT.
AND I. GET TO. LUCIA THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CAN POLITICAL. THAT
ARE ALWAYS I LOOKED AT. AS
BEING NONESSENTIAL NOT
IMPORTANT I'LL BE TRIGGERING
THIS AFTER THE FOREFRONT- YOU
KNOW WE ARE IN THE FIGHT I AM
READY TO GO SO AGAIN. WE HAD
LET PHONE CENTER GONZALEZ WEEK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
OUT WITH BUT YOUR STAFF ON IT
CONTINUING TO BRING THIS ISSUE
TO LIGHT. HERE THANK APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND ONLY ONE
FOR. REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE IN
THESE IN THESE FACILITIES THAT
REALLY NEED. THE LIGHT SHINED
ON THESE THE PRACTICES THE THAT
ARE GOING ON THERE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. IN TODAY'S
HEARING AS WELL- ANYONE ELSE.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE ONLINE
NOW WE- HAVE ONCE AGAIN
EXHAUSTION SECURE AT THIS TIME
OKAY AND- WE'RE GONNA ASK
PEOPLE IF ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT TO PLEASE CALL IN AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THE
NUMBERS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOR THE
PARTICIPANT ACCESS CODE IS SIX
THREE SIX. FOUR EIGHT ONE FIVE.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE WELL PEOPLE ARGUING IN I
WANNA JUST A- FEW COMMENTS- TO
SOME OF THE COLORS ARE CALLED
IN- THERE WERE SOME QUESTIONS
ASKS AND IT AND IF I CAN GET
THE INFORMATION I FEEL IT'S MY
RESPONSIBILITY PROVIDED IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE HAVE- SOMEBODY
ASKED ABOUT THE NUMBER. OF A
TEST IN SENEGAL COUNTY. FROM
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GATHER- FIRST OF ALL SO NEW
COUNTY DOES NOT REQUIRE
SYMPTOMS TO GET A TEST. SO
ANYONE THAT WANTS TO TEST COULD
GO TO ANY OF THE TESTING
FACILITIES AND GET A TEST. AND
WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IF THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO TO
DO THAT- SO WE CAN IN A THE-
GET IT IS. TO GET AN ACCURATE
COUNT ALSO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
ARE QUARANTINING IF THEY NEED
TO BE. THIS EIGHT BILLION
AVERAGE. INSTEAD COUNTY OF TO.
PERFORMED THAT IS- THOUGH THE
NUMBER I'M GIVEN IS VERY
SPECIFIC NUMBER. SEVEN THOUSAND
EIGHTY TWO BUT I IMAGINE IT'S
JUST- SLIGHTLY. ABOVE SOUTH
SEVEN THOUSAND PER WEEK. OF THE
TESTS ARE ACTUALLY BEING
CONDUCTED. IN CENTER CENTER
COUNTY IF I'M NOT CORRECT- IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN I MEAN. OKAY
SO. IS THAT AN ACCURATE NUMBER
OKAY IT IS AN ACCURATE NUMBER-
ALSO- REGARDING THE TRANSFERS
WE HAVE AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TAKING THE LEAD ON THE ON END
IN THE TRANSFER ISSUE AND I'M
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF THAT I
SIGNED ON TO THE LETTER AND
HOPEFULLY THOSE TRANSFERS WHAT
IT IS WITHIN THE POWER OF
CALIFORNIA TO EXERCISE
AUTHORITY TO LIMIT THOSE
TRANSFERS ARE IN THEM AND I'M A
PROPONENT OF THAT AND HOPEFULLY
THAT WOULD HAPPEN IN OUR STATE
SOON. TO HELP PROTECT NOT ONLY
THAT AT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE OF THOSE INVOLVED BUT
THE OF THE PEOPLE THAT HANDLE-
THAT POPULATION AS WELL VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE FALLING IN TWO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER COLORS IN THE
QUEUE. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
WELL- WE'RE GONNA WRAP A PER
SESSION I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR
COLLEEN AND FOR THOSE SELTZER
CAME IN PERSON. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION YOUR
COMMENTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
US. WE ALSO. WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS A SPECIAL TANK THANKS
TO CENTER GONZALEZ FOR THE- HER
JOINING US WITH HER SELECT
COMMITTEE AND TO THE MEMBERS.
OF THE PUBLIC FOR MAKING TIME
TO ATTEND THE SYRIAN. SPECIAL
APPRECIATION FOR THE SPEAKERS
AND GUESS WHO TRAVELED TO BE
HERE. AND THOSE THAT TOOK TIME
FROM THE DAY TO HELP US
INFORMED PUBLIC AS BEST WE CAN.
WE'RE DOING OUR BEST YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA AND- WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED. ABOUT EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING RELATED TO
THIS ISSUE IN THE IMPACT IT'S
HAVING ONE WHERE ANOTHER. AS
YOU CAN SEE THERE ARE ARE WILL
NO MATTER WHAT WE DO WITH IT.
THERE ARE THERE ARE OF VICTIMS
OF BOTH SIDES IN THIS IS JUST A
VERY. TERRIBLE TERRIBLE TIME.
THAT WE'RE ALL LIVING THROUGH
AND- I THINK IF WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER JOIN TOGETHER WE'LL
GET THROUGH IT. TOGETHER AND-
WHEN. THE FIGHT OVER THIS
PANDEMIC EVERYONE STAY SAFE WE
WISH YOU A VERY HAPPY. DAY AND
FOR ALL OF THOSE- CELEBRATING
THE FOURTH OF JULY THIS IS A
TIME TO CELEBRATE. THE BIRTHDAY
OF OUR NATION VERY PROUD TIME
BUT WE ALSO ASKED PEOPLE TO
EXERCISE CAUTION. AND TO BE
VERY CAREFUL AND TO PLEASE-
OBSERVE SOCIAL DISTANCE IN AN
ALL THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY AND A WONDERFUL
HOLIDAY COMING UP.